welcome to the captivating realm of
digital marketing where creativity
strategy and Innovation converge digital
marketing is a thrilling journey of
exploration mastering the art of
captivating audiences shaping brand
narratives and crafting impactful
campaigns with data driven insights and
developed consumer Behavior Mysteries
and fine-tune strategies for your target
audience unleash social media expertise
to Foster meaningful connections while
mastering search engine optimization for
heightened brand visibility from
engaging content to unlocking analytic
Secrets Empower businesses in the
digital age digital marketing offers a
thriving job market with numerous
companies actively seeking skilled
professionals roles include digital
marketing Specialists social media
managers SEO experts and more salaries
vary depending on experience and
location ranging from competitive
entry-level packages to lucrative pay
for experienced professionals if you are
looking to grab some such an opportunity
then unlock the path to success which
simply learns postgraduate program in
digital marketing gain in-depth
knowledge of search engine optimization
with this course will also learn content
marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
optimization and more unlock a whole
toolbox of skills including essay
ranking HootSuite Facebook Instagram
LinkedIn YouTube Twitter Google ads and
Keyword Planner don't miss out on this
opportunity Find the course link
mentioned in the description box for
more information and now here success
stories from our satisfied Learners in
their own words change is inevitable but
growth is optional
for me both came hand in hand
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learn present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University when I shifted to
Dubai from Sri Lanka in 2015 I joined a
group of company as a software engineer
but my interest in content creation
attracted me towards the marketing
industry intrigued by the marketing
functions I decided to take up a
challenge that would change my life
forever I aim for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with Purdue University acted as not only
a catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no profiting
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely
so I decided to upskill with the
professional certification program
I just simply learn because of its
tremendously High waiting to be rated as
one of the best Education portal online
worldwide is surely promising not only
were the ratings high but also the
courses were economically charged the
modules were very informative and
amazing I still refer to those while in
the final stage of my course I told my
Superior about the certification program
I was doing and they offered me a
digital marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive is that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confidence boost alongside numerous
other positive outcomes I had a chance
to take a challenge and change my career
domain all together
and I took it So currently I'm pursuing
masters of Masters program from Simply
learn where I would complete a Masters
program including artificial
intelligence cloud computing and devops
and many more growing requires moving
out of our comfort zones
keep learning keep growing greetings
everyone this is Rob Sanders and today
we're going to talk about what is
digital marketing so thanks for joining
us here at simply learn and let's get
started let's start talking about why
digital marketing is important so let's
start there on the why so if we're just
a fly on the wall and we're in an office
environment we're looking at two friends
having a conversation about digital
marketing so really if we're listening
in everybody every marketer is using
digital marketing for his or her
business now digit marketing has become
more popular than traditional marketing
that's not a surprise so in response hey
over the past few decades digital
marketing has evolved at a rapid Pace
these days a lot of people spend most
their time on the internet so what
happens in the internet every 60 seconds
well a lot happens every every 60
seconds so according to Social Media
today I mean there's a lot of snaps
there's a lot of clicks there's a lot of
text there's a lot of videos watched
there's a lot of pictures being taken
there's a lot of voice activated
activity going on a lot of tweets emails
swipes there's a lot going on here in 60
seconds so there's a lot of activity on
the internet a lot and so the one
gentleman says hey can you also mention
a few differences between digital and
traditional marketing systems and then
the expert responds of course I can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say what the differences
are between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper TV
anything that's not on on your mobile or
laptop so we know what traditional
marketing reaches limited with digital
marketing reaches maximum and what we
mean by that is hey when you print
something you're printed it for x amount
of people if you're trying to promote an
event and you basically create a
thousand Flyers okay you figure it's
going to a thousand people maybe it'll
share it so you're looking about 2 000
people maybe just to be generous well
digital marketing we're promoting an
event we can promote it to a whole lot
of people depending on the platform so
2000 is nothing when you're targeting an
audience on Facebook or Google search
traditional marketing non-versatile and
with digital marketing very versatile so
again going back to our flyer printing
an eight and a half by eleven okay
that's it you know with with digital
marketing running display banners you
have 468 by 60 200 by 200 250 by 250 300
by 300 I mean and the list goes on on
the types of different display sizes not
to mention text ads not to mention video
or multimedia so there's a lot you can
do to get your message out there okay
with traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so meaning if you're
trying to get that TV spot there might
not be a spot open until one in the
morning okay well with digital marketing
there is no hours okay you can certainly
get your point out there and have people
see it instantaneously so with
traditional marketing there's a lack of
real-time results I mean this seems like
uh it's obvious but you know digital
marketing that's one of the biggest
benefits instant real-time results
instant okay nowadays we're going to
analytics you can look at real time
reporting okay so we could see real time
results okay traditional marketing can
be very costly I mean if you're not only
doing postcards and printing postcards
cards but you have to mail those
postcards so there's postage fees we're
with digital marketing it's very very
very cost efficient I mean meaning you
could pick and choose who you want to
Target when you want to Target where you
want to Target what you want to Target
and if you're doing search you can put
your bidding in place you can put your
hours in place you can really control
how much you actually spend so that's
amazing one of the biggest advantages to
digital marketing not only do you get
real-time results but you can control
costs and then obviously optimize based
on the amount of cost you're spending
based on those real-time results
traditional marketing it's difficult to
reach a target audience you know with
digital marketing it's easy to reach a
target audience I mean you know I don't
want to bash traditional marketing too
much I mean if you're gonna put a TV ad
in place you know you're going to do it
on a TV show that tends to gear more
towards your target audience but that
doesn't guarantee anything here we can
simply go to Facebook book or Twitter or
LinkedIn and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to Target when
we want to Target them so it just
becomes a lot easier to reach a targeted
audience on a digital marketing platform
and then with traditional marketing Port
campaign measurement with digital you
have easy to measure and optimize
campaigns and what we really mean by
that is because you get instant time
results because you can control costs
because you can reach your target
audience more easily although as a
result of okay you can measure and
optimize based on what our audience is
seeing and how much they're spending to
see it we can quickly make adjustments
in order to optimize the campaign for
better performance so that's generally
what that means that's a culmination of
pretty much everything that we've listed
as a benefit for digital marketing okay
so now why digital marketing has been
answered with all the benefits that it
carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so you know that you
know you want to do digital marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just Define it
digital marketing it's just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device and we
talk about technology it could be an app
it could be you know a cloud-based
platform okay it could be a piece of
software okay so a lot going on on the
digital side in terms of variations and
what you can do but that's in a nutshell
what digital marketing is you're really
just using technology to promote your
product or service so we know because of
the benefits in digital marketing you
can promote your campaign on different
platforms okay so all those benefits we
mentioned about instant real-time
results cost efficiency optimizing
campaigns you could do that on search
you could do it on social via email on
mobile apps Etc so that's what we mean
by with the help of digital advisors and
Technology well these digital devices
and Technology come in the form of
search engines and emails and mobile
apps Etc so I already mentioned a few
examples based on the use as a digital
marketing I mentioned Google's Display
Network I mentioned YouTube and blogging
and social media platforms like Facebook
well there are lots of different types
of digital marketing channels out there
and we're going to talk about a few of
them today we're going to start with
search engine optimization and so search
engine optimization as you probably know
from the name involves search engine and
it involves really making your site
relevant in the eyes of that search
engine so if you're in the United States
you know that Google has a large market
share remaining a lot of people use
Google on a daily basis so we want to
make sure we do everything we can to
optimize our site in order to make our
site relevant for those coveted keywords
now why do we want to make ourselves
relevant for those coveted keywords that
we want to be found for on search well
because a lot of people use search and
when a lot of people use search and
you're found for those keyword queries
then it's going to increase the flow of
organic traffic to your website so the
higher you rank in theory the more
traffic you're going to get and so when
we talked about optimization okay how do
we optimize our site in order to be
relevant in the eyes of Google well it
really comes down to a two-pronged
approach you have on-page SEO you have
off-page SEO on-page has everything to
do with your website in order to make it
relevant off page has everything to do
with your website but not on your
website it means that how can we become
relevant by linking to other websites
for example how can we become relevant
by getting our content on other
platforms so we become relevant in the
eyes of Google so that's off page SEO so
SEO is always going to be two-prong what
you do on your website and what you do
off the website to make sure your
website your domain whatever that domain
is.com or dot org is relevant in the
eyes of Google and so let's take a look
at on page SEO first so like I mentioned
it involves optimizing your website and
when we say optimizing your website
there's a lot of things you can do on
your website to make it relevant in the
eyes of Google and we can look at the
content okay we can look at the source
code and so there are a lot of different
components to be looked at here so you
have the header tag you have the meta
description you have the alt tag you
have how fast your page load codes you
have internal linking you have a site
map you have lots of different things
going on here and so for me one of the
first things you should do when you
create a page on your website is to make
sure the title tag is unique and
includes those keywords so if we look
here at this example the title tag is
important because that's what shows up
in search results here you can see the
title tag on Google is up to 65
characters so you always want to include
that keyword in the title tag then you
have your URL and then you have what you
call a meta description so that's
underneath the URL underneath the title
tag and again this is in search results
so organic search results somebody types
in a keyword you want to be found and
you want your title tag to stick out and
you want your meta description to
specifically describe what it is you're
offering okay so again if somebody's
looking for stock imagery then you want
to make sure that you know that person
who's looking for stock imagery can come
to your website and they can in this
case search for millions of royalty free
stock images photos videos and music and
so you want your description to really
get that person to click on your listing
an organic search that's the whole point
so that's the point of a title tag and a
meta description is you really want to
be found for what somebody's searching
for and you want to be able to show them
that you have what they're looking for
you have something here underneath your
organic search results called sitelinks
and site links are just other or links
to pages on your website and so
unfortunately this is not necessarily in
your control this is in the control of
Google so if Google wants to offer up
site links underneath your title tag
amount of description they will add them
and it's based really on the amount of
content you have and that goes with site
search so you can see also there's site
search there underneath the meta
description all of that is contingent
upon your website do you have a lot of
content and if you have a lot of
relevant content then Google will
naturally add in site links underneath
your organic listing to links to other
pages on your site so that's on page SEO
and now we're going to look at off-page
SEO okay so off page SEO involves using
promotional methods Beyond just
optimizing your site for example
optimizing your title tag in my
description might not be enough to get
you to rank for that coveted keyword
query so we need to do some link
building we need to get our name out
there on other websites okay so we need
to be able to establish some external
links or backlinks from high quality
relevant sites to our site and it may
not just necessarily have to be a link
because Google recognizes linkless
backlinks so just having a reference on
a high quality site may be good enough
to get you in the eyes of Google to
become more relevant okay so that's off
page SEO in definition so really what we
want to do is we want to establish a way
to get links from other websites to our
own or references on other websites to
our website we want to build those links
to help us gain in ranking so there's
lots of ways to do that you have social
media again you have social content
sites like Reddit medium quora you have
blogging okay there's lots of ways to
establish yourself out there on the
internet you just need to make sure the
quality sites and you need to make sure
they're relevant and so when you do get
a link on an external site pointing back
to yours you want to make sure it's a
follow so you want to make sure that
Google knows to follow that link from
that site to yours so if you're out
there establishing content on a
third-party website or another website
and they're going to link back to you
just make sure that it's a follow do
follow not a no follow okay and I'm
going to show you an example of what
that looks like here so if you're not
sure what the difference is here I'm on
backlinko.com and really a no follow
versus a do follow is simply in the href
so in the href if you don't have
anything in there other than the link
then the search engines are going to
follow that link from that external site
to yours and if you have a nofollow in
that link then the search engines are
going to ignore the link so you're not
going to pick up the backlink or
external link to your site and that's
simply that site just adding the real
equals nofollow Okay so if you see that
in the link pointing to your site from
that external site then that means
you're not going to get credit for that
backlink so you always want to shoot for
a do follow link because that means
you're going to get credit for the
backlink okay so again do follow links
allow searching and crawlers to follow
the link and if they can follow it
you're going to get what they call link
juice and that's going to establish some
reputation to your domain a nofollow
link basically doesn't allow the search
engines to follow that link so it
doesn't pass on the link juice now again
search engines like Google are smart
enough to pick up the association
between a website that talks about your
website and your website so meaning if
you don't have a link and you don't have
a if you have a nofollow link on that
site don't fret because you know Google
has come a long way they're not just
necessary focused on lengths though it
does help so for example if you are on a
very prominent site and there's no link
then you still may get credit because
Google does recognize linkless backlinks
and that's what they call a linkless
backlink is just having a reference on
that site but you always want to try and
get that follow not the do not follow
okay so here you can see an example of
off-page SEO okay like TripAdvisor would
be a good example a link that redirects
from TripAdvisor to you know the Oprah
Magazine as an example so the Oprah
Magazine is going to get a a back link
from TripAdvisor to the site so if
Google crawls TripAdvisor then they're
going to be able to see this link and if
it's a follow link they're going to give
the Oprah Magazine that domain credit
from TripAdvisor so for SEO because
there's a two-pronged pro approach
involved you have on page and off page
there's a lot of tools here a lot of
tools so let's take a look at some of
these tools we're going to look at
Google Keyword Planner we're going to
look at Moz ahrefs we'll get some tools
that will help you with both on page and
off-page SEO so let's start with
Google's Keyword Planner so why are we
using Google's Keyword Planner because
we want to find keywords okay so we
can't do on-page SEO we can't optimize
our title tag and meta description
without a good keyword that we want to
be found for so what we want to do is we
want to go into Google ads now that's a
pay-per-click platform okay so if you
want to be found via paid search you're
going to use Google ads but form an
organic search perspective we can use
Google's Keyword Planner so we need a
Google ads account we have a Google ads
account then all we need to do is go to
tools then we need to go to Keyword
Planner and the keyword plan Banner is a
good tool because it allows us to find
those coveted keywords so we can
discover new keywords and that's exactly
what we're going to do so for example
we're going to find you know use the
keyword mail delivery if we have a
business that delivers mails to people
what keywords do we want to optimize for
so we're going to be in Google ads we're
going to go to go to tools we're going
to go to Keyword Planner we're going to
discover new keywords and we're simply
just going to type in a keyword so we're
going to click get results and Google's
Keyword Planner is basically going to
give us some information so the keyword
we chose was mail delivery and they're
telling us that on average over the last
12 months there's 22 200 search queries
on average over the last 12 months okay
so I could see if I click hover over the
graph here I'm going to be able to see
the the average over 12 months okay so
here I could see the average over 12
months from July to June 2019. so here
what do I want to do I want to look for
Trends because you here I could see the
averages go up and down a little bit but
22 200 is the average over 12 months and
then Google's Keyword Planner also tells
me how competitive that keyword is so if
it's highly competitive but it's got a
lot of search volume it could be a
keyword I may want to cover it but the
beauty of the Keyword Planner is that
they also give you other keywords to
look at okay so mail delivery service is
49 500 okay so here you got some other
ones best food delivery service
9900 again some of these are very
competitive but some of them aren't and
so you want to be able to do your due
diligence do some analysis and figure
out what keywords work best for you that
aren't going to be competitive but at
the same time give you some search
volume so if you do rank for that
keyword you should expect x amount of
clicks on that keyword based on the
volume so that's Google's Keyword
Planner alternatively you can use a tool
like moz.com so if I log into Moz we
have a tool called keyword Explorer and
so here I can just type in that same
keyword meal delivery targeting the
United States in English and Moz is
going to give me some information on the
keyword so here they're going to give me
a range in terms of the monthly volume
and they're going to give me a
difficulty score so they're going to
tell me how difficult this keyword is so
out of a score of 100 it's 53 and
they're going to tell me what my
expected click the rate could be if I'm
ranking for that keyword more
importantly they're going to give me
some other keyword suggestions just like
Google Keyword Planner so here I can see
prepared mail delivery mail delivery
service mail delivery companies so there
are a lot of different suggestions of
keywords that I can choose from and if
we scroll down we could see basically
some Mansions we could see the analysis
who's ranking for these keywords so we
can really get some insight as to who's
ranking how much volume how difficult it
is what my estimates could be if I'm
ranking Etc so a lot of information
built into moz's keyword Explorer tool
so Moz is keyword Explorer tool could be
a good option for you if you don't have
access to Google ads and Google's
Keyword Planner so if you're working on
SEO for a website and you curious is
about what the off-page SEO situation
looks like well you can use a tool like
age prefs it's free tool you can go here
if you're working on a specific domain
and you're focused on off page you can
simply type type in that domain here and
then you can check the back links for
that domain okay so I'm gonna go ahead
and type in my new net my domain and now
I'm going to get a sense of what my
backlink profile is for my domain so
here I can see the number of back links
the total backlinks and notice 85
percent of them are do follow links so
Google is able to recognize those links
and then I could see referring domains
so I have a 124 different domains
pointing to my website and so here I can
get a snapshot of the top 100 backlinks
pointing to my website and so this just
gives me a snapshot of what's going on
with my off page SEO performance again
it's a free tool it's good to use
because it gives you an idea of what
your off-page SEO situation looks like
okay another tool you could use is ping
them okay you can set up a free trial
here it's good for 14 days and it allows
you to you know look at page speed it
allows you to monitor the site itself in
terms of you know visitors maintenance
Etc so you can use pingdom as well uh
however it's only a 14 day free trial
but it does give you some good insights
into SEO now page load time is one of
those on page SEO factors and so if
you're doing on-page SEO for domain you
certainly want to go into Google
analytics and you want to measure the
page load performance of the pages on
your website and so here if I go to
Google analytics and then I go to
behavior and I go to site speed and I go
to speed suggestions here I can see the
pages how many pages I've received over
a period of time and then the average
page load time now now if you see the
average page load time is slow and in my
opinion anything over two to three
seconds is going to be slow you need to
be able to take action and so the great
thing about Google analytics the page
load time reporting is it actually gives
you some suggestions so page speed
suggestions so all you need to do is
click on the link here in this case this
particular link or URL on my website has
seven suggestions if I click on that
then page speed insides is going to open
up and what's going to happen is Google
analytics slash paid speed insights is
going to analyze this page and give me
some feedback on how the page is
performing not only on desktop but on
mobile as well and so here I can see if
I analyze this page I can see some of
the opportunities to improve the page
load time on desktop and again on mobile
here so here you can see a lot of the
opportunities and a lot of the issues I
have that I can address now if you're
going to manage seo4 website then you're
going to need an SEO platform so again
Moz is a good example because we showed
you the keyword Explorer but they also
have many other tools available built
right into the platform for example
rankings okay you can get crawl
information so when the Bots crawl aside
what kind of errors are coming up here I
can get some page optimization so I can
choose a keyword and I can choose a page
and Moz is going to be able to give me
feedback to see what more I could do to
improve my on page SEO performance okay
we mentioned keyword Explorer in terms
of looking for keywords okay you also
have something called link Explorer as
well so if I go back and choose link
Explorer from my list here then I'm
going to go to a link Explorer and I can
type in any domain again just like on
the hrefs except mods goes a little bit
deeper here okay so they're telling me
how many linking domains and where my
keywords are ranking okay and then I
have some other reports that I can
leverage for off-page SEO I can look at
spam scores for certain websites that
are linking to me because you can
disavow yourself from us being
associated with those sites here you got
a link intersect tool so you can compare
one domain against another to what
lengths are pointing to that other
website so a lot of different reports
and tools available to you for off-page
SEO under moz's link Explorer so Moz has
a lot of different tools available and
again my recommendation if you don't use
Moz there's sem rush there's bright Edge
there's a lot of SEO platforms out there
to is but if you're going to focus on
SEO you are going to need an SEO
platform now if you have any more
questions on SEO you feel free to go to
simplylearn's YouTube account you'll be
able to find a video there for SEO
tutorial for beginners you know take a
look at the video it goes really in
depth about everything we just covered
about on page and off-page SEO so take a
look at the video and if you have any
comments about everything we covered
with SEO feel free to comment underneath
this video here and we'll be sure to
respond accordingly especially if you
have any tips and tricks that you do for
SEO so let's move from search engine
optimization to content marketing and so
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves simulating interest in a
Brand's products or Services by creating
and sharing online material so when we
talk about online material that can come
in many forms or assets say some
examples are blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
ebooks all of this is content generated
it's just in different forms and so you
want to be able to take any one of these
forms of content and be able to
distribute that in some form or fashion
okay so for example a Blog can be part
of your website a video could be
something you upload to Youtube an
infographic could be something you
actually share on LinkedIn so all these
other assets could be integrated
throughout they could be shared or used
on your website okay for people to grab
and share and use and comment on okay so
that's what content marketing is you
need to be able to push out content so
that people have a better understanding
of your product or service the process
of content marketing is you really want
to decide what goal you want to she with
your content marketing campaign you want
to Define your buyer personas to
determine the audience best suited for
your content okay so what are you
creating who is it for and then you want
to run content on it to determine the
best type of content that can be used
and we talk about content audits we're
talking about you know content that's
already been posted are people sharing
it are people downloading are people
viewing it and so you want to be able to
understand over time what people are
reacting to so that you can reuse or
continue to use that content that seems
to resonate with your target audience so
you want to choose an appropriate
content management system so if it's a
Blog you want to use WordPress maybe so
you want to start brainstorming for
ideas for new content ideas so in my
opinion maybe put together a Content
calendar and jot some ideas on that
content calendar then you want to settle
on a particular type of content you want
to to create and then you want to be
able to publish and manage your content
so some top popular tools used for
Content marketing you have buffer you
have buzzsumo follower won cootsweep so
let's go ahead and take a look at an
example of a Content marketing
management system and we're going to use
WordPress and so if we go into WordPress
here on the back end we're logging a
login and so the reason why we use
WordPress is because we can post blogs
so in WordPress if I go to post here I'm
going to be able to see all the
different posts that have been posted
over a period of time and the great
thing about WordPress is you can
optimize it for SEO so if I go in here
and look at this recent blog post that
has been posted I can go ahead and edit
it and when I edit it okay I'm going to
be able to look at this blog post in a
visual format and I can also look at it
in HTML form so notice I the great thing
about WordPress is I can use imagery I
can insert videos I can insert
infographics I can attach a white paper
case study to it and then again we have
something called yoast SEO plugin so
we've installed a plug in here so
that'll help us with optimizing that
particular blog post for that particular
keyword we're trying to Target and so
here you can see our Focus keyword is
remarketing and retargeting okay so we
have that in the title tag okay we also
want to make sure it's in the meta
description and so here we have an
internal link we have it in the
introduction okay we have it you know
spread throughout the content so yoast
does a good job of allowing us to make
sure we're integrating that keyword into
our blog post but the key to blog
posting is we want to again follow the
process we want to be able to choose
content for our intended audience and in
this case with a blog post we can ride
up to you know 500 to 3000 keywords and
the whole point is we're trying to
introduce our audience to a particular
topic that resonates with our product or
service and so that's the great thing
about blogging that's the great thing
about WordPress is that you know it's
very easy to use uh you can integrate it
with SEO you obviously have commenting
you have different plugins that you can
add in there uh very easy to edit and so
there's a lot you can do here with
WordPress and blogging so another
example of content marketing is video so
with video you have the ability to
upload this video to popular video sites
like YouTube or video and you can
optimize is that particular video with
title tags and and hashtags and
descriptions and you could see the
interaction here so you can see how many
views how many likes shares the ability
to share the ability people for saving
it and there's just a lot of
interactivity when you have video you
can also use video as I mentioned on
your blogging platform if it's WordPress
you can also use video and social media
platforms like Twitter LinkedIn and
Facebook so video is a very popular form
of content marketing lots of good video
tools out there to create a video a high
quality video is what you want to put
your product service in the best
Forefront okay so that people can react
they can share they can comment they can
follow they can like okay so that's what
you want to do is think about video
because videos very versatile and
Powerful in terms terms of getting your
message out there so let's move from
content marketing to social media
marketing and social media marketing
really involves creating content if it's
that blog if it's that video that you
created for Content marketing and really
using different platforms to increase
your visibility whether that be traffic
whether it be engagement whether it be
brand awareness or any other marketing
goals that you have that's what social
media is good for because social media
will take that content take what you're
trying to get out there and really allow
you to hone your marketing goals against
that okay so if it's Facebook and you
got some videos that you want to post up
there okay what's your goal is your goal
to then post the video to get traffic to
your website or to build brand awareness
or to just get people to react by
sharing or liking and so that's what
social media is good for it's really
good for taking content and really
Distributing it to your target audience
okay so uh sharing content allows you to
you know generate user generated content
or it allows you to create interactive
content and again you can use
infographics or you can apply content
with imagery or post videos or do things
that are interactive like polling and
contests so a lot of flexibility in
terms of the content that you could
share on social media and so you want to
establish a process for social media
marketing so this is the digital
marketing course of it so you want to be
able to have a process and you want to
be able to set up goals that you want to
achieve with your social media campaign
because just posting content for
content's sake is really not going to
generate anything for you so you want to
set up those goals ahead of time then
you want to understand what content
would be best suited for your target
audience so if our goal is to generate
brand awareness then maybe an
infographic is what we want to do okay
maybe that's the best choice of asset
for our target audience based on the
platform with social media we also want
to research what the competition is and
find out what works for them so it's
very easy to do on social so if you
already have a competitor on Facebook
you can always go to your competitor's
website and you can always see you know
what they're posting and what kind of
reaction engagement they're getting for
a particular post so it doesn't help
before you go live to do some due
diligence about your competition you can
also conduct a social media audit and
again what we mean by audit just like on
the content side we want to be able to
see what's worked and what's not worked
in the past and with digital marketing
recall you can get instant metrics back
so if you've posted something last year
and you're thinking about posting it
again you probably want to do an audit
to see over the past year what posts
have worked and have not worked for you
then you want to pick and choose the
social media channels or platforms and
to find a strategy for each of them
because if you have a video then the
video may work on say YouTube or
Instagram but they not necessarily work
for LinkedIn and Twitter and so you want
to be able to pick and choose the asset
the strategy and align it with the
appropriate platform then you want to
take inspiration from case studies and
other famous Brands so again continue to
learn I mean that's the beauty of social
media marketing most big companies
medium-sized companies even smaller
companies that have performed well are
out on social media so take a look at
some other companies that inspire you or
some other companies in your industry or
even again your competitors and see what
they're doing and what they're posting
and what kind of Engagement they're
getting so should always you know be
able to seek out what others are doing
on social and to me this is important
create a social media content calendar
and this isn't necessarily the very end
of the process this goes back to the
beginning of the process so when you're
establishing goals and you're
establishing kind of type of content you
want to use that should all be part of a
social media content calendar and I'm
going to show you an example of one here
shortly and then again you want to be
able to test evaluate and adjust your
strategy because again you're getting
metrics and if you post a video on
Facebook and it's taking off then
meaning in terms of likes and shares you
probably want to consider maybe doing
another one that complements that so
here's a broad example of a Content
calendar okay it's in a spreadsheet
Again by no means does one size fits all
but just to give you an idea if we're
blogging what we want to do is we want
to pick our target audience maybe that'd
be country or particular demographic and
you want to come up with some topics
ahead of time here and you want to maybe
put the status up there of you know it's
just a draft or an idea when it actually
does go live you want to turn it on live
you want to pick your day to add some
comments okay create your content and
you know what's good about a Content
count is you can also work in seos you
can assign keywords and then you could
add those keywords to Moz for ranking uh
you can create your title and meta
description then you can carry that
content forward and choose a particular
social media platform to post to so
that's the beauty of a social or excuse
me a Content calendar is it allows you
to think about things up front and then
prepare the content accordingly so you
can optimize them for organic search and
post it on social media for off-page SEO
and for social media media marketing and
so you just want to get organized ahead
of time using a spreadsheet in this case
Google Sheets to lay out the topics
ahead of time so you can write the
content for your intended audience that
to me is the way to go now remember
there's lots of different forms of
content that you can use with social
media marketing here we have video so
you can see this video can be posted on
YouTube or LinkedIn or wherever and the
whole point is you want to be able to
measure engagement here you can see this
is just an image it's just a file and
this has been posted on Facebook so here
we can see my likes and comments and
then shares and so you want to be able
to leverage different forms and
different assets across social media to
see actually what works and what doesn't
work and again look at what other
companies have done whether they be
competitors or not see what type of
assets they're posting and what's
working for them now when it comes to
social media marketing there are lots of
tools available okay you got buffer
HootSuite sprinkler post planner later
Sprout social I mean the list of social
media marketing tools is endless and
just like SEO you will need a platform
to work with so with SEO we showed you
Moz as the SEO platform with social
we're going to show you sprout social
because with Sprout social if you have a
Content calendar if you have a lot of
different assets you want to be able to
organize those assets and content across
multiple channels and the great thing
about using a social media calendars yes
you can publish and organize your post
accordingly you also have most social
media platform tools have listening so
you can listen in on keywords and
audiences different brands and
industries and conversations that are
being had about specific topic okay and
again most social media platforms if not
all have reporting and so this is
important because you can actually see
you know what how your post or different
assets are performing in terms of
Engagement and so to me that's important
if you're going to focus on social media
as a platform as a channel you want to
have a social media platform tool that
will help you organize your content
publish it accordingly listen in in and
get that report to help you figure out
what's engaging and what's not engaging
again so that you can you know react to
the content that you're using and
sharing so that's Sprout social is an
example but you will need a social media
platform now the other benefit to social
media is in some cases you can actually
pay to have your post out there and so
for example on Facebook we could set up
a a paid campaign to Target our intended
audience and so with Facebook Facebook
owns Instagram so you have the ability
to really put your content out in front
of your target audience on Facebook and
Instagram and so what you need to do is
go to Facebook ads manager and simply
just create an account or campaign
um you want to be able to create a
campaign and by creating a campaign that
means you're gonna have to go through a
particular process here so if we first
we want to do is choose our objective
okay so you always want to have an
objective for your campaign so is it
going to be brand awareness is it going
to be to drive you know traffic is it
going to be to drive conversions so you
want to choose a goal or objective if
you're advertising really on any
platform then you want to be able to
choose your audience so who are we
trying to Target so with Facebook you
know you can Target any specific age
gender demographic based on interest and
behavior so you can choose specific
placements and you can assign a budget
okay and then on the ad side you have
different types of ads that you can use
you can do single image or video you can
do a carousel okay meaning you can
rotate different images as a collage or
different videos as a collage and again
you can choose exactly where you want
your ad to be shown for example desktop
or mobile news feed Facebook and stream
video you got Instagram feed you got
even messenger so you have a lot of
options available too on where you're at
or video is going to be shown and then
you can support that with a headline
description and you can send that
traffic back to your website you can
even test call to action buttons okay so
you can pan your ad with a call to
action button and so you can do a lot
here this is just Facebook you can
really do a lot of specific targeting
now with Facebook advertising it's a
cost per click model so anytime somebody
does click on that ad you're going to
pay but it allows you to really get your
content out there in front of your
tenant audience if you're not doing it
organically meaning you're not posting
on Facebook on a regular basis or maybe
you want to supplement those organic
posts then doing this is a good way to
really get your brand out there if it's
awareness if to drive traffic or to
convert Facebook is a good option
LinkedIn Twitter all these social media
platforms offer that up that option up
to do paid advertising now if you want
more information about social media we
have a great video on YouTube already
how to start social media marketing game
it really goes into the details about
organic social and what I just covered
with paid social specifically on
Facebook so take a look at that video
and again if I missed anything on the
social media side feel free to comment
or add in your best practice whether
that be part of the process or a
different platform that you use for
social media okay let's switch to our
next digital marketing channel and
search engine marketing so search engine
marketing is an advertising model that
is good for driving traffic to your site
because you're paying each time someone
clicks on your advertisement now how is
that an equal trade well because you can
advertise on channels like or search
engines like Google or Bing or Admiral
which has a a big Network that includes
Google you can actually pay your way to
the top of search engine rankings and so
if you're at the top for paid search
search and so many churches something
like shoes or something to that effect
your ad can appear at the very top even
above local search even above organic
search and so the visibility is there
it's a good way for you to then get that
traffic that uh that you you covet for
certain keywords and because you're
getting traffic or other potential to
get traffic you're going to pay each
time somebody clicks on these ads so you
have multiple choices on the type of
asset you want to use including text
image video Etc so there's more to it
than just Google Bing adroll I mean you
have LinkedIn you have Twitter you have
Facebooks you have lots of different
ways to advertise and get your ad in a
more prominent position you just have to
pay for it and I just showed you that
under social media marketing Facebook
you can create an ad have your ad
targeting your audience and in return
you're gonna pay Facebook works the same
way for most of these networks okay so
when you actually set up a campaign like
anything you do when you set up a
campaign you want to determine the goal
you want to achieve for the campaign you
want to do that up front especially when
you're talking about paying per click if
you're paying per click then you
definitely want to make sure you
determine what your goals are so you can
measure them accordingly then you want
to choose in this case a relevant list
of keywords you could do it for your
brand meaning you could choose your own
brand keywords you could choose keywords
related to what your brand is trying to
offer whether that be a service or
product and once you choose a relevant
list of keywords you can finalize those
keywords and then bid on them so once
you start bidding on them then what
you're going to do is align those
keywords with a headline so it's all all
done within the framework of any
platform you're advertising on really
the key here that I want to really
emphasize is when you establish a
campaign or set up a campaign you need
to establish what the goal is because
when you actually choose your keywords
and write your ads and launch the
campaign and start paying Google or Bing
or whomever it is you're advertising
with you want to be able to measure
those goals so that's really the
important part here because regardless
of where you advertise you're going to
be able to monitor campaign results and
so with Google you can even import
conversions into the campaign so for
example if I go to Google ads for
example if I go to tools okay you can
see I'm running campaigns what am I
trying to accomplish with these
campaigns well in this case I'm trying
to get donations people click on
donations so I can go to tools click
conversions and then I can see what
conversions are added to my account and
that way I can measure my campaigns
against these conversions okay if I
don't see a conversion air I can
certainly create one or import it from
in this case Google analytics so that's
the important thing you want to be able
to measure your campaigns with your
conversions and then just as important
you want to be able to optimize your
campaign because if it's not performing
if you're running a campaign you're
running up costs and you're not getting
conversions you're probably not going to
be continuing to run those campaigns so
you want to optimize your campaign and
retarget potential customers so
retargeting is always a good option
retargeting is targeting someone who
that went to your website and basically
acted in a certain way meaning they went
to a certain page or abandoned the card
or actually purchased or downloaded
something okay you define what action
you want that audience to take in order
to retarget to them okay so the whole
point is you can configure your
retargeting campaign based on certain
behavior on your website and the whole
point there every Target is you're
pulling people back to your website so
in addition to optimizing you know
search campaigns you can one of the
benefits of search engine marketing is
you can run retargeting campaigns so
here's an example of an ad okay so here
you could see it's a good ad in the
sense that it's using everything
available to it so for example here I
could see three headlines so Google in
this example allows you to add in three
headlines so here you can see simply
learn official site get certified get
ahead then you can see simplylearn.com
so they're taking advantage of three
headlines and then here you can see two
description lines and so each
description line you can have up to 90
characters and so you want to be able to
take advantage of what Google gives you
the more information you can add the
better well here you can see some other
types of ads here you can see a banner
ad for slack okay here you can see
betterment.com running an ad okay so
this looks like an ad that is on YouTube
so because you can see after a few
seconds you can skip the ad okay so
here's a video ad here's an image ad
here's a text ad so depending on what
platform you advertise on you have an
option on what type of asset you want to
use you know the one thing I like about
Facebook is they offer up a multitude of
options in terms of assets you can run a
single image ad you can run a carousel
meeting kind of multiple images you can
run a video you can run a combination
video image you could obviously run text
okay with a thumbnail see you have a lot
of options in terms of the type of AD
you can run so before we move into our
next Channel let me just show you an
example of you know how an ad actually
looks on a particular website so here
you can see see I'm on buzzfeednews.com
okay here you can see a Volkswagen Golf
is running an advertisement in Spanish
on this particular site so they're
either using Google or some other
platform and having that platform if
it's Google post their ad on this
particular site so here you can see it's
a banner app and if we're in Google ads
and you're setting up a text ad let me
just run through you with the text that
it looks like remember you want to
always take advantage of what's offered
to you because especially text ads you
have very few characters and with very
few characters it's hard to get your
message across so with Google you have
your final URL which is where people are
going to go to after they click on your
ad but you have one not one not two but
three headlines that you can take
advantage of so we're talking about help
and child hunger help today you know you
can always add in visit our website for
more info I mean you want to take
advantage of what's available to you now
again here you can see in this example
I'm only allotted 30 characters and if
you go over then your ads not going to
get approved so you really have to be
cognizant of the character counts and
getting your point across because
writing text ads is not the easiest
thing to do when you're limited to
characters now with Google you have what
they call a display path so after the
domain you can add in a couple of
keywords in there and then you have
description line one and description
line two so again take advantage of
what's available if you're not sure what
copyright grab some from the website and
paste it in there you want your ads to
be healthy and have as much information
as possible and then the one thing I
will say about Google ads is they also
have extensions so extensions are
exactly that their extension to your
text ad so here you can see I have four
extension these are actually site links
so Google ads offers up something called
ad extension so it could be call outs
site links it could be location
extensions app extensions they have a
number of different extensions that they
can append to your ad so take advantage
of that as well remember the whole point
of ads is to make a compelling case for
your product or service so that somebody
can click on the ad and go to your
website and then perform the action you
want them to perform now if you have any
more questions about Google ads feel
free to check out our in-depth video
about Google ads it covers everything A
to Z on Google ads you know we also have
videos on our simply learn YouTube
playlist for Facebook Twitter social
media marketing so if you're curious to
know a little bit more about search
engine marketing you know check out any
one of these videos that we have I've
listed on our YouTube channel okay so
let's move over to affiliate marketing
now and so with affiliate marketing
really it's interesting and unique in
that affiliate marketing involves paying
out commissions and who are you paying
commissions to while you're paying
commissions to website owners or
Publishers or people who have websites
with lots of content or people who have
websites that attract a lot of users and
so the whole point is you want to be
able to find those websites to advertise
your product or service okay these
people who are selling your product or
service on your behalf are gonna get
commissioned or incentivized based on
whatever action you put out there so it
could be registrations just getting your
Affiliates to help you with getting
people registered or signing up for your
email or you know for a lot of you
conversions you're trying to sell a
product say you want help inside selling
that product or it could be
subscriptions okay signing up to
something okay so you determine what it
is you want to incentivize your
Affiliates for you also determine how
much you're going to incentivize them
and that's the great thing about
affiliate marketing it's it's no
different than having a sales team
um to support you what are the steps for
affiliate marketing well you need to
find a platform there are lots of
different affiliate platforms out there
you know Commission Junction or cj.com
comes to mind because these platforms
are going to help you find these
Affiliates or Partners okay so they're
the broker and all this and so once you
set up your platform you're going to
establish rules guidelines post images
and Banners and assets for those
Affiliates to use on their websites and
more importantly again you're going to
establish the commission so the
commission doesn't have to be the same
for all Affiliates it could simply be
you know your top Affiliates get a
higher commission as opposed to just
some other Affiliates who get a starting
commission you establish everything on
the platform the affiliate platform that
you choose now Affiliates apply to
advertise on your behalf so they're
going to say hey I'm interested in
selling your product or service so
you're going to use that platform if
it's Commission Junction to approve or
disapprove three Affiliates request to
advertise on your behalf and really what
you want to try and do is leverage the
platform as best as you can a lot of
these Affiliates are out to make money
and some of them are really good you
need to be able to choose the affiliate
that is going to represent your brand
product or service the best so it's
simple customer clicks on an ad or link
okay on that affiliate website and they
go to your website and they perform an
action so that could be a purchase or
registration a subscription a download
an email sign up you determine that and
the great thing is these affiliate
networks the CJs commission Junctions of
the world will record everything they're
Tracking not only traffic from the
affiliate website to your website but
they're also tracking the conversions
the transaction is validated and
credited to the affiliate by the broker
and then the affiliate is paid his or
her commission so that's how it works so
the more the affiliate sells or converts
on your behalf the more they're going to
make and that's the beauty of the
affiliate Network so here's an example
of affiliate marketing okay here you can
see uh an advertisement here okay so you
can see profit from our experience earn
up to 12 advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce list leader so somebody
clicks on that link joins and then this
person is going to get a commission
based on somebody joining for free and I
mentioned Commission Junction there are
also some other affiliate marketing
tools out there uh Amazon Associates a
win trade doubler Max Bounty I mean
there's a there's there's a lot out
there
cj.com is the one I've used in the past
but you know give some of these other
platforms a chance okay it doesn't hurt
to even be on multiple platforms you
have nothing to lose okay when you're on
a platform basically the platform again
is acting as the mental person they're
introducing you to Affiliates and so
every time you actually pay an affiliate
a commission they're going to get their
cut of it so they're going to get a
small percentage as well so just keep
that in mind but you know give it a try
try one or two of these Affiliates if
you find you're getting quality
Affiliates that are selling your product
or service great if you don't then you
know feel free to change you know
affiliate networks it's that simple but
the key here is find the Affiliates you
think are going to best represent your
brand product or service because those
Affiliates are likely going to be the
ones to convert for you and if you're
small business starting out and you need
some help affiliate marketing is the way
to go okay let's move over to Native
advertising okay so native advertising
so neighbor advertisements means that
your ad is showing up next to content
that basically naturally fits so these
are advertisers that are featured on a
platform alongside the content okay that
isn't paid for okay so for example here
you can see a paid post okay this is by
Spotify okay this paid post okay was on
BuzzFeed this particular post was
probably on a news article related to
music because they're talking about you
know bands that probably won't exist
without Led Zeppelin okay so for Spotify
you using native advertising allows them
to put their ad next to content relay
added to their ad here you can see
another BuzzFeed article okay 11 great
Amazon deals that will be music to your
ears if your audio file here you can see
an advertisement next to the article so
you can see the ad about Led Zeppelin
and here you can see the actual article
is about music so the whole point about
Native advertising is making sure
there's a connection between the ad and
the article so Spotify is advertising
okay their product and service on an
article on BuzzFeed which happens to be
about music so a good example we use
BuzzFeed just a second ago so if we go
to BuzzFeed here you can see I'm in TV
movies and here you can see got an ad
here if we scroll down uh keep scrolling
down we can see another ad here for HBO
and so this ad makes sense because it's
placed on TVs and movies so people who
go and read the content are gonna see an
ad had related to that content so that's
generally what Native advertising is you
need to be able to be able to place the
ad on the right pages okay so you're
going to need an ad Network for that so
we talked about paid search advertising
we talked about Google ads so Google ads
has the ability to place your ad
natively on particular pages that are
relevant to that ad so that's really
what Native advertising is all about
making sure that your ad is placed next
to content that's naturally relevant so
if you need more information about
affiliate marketing feel free to visit
simply learns YouTube channel we have a
nice uh in-depth video about affiliate
marketing to get more information about
the platforms how it works and all the
tips and best practices about how to run
a successful affiliate marketing
campaign so let's turn our attention to
email marketing now so email marketing
very traditional form of digital
marketing spent around the longest it's
kind of the grandfather of all digital
marketing channels so email marketing
really is used to personalize emails in
order to convert that recipient or that
perspective user into a customer and so
like all the other digital marketing
channels we want to follow some type of
flow or process or methodology and the
first step in email marketing is you
have to identify your target audience
okay when you identify your target
audience you're going to create a
segment okay so in other words you don't
want to send one email to everyone
because not everyone is going to be
interested in that email so in order to
get somebody interested you need to be
able to send an email tailored to that
audience okay so that audience can
respond and react accordingly so once
you target that audience and create
segments email segments you're going to
create the campaign and and set up an
appropriate call to action one node here
is when you create the campaign and set
up that appropriate call to action that
call to action is going to be in line
with your goal so what is the goal of
the email campaign is it simply to get
people to click on something and
purchase or is it simply to get people
to click on something and sign up or
watch something or submit some
information or download or whatever the
case you need to establish that up front
just like you would with a search engine
marketing campaign or any other type of
campaign you want to run so there are
lots of tools out there just like with
affiliate marketing you want to choose
an appropriate email marketing tool
there are plenty to be Had Each work in
a very similar nature some offer
different pricing models meaning you
know you can send an email to ex
recipients for flat fee or or you pay a
small amount per email address each one
is slightly different in terms of how
they price but in terms of the features
they all work in a very similar fashion
and we're going to show you an example
of one here shortly so when you choose
that email marketing tool you're going
to test your emails before you send them
out and then when you test your emails
you're going to use that email marketing
tool to actually send the campaign after
it's been tested okay so you want to
send the campaign you can immediately
send them out or you can schedule them
now a best practice with an email is
when you actually send one out you're
sending an email out to your target
audience you want to create probably two
emails per segment audience why because
you want to add an attractive subject
line and copy to the email but if you
send two emails to the same target
audience then you want to test the
subject lines you want to be able to see
what subject lines going to entice
somebody to open the email okay that's
the beauty of email marketing is you can
do that okay so you can set up your a
design based on your target audience but
it's always the subject line that people
see first so you want to write an
attractive subject line and copy that's
going to entice somebody to open the
email so why not send two emails to each
target audience that way you can see
what email subject line works best so
that's the whole idea about performing a
b tests to test out different ideas it
doesn't necessarily have to be a subject
line it can be the same subject line two
emails but the difference being the body
of the email it's totally up to you but
the idea here is to always split out
your emails per target audience and just
like any other channel whether it be
affiliate or search engine marketing
organic search you want to analyze
performance and in the case of emails
it's always about open right how many
people are opening then how many people
are clicking and then how many people
are actually responding are they
converting or downloading or whatever it
is you want them to do you need to be
able to monitor the behavior because for
example if your open rates don't work or
they're low then you know something's
wrong with your subject line so you want
to be able to make an adjustment so
here's an example of an email from
Airbnb it's a simple email okay they're
just simply trying to get somebody to
click on that call to action to take the
survey okay that's really all it's about
here with this particular email so who's
their target audience well their target
audience could be somebody who's already
stayed at a Airbnb property or it could
be somebody who used the app probably
Airbnb has already targeted this
audience and they're sending this survey
to a particular audience so that they
can get the best results okay so that's
a good example I have a targeted email
with a good call to action that's
getting somebody to take the survey so
they're probably measuring I mean people
opened it how many people clicked on the
CTA the call to action and then how many
people actually filled out the surveys
you need to follow each step and track
each step accordingly okay so again some
popular tools used in email marketing
let's take a look at MailChimp here uh
but I will mention like Marketo is a
good marketing automation tool now owned
by Adobe Marketo allows you to send
those drip campaigns so if somebody
doesn't purchase right away you can send
up follow-up emails like say one day out
or seven days out or 14 days out so
HubSpot Works in a very similar fashion
you want to be able to methodically plan
out your emails that's the point I'm
trying to make here so let's take a look
at MailChimp so if we go over into
MailChimp very easy interface okay here
if we go under audience we can actually
see who our audience is if we could
break out our audience into different
groups you can have a simple test list
you can have people who purchase people
who subscribe to something okay so you
can break out your audience into
different groups okay when it comes to
campaigns you can see campaigns that are
already been built or you can create
your own campaign okay so in the case of
MailChimp we can actually see what
campaigns have been dropped or sent out
already and then we could see the opens
the clicks and then the conversions so
MailChimp has some nice reporting so you
want to be able to measure the reports
or how well the campaign performs so
here we can see specifically how many
people open clicked how many people
bounced or email addresses bounced and
how many people unsubscribe from the
list and here we can see you know the
top links that have been effect okay the
subscribers with the most opens did
anybody perform any social media
activity okay what locations open the
email okay so you can actually see a lot
of good information here right in
MailChimp and you want to be able to
react to the emails you send out so if
an email is not performing okay you want
to learn from that so you don't make the
same mistake again great thing I like
about MailChimp too they have a lot of
nice templates to use so if you're
trying to create a template here you got
some templates that you can leverage so
that's MailChimp kind of in a nutshell
MailChimp you could pay up front buy
credits and with those credits you could
send out emails to a number of people
okay so that's how MailChimp Works they
do have a free trial so you can set up
an account using the free trial now if
you need any more information about
MailChimp or email marketing in general
take a look at the email marketing
webinar we have set up on our simply
learn YouTube
now let's finish up with online PR press
releases so we talked about SEO and
social and search and affiliate and
email marketing and and content native
advertising let's talk about online PR
here because and what we're going to do
is start out with search engine
optimization okay so search engine
optimization or organic search we have a
mixture of paid and free so there's a
lot of different platforms but if you're
focusing on SEO you certainly need to
use an SEO platform so there's sem Rush
okay you also have Google search console
which is free so if you don't have a SEO
platform you definitely need to be using
Google search console and so we'll take
a closer look at that there's Google
Keyword Planner which is actually
situated under Google ads and so if
you're running Google campaigns on
Google search Network or even the
Display Network you have access to a
great tool called Keyword Planner and if
you know anything about SEO you'll know
that using Google's Keyword Planner is a
good tool so we'll take a look at that
Moz is a freemium tool meaning they have
a free trial that you can sign up for to
test drive it but it's another SEO
platform and it does cost money got a
great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in
hrefs that help us with all aspects of
SEO primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
going to hone in on but this is just a
small subset of what really is available
out there in the market so let's go
ahead and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about SEO is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is Google's
Keyword Planner and Google's Keyword
Planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested in optimizing for
because not only one are they relevant
but two they're going to have high
volume and low competition so let's take
a look at an example in Google's Keyword
Planner so here I am I'm in Google's
Keyword Planner and as I mentioned
before Google's Keyword Planner is
situated under Google ads okay so you
have to have a Google ads account to use
Google's Keyword Planner and so when
you're in Google ads you simply go to
tools and then under Tools you're going
to select Keyword Planner so what we
want to do is look for keywords we're
focusing on organic search not
necessarily paid search so organic
search we want to hone in on some
keywords so let's just use one of the
examples that Google's given us here
meal delivery so we're going to just
type in mail delivery and get some
results so notice I can enter a domain
as a filter and so in other words hey I
could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if I wanted to
but I'm asking Google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
I'm going to click click get results
notice I can add another key to it if I
wanted to but I'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that I can certainly hone
in on if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just hone in on that one
keyword mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what Google Keyword Planner does is not
only give us the key word in other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here I
get a column for competition so I'm able
to see whether that's a very competitive
keyword or not and then just to give you
an extra Edge when you're choosing
keywords you can get a sense of what the
keyword May cost if you wanted to bid on
that for paid search so for mail
delivery I can see it's anywhere between
7.46 and at the top of the page high
range
16.61 so that should alert me to the
fact that hey if I'm gonna try and
optimize for this keyword I know it's
competitive because not only Google is
telling me it's competitive by telling
me high competition but I know that the
cost per click seems a little bit high
and what is a little bit hi well you
know I can see some other keywords here
that you know a dollar to three dollars
okay I could see some other ones that
are even lower than the seven dollars
they're suggested so that's a indication
that the keyword is highly competitive
so the idea here using Google's Keyword
Planner is one we want to get an idea of
what other keywords are out there that
are relevant so it helps stimulate some
ideas for relevancy two we can get an
average monthly search volume so we want
to know on average over the past 12
months how many search queries I can
expect from this keyword and then three
I can get a sense of the competition how
competitive is this keyword so if I try
to optimize for this keyword and I want
to rank for it organically is it
competitive if it's competitive then
it's probably going to take me a bit
longer to be found for this keyword on
page one of Google so that's the whole
idea behind Google's Keyword Planner and
and note that you could change some of
the settings here so if you want to
choose a different language okay you can
hone in on a longer or shorter period of
time you can even choose a specific
location so I chose taxes I can
certainly choose the entire United
States to get a sense of what the volume
would be for the total us so you have
settings that you can change and
manipulate to get you the data you need
to choose keywords so that's the whole
idea behind Google's Keyword Planner to
find relevant keywords high volume low
competition now alternatively I can
certainly use another tool to find
keywords so I have a Moz account so I
logged into Moz and Moz has a tool
called keyword Explorer so if I use that
same keyword I used in Google's Keyword
Planner mail delivery I'm going to ask
Moz to give me some data on that keyword
so this is for the entire United States
and again I can change that if I wanted
to okay so I can hone in on a specific
country or different country so what
miles is telling me hey for this keyword
in the entire United States I'm looking
at anywhere from eleven and a half
thousand to thirty thousand on monthly
volume now what Moz does is they give
you a difficulty score so a difficulty
score is a score between 1 and 100 and
so I could see this is pretty much right
down the middle in terms of difficulty
okay so if it's zero it's an easy
keyword if it's if it's a hundred it's
very difficult and then that means you
have a lot of competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword and so Moz
gives us the volume they give us the
competition M8 just like Google's
Keyword Planner gives us some other
keywords that we can potentially hone in
on so here I could see keyboard delivery
plans delivery services is ETC so I can
see a lot more suggestions than what's
listed here so Moz delivers a bunch of
other analysis related to the keyword
you know they also give you some good
keyword suggestions so Moz is a good
alternative tool and we'll be coming
back to Moz related to SEO for some
other of its features but for now if you
don't want to necessarily use Google's
Keyword Planner because maybe you're not
running Google ads you can always use
Mazda remember Moz has basically a
freemium version I mean you can sign up
for a free account and you can sign up
for a free account as a test trial and
you could test it for a period of days
and leverage its tools during that free
trial to get a better sense of how these
tools work so we want to be able to use
Moz we want to be able to use Google's
Keyword Planner not only to search for
all those relevant keywords available to
you but we want to be able to choose
keywords with high volume and low
difficulty low competition we also want
to select primary and second keywords
wisely so remember when you optimize
you're optimizing a page for more than
one keyword so you want to be able to
have a nice portfolio of diverse
relevant keywords with high search
volume and low difficulty and then you
want to be able to identify those
keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so Moz gives you that
information and so we want to be able to
leverage the tools available to us to
choose the right keywords so if you need
any more information on this we got a
nice webinar on keyword research for SEO
so take a look at that video on YouTube
to get more specific details about using
SEO tools for keyword research and all
about keyword research in general for
SEO so let's talk about some other
reasons under SEO what we would use some
of these tools available to us well we
want to be able to under understand the
search engines and how they crawl and
index our site okay we also want to
check the correct format of the site map
and we want to monitor backlinks okay we
also want to analyze linking to our web
page okay which ones are good which ones
are not good okay we also want to
perform some competitor analysis so
these are some of the reasons why other
than keyword research why would we use
some of these SEO tools so we have tools
available to us a majestic hrefs again
Moz let's take a look at Google search
console and I want to hone in on Google
search console because it is free and
it's a must if you're going to work on
SEO you need to be working in Google
search console and so the whole key
behind Google search console is you have
a website you need to get that site
verified once it's verified once Google
can wreck in eyes that you are
associated with this website then you're
going to be able to see some important
information so here I'm looking at a
website and what am I looking at I'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so what does coverage mean
well going back to what we just said we
want to be able to understand how
Google's crawling and indexing our pages
and so what Google does is through this
platform search console is they're
letting us know once they go to our
website and start crawling it and they
pull these Pages back to their server
they're letting us know if we actually
have any issues so here I could see I
have some issues with 112 pages and some
of those issues are listed down here so
there could be a crawl issue a 4-4 you
know redirect okay so you can see
there's some five unique issues across a
hundred and 12 pages so here I can see
submitted URL Mark no index there's a
hundred of those pages we have some
redirect errors there's seven pages that
you know fall victim to this error and
so we can really hone in
um what the error is and address the
error okay so if Google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by Google then we should
probably address the error and so that's
the great thing here about going into
Google search console is you can under
index go to coverage and get a sense of
what Google's indexing and what they're
not indexing okay so these are the
errors I can see they've certainly were
able to crawl and index
9115 Pages they were able to crawl okay
and they excluded 54 000 plus pages and
then we also have some pages with some
warnings so this is kind of an overview
of what Google Sees when they crawl our
site so when they say crawl they're
coming to our site they're following
links on the site and every link they
follow they're either going to index
that page or they're going to report to
you an error or an issue that they found
if we want these Pages indexed we need
to address the issues the errors and so
that's the beauty of this report here is
Google is telling us firsthand what the
issues are so we also want to take a
look at the site map so you have an
opportunity to submit a sitemap and a
site map is just a formatted file that
includes all your website URLs and so
you're going to have this file sitting
in your root directory and you're
probably going to call it or should call
it
sitemap.xml XML being the format so once
you have this file you're just going to
let Google know that that file exists so
you're going to enter in the sitemap URL
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what Google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see that we discovered 1
419 URLs so I can go back under coverage
and I can see some of the issues that
they found but if I go back under site
Maps I can see that these are the URLs
they discovered via the sitemap and so
the whole point of a site map is we want
to be able to get and push the URLs to
Google not have Google come to our site
and discover them so this is a quicker
faster more efficient way to communicate
with Google all the URLs that you have
on your site that you want Google to
index and so that's the beauty of search
console now while we're in search
console we might as well take a look at
some of the other features it has and so
one of the most important features under
search console is this mobile usability
report okay so Google is a staunch
believer in mobile first so nowadays
most people start and finish a lot of
their searches a lot of their behavior
on mobile so the beginning on mobile and
they may end it on mobile so if they
don't end it on mobile then you know
perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
Googled is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts with mobile so they want
you to understand how your site fares
Via Mobile and when I say fares Via
Mobile is it mobile friendly is it
responsive is it loading quick enough
you know is it formatted to Google
standards and so if there are any issues
Google's going to let you know what
those issues are so here I could see
Google's recognized 206 Pages before
different issues Okay so so here I can
see what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here I can see for
206 Pages text too small to read click
elements to close together the viewport
not set to device with and then content
wider than the screen so there's 10
pages that fit under this error and if I
actually click on it the error I can see
what those 10 pages are and so when
we're done we can actually when we
address the issues we can actually have
Google validate whether the fix has been
made so you can definitely use this as a
means of communicating directly with
Google telling Google look I see what
the issues are I'm going to fix them and
then I want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with Google and let them
know hey we do recognize the errors we
are fixing the errors please validate
them you know it's going to draw
Google's attention Google's going to
validate them and get these pages in X
quicker so if you ignore the issues then
the errors especially for mobile then
you stand the chance of your pages not
getting indexed so the mobile usability
report to me is an important report
because we want to better understand
whether Google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get Google value them so
Google can index them quicker now
there's another report that is of
interest to you or may be of interest to
you in Google search console and that's
the links report so the links report in
Google search console shows us what
pages have the most links okay so here
we can see the home page has 26 000 plus
links if we hone in on interior Pages we
can see the links to those pages okay so
we can get a sense of what are the top
link pages from external links meaning
links on other websites pointing to
these pages I can also see internal
links so Google's recognizing links from
within my website from one page to
another so external links internal links
both factors for SEO when ranking so
then I could see top linking sites what
sites are linking to my site and then I
can see top linking text so Google
search console has given me kind of an
overview of what my leaking structure
looks like okay so externally I want
links from other websites pointing to
various pages on my site and I certainly
want my pages linking to one another on
my site and so I'll be able to better
understand what that structure looks
like using Google search consoles links
report okay there's one more report that
I think's of interest in Google search
console and that's the performance
report so the performance report is a
report that actually you can link up
with Google analytics so you can see the
same report and analytics if you're able
to link up Google Google search console
with analytics and you should be able to
do that all you need to do is make sure
you use the same email address that you
use for analytics and search console so
it needs to be the same email address
you could certainly link up the two and
have this data imported into Google
analytics so what is this data that
we're talking about well it's called
performance so what we can actually see
is the queries the actual queries people
are typing in to Google so when they're
typing them into Google we can actually
see how many Impressions the keyword
queries received and how many clicks the
keyword queries received and then I can
see click-through rate and average
position okay so here I can see for this
particular keyword on the first line I
could see over the course of the last
three months it received 209
297 Impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used or
typed in as a query at least that many
times and that's how many times my
listing appeared and the Google search
results Pages based on this particular
query and so as a result of somebody
typing in this query 209 000 plus times
this site received 120 000 plus clicks
so to get a sense of the click-through
rate all you would need to do and Google
can obviously do this for you is you
would simply just divide the 209 297
into the 120
397. okay so that's really going to give
you that's going to give you your
click-through rate and the click-through
rate in this case is 57 so over half of
the clicks occur when this listing
appears for this keyword okay so we can
get a sense of the click-through rate
for each one okay and you could simply
just use the filtering here now we can
also see average position okay so we
could see a little bit more than that
too we can go from queries to Pages we
can go from pages to countries so we get
a sense of how many Impressions and
clicks I'm receiving by country and
importantly we can see by device so here
I can see a majority of the people who
conduct a search related to my website
primarily do it on desktop now I
mentioned the beauty of the Google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to Google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
Google search console and then from
there you could choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so I could
see the same data that I see in search
console but this time I'm looking at it
in Google analytics and so here I can
see what my search queries are my clicks
my Impressions my click the rate by
search query and then the average
business position so that's the great
thing about that performance report is
that when I link up Google search
console with analytics I'm able to see
that data in analytics so that's an
added bonus so to speak now let's talk
about some other reasons why we're going
to use these SEO tools available to us
and so we already listed a number of
different reasons ranging from site maps
to keyword research but we also want to
hone in on you know what domains are
driving links to our site so I showed
you an example in search console we also
want to hey maybe identify and disavow
poor backlinks so search console is a
great tool for that because if we don't
want to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and no follow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates some Impressions
just as we did with search console we
could track keyword ranking for desktop
mobile cross locations just as we just
did with the search console performance
report we can identify top performing
gaining and losing keywords again the
performance report so we could certainly
look at the Google search console report
but if you have a platform like Moz you
can certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a Moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see for the keywords that we've
chosen that we want to optimize for we
could certainly see where they rank the
great thing about Moz is it's a great
tool not only for rankings and on-page
optimization but for off-page
optimization as well so if I go ahead
and take a look at a domain for example
I'm just going to type in this domain
I'm going to be able to get what they
call a domain Authority so a score or
atom of 1 and 100 I'm able to see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
Moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links I have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if I click on the linking domains I'm
going to be actual able to see the
actual domains pointing to my site as an
external link and not only can I see the
domains I can actually see the domain
authority of those domains so if there's
a domain for example that doesn't have a
good domain Authority and the site
appears a bit scammy per se then we can
disavow that so I can certainly look at
all the domains that are linking to me
and then I can highlight the ones that
have poor domain Authority what Moz even
takes it a step further they also give
me a Spam score so Moz is able to
measure how spammy a website is so if I
have a combination of say a low domain
Authority and a high spam score then I
probably want to disavow myself from
that site and so I can use this report
here you can see here as I keep going
down for example I can see this
particular website has a domain
authority of 26 and it has a Spam score
of 16 so not a good combination this
should alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has so
many links pointing to me or it has at
least one link pointing to me that I
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
Authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is I'm
able to hone in on not only who's link
linking to me meaning in domain but how
many linking domains does that domain
have what's the spam score of that
domain what's the domain authority of
that domain and then I could get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about backlinks domain Authority spam
Etc everything you need to use in order
to measure off page SEO so that's the
great thing about Moz is they have not
only on-page SEO tools but off-page SEO
tools and Moz is a freemium so to speak
so here you can see if you just go to
mods.com free Dash seo-tools you'll be
able to use some of these tools
available to you not just for SEO but
also for local SEO as well so here you
like some of these tools you can start
your free 30-day trial so I use and lean
on Moz a lot for all that it has to
offer from choosing keywords to rankings
report to checking issues on my website
to even checking who's linking to me so
this fits in the mold with everything I
need to do for SEO so in addition to
that keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on SEO so
we've done a webinar on SEO tools and
we've also done a webinar on SEO tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or SEO in general take a look at those
two videos and check them out and that
should kind of complement what we've
talked about with using some of the
tools Google's Keyword Planner Moz and
Google search console okay let's switch
over to email marketing tools and so
with email marketing tools we have a lot
available to us in the form of reporting
in the full form of Platforms in the
form of you know tools that really help
us go from A to Z on our email choosing
you know what email to send out to
creating a list to measuring how the
email campaign went and so we could
start with MailChimp because mailchimp's
a freemium version when we say freemium
meaning they have a free trial available
then you're expected to upgrade but you
know MailChimp to me is a tool I use I
like the interface very easy for
beginners so we're going to take a look
at MailChimp but there are certainly
many others available you know more
cattle is a good tool you know Marketo
is a good toll because if you have a
business and you're trying to funnel
people through your pipeline so to speak
meaning they they sign up as a lead and
you want to nurture that lead from the
beginning to the end meaning at the end
they're actually going to turn around
and purchase well Marketo is a good tool
for you to use because you you can then
set up trip campaigns or also known as
email campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular Prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about Marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a HubSpot a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages to a b testing to social to you
know emails so this is another freemium
tool that you could use you have another
freemium and send in blue email platform
and then you also have convertkit
another email platform there's more
Dimension that we can't even fit on this
screen now if you have a favorite email
marketing tool that you use Constant
Contact vertical response they're plenty
out there Emma you know feel free to to
note that in the comment section below
this video I'm curious as to how many
people actually use you you know
different tools because there are so
literally so many email marketing tools
out there why because email marketing
has been around probably the longest
amongst all the other digital marketing
channels and a lot of people use email
on a daily basis so it's no wonder why
there's just so many tools available and
so with these tools you can certainly
send bulk emails now in the case of
Marcato you could send emails to a
segmented audience and so that's a
actually what you want to do as a
strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around that particular audience so you
know you have a good tool when you can
do that when you can really segment for
your audience okay you want to be able
to use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use trans
actual emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like I
mentioned with Marketo you want a
workflow set up where hey if somebody
does this you're sending email B Etc so
you want an email marketing tool that's
flexible enough to handle what your
business strategy and goals are okay so
you want to be able to also use a tool
that you know has various email
templates available okay you don't want
to be stuck with just a vanilla template
again you want to be able to customize
an email for your audience you want to
be able to manage your list
appropriately meaning if you have 10 000
users or emails in a list you want to be
able to manage them accordingly you know
break them up or or have sub lists so to
speak and then most importantly you want
to make sure you have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some some detailed
insights meaning you know what
percentage of users opened your email
what percentage of recipients clicked on
your email what links do they click on
you know which which emails bounce so
you want some detailed insights right in
the platform that you're using it just
makes it more simpler and easier and
more effective to manage you certainly
want to create that smart automated
campaigns meaning you don't even have to
send out the email and then you want to
be able to have some flexibility to set
up email delivery based on a specific
time of day so these tools also allow
you to your segment contacts based on
geolocation you want to be able to use a
tool that allows for multivariate
testing again you want to analyze
performance and optimize campaigns you
want to trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool that will automatically
send that email out so these are all the
reasons why you would use an email
marketing tool so let's dive in and take
a look at an example and we're going to
use MailChimp as our example today so
let's dive in and take a look at
MailChimp so with MailChimp once you log
in you know you're going to be able to
see some historical campaigns that you
sent out or are you going to be able to
create your own campaign and so this is
kind of under campaigns you can kind of
see an overview of the ones you've sent
out or if they're in draft mode you'll
be able to see they're in draft mode so
you can go ahead and edit them so here
we have one that was set up on August
26th and it's still in draft mode so we
can go ahead and edit that so if we just
click edit you know we have the
flexibility to you know pick and choose
who we're sending this to who it's from
what the subject line is and then we can
certainly design the email so if we
click design email again this is
important because with email marketing
you want to be able to cater your email
to your intended audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with intended audience and so
here you can see MailChimp allows us to
do that okay you can see some of the
layouts here okay you also have themes
that you could choose from okay you
could search for different themes or you
can even just code your own so you can
just paste your code in or you can
import it so MailChimp allows that
flexibility you're not stuck with one of
their templates and so if we go back to
the dashboard the one thing I like about
MailChimp though is the reported okay so
yes it is easy to choose a template and
map that template to your audience but I
really like make the reports that they
have to offer so you know here you can
see there's some lists that we've sent
to and we choose one of our audience
lists then we can see some really
detailed reporting here and so here I
could see this email that was sent out
in June I could see it was sent to 95
000 plus subscribers okay of the
subscribers I saw two thousand plus open
it and 157 clicks so I can view this
report in more detail just by clicking
on view report so again we want an email
platform that's going to be able to give
us some detailed information about how
that email campaign performed and so I
can get down really to the nitty-gritty
I can actually see you know on the
content what was clicked and what wasn't
clicked so here I sent two different
subject lines so I'm able to compare the
two against one another okay so I can
really go into detail about one of them
here so if I click view report I can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here I'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16 I
only had an open rate of 2.5 percent so
the industry average is 18 and so here
I'm able to see the list average for the
click rate and the industry average for
the click rate as well so then I can see
some specifics about it how many people
unsubscribed then I could see a graph I
could see the top links that were
clicked okay the top subscribers with
the most opens I can link social to it
if I want to and then I can see
geographic information so the point
being is MailChimp really goes into some
nice detail here about the email
campaigns and how they performed so the
great thing is too with the MailChimp
you could link it with a Google
analytics you can link it with
e-commerce okay so if you have an email
and you're you're selling products and
somebody purchased that product
MailChimp is able to integrate in with
your shopping Commerce platform for
example woocommerce so if somebody did
purchase you can send out that thank you
email MailChimp even goes a step further
and if somebody did click on a link go
to your shopping cart add something to
the shopping cart and then abandon the
cart you know MailChimp allows you the
opportunity to retarget them via email
so MailChimp is flexible and that's what
you want in a email marketing platform
you want something that's flexible that
you can cater to your audience you can
manage your audience list and you can
get detailed reporting on your different
campaigns for that audience so that's
MailChimp and summary and so most email
platforms do a lot of similar features
or have some similar features but that's
what you ideally want to look for in an
email marketing platform so here's a
tool that doesn't get talked about
enough when it comes to email marketing
and that's Google's URL Builder and the
reason why we're going to talk about
this tool today is because most people
in the US use Google analytics as their
web Analytics tool and the one thing
about Google analytics is it allows you
to track different campaigns so if
you're doing pay-per-click campaigns
outside of Google you can certainly
track the performance right in Google
analytics and email is no different so
if you're using Google analytics and
you're sending out an email let's just
say on MailChimp or any other email
marketing platform you want to be able
to append your links with what we call
UTM tracking so for example if I have a
URL that says visit Florida and I'm
going to send out an email I have up to
five parameters that I can use Okay so
so here's my email or URL that I'm using
in the email so I have up to five
parameters that I can use to track this
particular email so let's go through
some of those parameters so the first
one is campaign source so what's the
source of the campaign well we could
certainly identify MailChimp if we're
using MailChimp as the source now the
the thing about the URL Builders you
always want to use lowercase because
Google analytics is case sensitive so as
a rule of thumb just stick with a
lowercase so our source is going to be
MailChimp because that's the platform
we're using if you're using you know
Constant Contact or vertical response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using to drive traffic to
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so their summer promo here is
visit Florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to Florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice I got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so Google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email I would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do I say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say if 10 000 recipient recipients I
want to be able to split out the email
into two segments one segment that's
going to get subject line one and one
segment that's going to get subject line
two so in this case I'm going to put
whatever subject line one is in the
campaign content field so now I have
four parameters and once I've entered in
my variables in this parameter Fields I
now have a revised or appended URL so my
original URL was visit florida.com
Florida Dash beaches.html my original
URL I've now appended that with some UTM
parameters and now I see my original URL
appended with the UTM parameters based
on those variables so I can copy it just
by clicking the copy URL I can go to my
browser I can paste that URL in there
and I want to check to see if it works
so here I could see this particular page
loaded Florida beaches with my etm
parameters appended to the URL so that's
for the first subject line that's for
the audience it's going to get the first
subject line I want to do another one
for the second subject line so now I'm
going to change my campaign content
parameter to subject line underscore 2.
I'm going to copy that URL I'm going to
check it okay so I could see that the
page loads with those U10 parameters and
so now what am I going to do I'm going
to use the first URL and the second URL
in my email okay so any link that I have
in this case I'm using subject line two
so for the email with the second subject
line going to that segmented audience
this is the link I'm going to use in the
email so if you have one or two or three
links in the email this is the URL
you're going to use because when
somebody clicks on that link you're
going to be able to see that that click
in Google analytics so if I jump over to
Google analytics after I send out my
email I'm going to go to acquisition I'm
going to go to campaigns I'm going to go
to all campaigns now based on the
variables I put into my parameters
meaning Source medium campaign name
content or term that's what I'm going to
look for in Google analytics so we could
start with source and medium so if I
click on source and medium as my primary
Dimension here I can see MailChimp and
the actual dates was used as part of the
variable for for source and then what
can I see the medium being email so now
I can see for this email that was sent
out in MailChimp in May I could see how
many users how many sessions and more
importantly how many conver versions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to if we
choose some of the other parameters
available to us so here I could see the
campaign name okay so I could see
exactly what campaign what source what
email drove in traffic and conversions
and if I'm doing subject line testing I
can choose content as my parameter so
here I'm going to change it to content
and now I can see the subject lines in
this case if I go back to my source
medium I'm going to be able to see what
subject lines from my emails generated
the most traffic and not only the most
traffic but also conversions so that's
the whole point behind using the URL
Builder again you're taking a URL that
you're going to use an email and then
you're going to pan that URL with
different parameters campaign Source
campaign medium campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those parameters you're going to
get it appended URL which you can then
use in your email so when the email gets
sent you're going to go back over to
Google analytics and you're going to
look at the results of that campaign of
that source of that Medium of that
content I.E subject line and so that's
why the URL Builder is so important
because MailChimp gives us some good
insight as to how the email performed in
terms of open and click rates but what
we really want to see is how that
campaign performed once it drove traffic
to my website so that's the whole idea
behind the URL Builder if you're using
Google analytics you'll be able to use
the URL Builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools and this is an
important section because web analytics
tools kind of the central focal point of
all digital marketing and it starts
really with Google analytics Google
analytics is a freemium meaning that
they have a free version that you can
use there is also a paid version of
Google analytics but given the Advent of
Google it's popular especially in the
United States a majority of users are
using the free version of Google
analytics so it's a very popular tool
especially for marketers but there are
also other tools available so it's not
just Google so we have Adobe analytics
which is also freemium you have kiss
metrics you have spring metrics you have
YouTube analytics which is part of
Google but YouTube has its own separate
analytics insights so a lot of these as
you can see are free to use they're
available no reason why you should not
be using uh an Analytics tool to measure
your marketing campaigns or website
behavior and why would we want to use
these tools again well again we want to
really measure Behavior we want to
measure what's going on with our website
so we want to be able to identify the
location of where our website visitors
are coming from and a lot of these
analytics tools use IP address to
identify the location of a website
visitor so if you're trying to Target a
specific country then you want to be
able to see that the visitors to your
website are coming from that specific
country or location we also want to
measure the engagement of our website
Behavior so we get traffic to the
website what are they doing how long are
they staying what pages are they
visiting so this is the overall nature
of really why we want to use is web
analytics to measure how successful our
website is at treating our website
visitors with the same courtesy you
would if you had a brick and mortar
store somebody comes into your store you
want them to find what they're looking
for quickly you want them to be happy
with their experience you certainly want
them to pay for the products very
quickly and easily and efficiently and
you want them to come back and that's no
different than a website so we want our
website to perform in a manner that's
going to suit our audience and that's
why we want to track engagement so why
else well we want to really look at
who's coming are they returning visitors
or new visitors you know ideally you
want a nice mix between 50 new and 50
returning because you know returning
visitors are loyal there's some loyalty
to that they already know your brand
they're coming back to your website new
visitors are curious and you want new
visitors because that means more traffic
so you want a nice balance between that
analytics tools will help you measure
that you want to be able to measure
organic traffic whether you like it or
not whether you know it or not but
Google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing UTM
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non-google campaigns you
want to use UTM tracking and Google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically Google analytics will help
you see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with UTM tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web Analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do I.E are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you could turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
and analytics tools will help us
identify what's not working from our
site perspective and from a channel
perspective and we can take action to
improve performance so that's the whole
idea behind optimizing our site's
performance so let's jump into Google
analytics and let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with UTM tracking all those
good things that we can can get and a
good Analytics tool so Adobe mix panel
spring metrics you know they all work in
a similar fashion and that they're
really measuring website behavior and so
if we're in Google analytics really what
we're doing is we're measuring the
performance of our website broken down
into four components audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and Google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
Rob Sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
San Francisco California came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device and they're a
returning users so they're painting a
picture for you okay so they're not
giving you a list of names that would
not be legal but they are providing you
with a good picture of who is coming and
when I say picture we have to paint that
picture and so if we look at say
demographics for example and I got a
demographics overview here's a picture
I'm painting well I can see that 25 to
34 year olds are the majority of the age
group that is coming to my website okay
I can see on the gender side of it I can
see that 63 percent of my traffic and
again this is year to date that I'm
looking at is coming to my website so
two-thirds of my traffic is female
one-third Mount and they're between the
ages of 25 and 34. so I'm painting a
picture about you know gender and age
coming to my website well I can also
look at Geo so where specifically might
these people be coming from so if I go
to location under Geo I'm going to be
able to see a breakdown of country where
I can even hone it down to city or
specific location and here I could see
the United States is the primary driver
but not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the US and then 16 percent
from Argentina 13 from Mexico 10 percent
from India so we have a nice mix of
traffic from different locations in the
world coming to our website so that's
Geo but more importantly let's take a
look at mobile so if we go to mobile
overview how are people coming to our
website are they on a desktop or a
laptop are they using their mobile
device are they using a tablet and so
Google analytics breaks it down very
nice for you and so we could see
percentages in actual numbers by device
category and so in this case I could see
year to date I can see 62 percent are
coming from desktop 30 35 percent are
coming from mobile and so that's
important because most people start
their Journey from mobile and that is
growing and that's going to continue to
grow so you want to keep an eye on
mobile so to me this is one of the more
important reports under audience because
people who come from Mobile have a
different not only experience because
the website should be responsive to the
mobile device but their mindset is going
to be different they're actively looking
for something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in Google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to acquisition so
acquisition reporting tell tells us how
the traffic was driven to the website so
if audience tells us who is coming to
the website acquisition tells us how
that traffic got to the website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and I'm a Believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines or indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents the
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down by Channel if I go to all
traffic channels report I can see in my
Dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic and this is
year to date then I can see paid search
then I can see direct which means
Somebody went directly to the site I
could see referral email social then I
could see more paid search broken out so
these are the different marketing
channels now analytics allows you to
look at a specific source and medium so
the source would be the actual website
or search engine in the medium would
differentiate how that traffic actually
got to the site so if we're talking
about a search engine did they come to
the site via paid search or do they come
to the site via organic search and so
all we need to do is change our primary
Dimension from default Channel grouping
to source and medium and we could see
specifically the breakout of the
different sources and mediums driving
traffic to the site so here I can see
Google organic it's 71 percent and and
then Google CPC or cost per click at 15
16 of our traffic so then I can look
down I can see email in here being
organic I could see some referring sites
I could see some social in terms of
mobile Facebook okay so we could see a
mix of the different sources of mediums
driving traffic to the site okay so you
don't always have to look at Channel per
se you can look at it via source and
medium and if you're running Google ads
under acquisition analytics has a whole
section of Google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on Google ads
remember we looked at the Keyword
Planner and Google ads so if you're
running campaigns on Google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also see campaigns other
campaigns that we're running so remember
that UTM tracking that we set up for
email well we want to be able to track
the performance of email and any other
non-google campaign with UTM tracking so
when we do that we'll be able to go to
campaigns all campaigns and we'll be
able to see the campaign performance if
we look at source and medium we'll be
able to see what campaigns drove traffic
to the website so here I can see
vertical response email as a driver of
traffic so that's the campaign reporting
and then also if you have search
consoles so we looked at search console
earlier we talked about SEO tools well
remember I said you can link up search
console with Google analytics well
here's search console and we could see
queries devices landing pages countries
so all the performance metrics that we
could see in search console because we
have it linked up with analytics we can
see it right here so this gives us a
nice snapshot of what what keywords are
driving traffic to the site organically
I could see The Impressions I could see
the clicks then I could see the clicked
array and then the average position so
in theory the higher something ranks the
more traffic you're going to get so
that's the idea behind it we want to
make sure that we're ranking for our
coveted keywords and if we are we want
to be able to measure how many times our
listing was seen and how many times it
was clicked so that's the great thing
about you know Google they have a family
of products and those products tend to
talk to one another in the form of
Google search console and Google ads you
can connect them directly to Google
analytics so let's move from acquisition
to behavior so here in Behavior we have
a number of different reports so
Behavior tells us what's the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so really what I would
do do is from there go to site content
all pages and so this gives us an idea
of how many pages were actually viewed
so site content all pages tells us what
page and how many times it was viewed
during a period of time and again we're
looking at year to date so I can see
engagement related metrics associated
with a page so this particular page here
on line one I could see how many pages
unique Pages which is equal to sessions
so I can have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session I could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and I can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page and didn't go any
further they left the website from that
page that they arrived on and so I can
also see percentage of exits meaning
what page did people exit the site for
from so these are all engagement related
metrics so here is where I want to react
and optimize my website performance so I
if I see a page now performing well
meaning it has a high bounce rate or
maybe low time on page then I'm probably
going to optimize it meaning test it or
change it to improve performance so
these are all pages but I could
certainly look at landing pages okay so
landing pages tells us the behavior of
the page when somebody landed on it so a
landing page means that somebody came
from organic search or paid search or
another Channel landed on this page so
here I could see this particular page on
line one had
4970 sessions okay and I can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because page isn't
performing in terms of Bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under Behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how fast or how slow our Pages load so
this is important from an SEO
perspective because if a page isn't
loading very fast then chances of it
getting ranked in Google are not very
good so Google's organic search
basically takes page load time seriously
so if a page doesn't load very fast then
we need to be able to fix it so we can
go to page timings I can get a good
sense of the average page load time of a
particular page and what Google does
here is under speed suggestions they
actually will give me some ideas and
speed suggestions on how to address a
page that's loading very slow and so
when we load up the speed suggestions
report what Google does is say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here I can see if I
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that I can
address when trying to improve the page
load time of that particular page so
here I could see there's some server
response time issues image sizes
probably need to be resized I can remove
unused CSS okay so there are a lot of
different things I can do to improve the
page load time on this particular page
okay this is for desktop I can also see
mobile so mobile a lot of the same
issues so if we address these these
opportunities then we could see a lift
in page load time we see lift and Page
load time we're going to probably see a
lift in organic rankings or even user
engagement because if a page takes a
long time to load a user is probably not
going to stay on that page very long so
to me site speed is an important report
under Behavior now one more report here
that I want to point out under behavior
is events and to me events are important
so if you're trying to measure
engagement on your website you need to
make sure you have event tracking set up
and when we talk about event tracking
we're talking about measuring things
that analytics doesn't measure by
default so if you have a button on your
website if you have a PDF download if
you have a submit button on a phone form
submission if you have a subscribe
button if you have a video if you have
an external link anything that is going
to trigger engagement on your website
you need to measure with event tracking
and event tracking is simply set up by
breaking out the event into a category
and action and a label and so here we
could see for our particular website we
have categories already set up for event
tracking so here for example I can say
on line six video I could see how many
people actually watched our video okay
so here's the action video Start okay so
over this period of time I could see I
had 49 unique events 50 total so that's
how many people actually watched the
video and you can always report to label
and that'll tell you what page people
watched in this case the video so event
tracking is important because we want to
be able to measure engagement so if we
go to events under behavior and you
don't see any events listed you probably
need to get that set up and that is set
up through Google tag manager so what
you want to do is you want to be able to
set up your events through Google tag
manager which is another Google platform
but you certainly want to do that so
that's where you set up your events when
you set up your events for your website
with a category in action and label
you'll be able to measure those events
in analytics under Behavior under events
and the important thing here is you'll
be able to measure engagement so I'll be
able to see how many people came to the
site and how many people clicked on a
button downloaded a PDF submitted a form
played a video did whatever we wanted
them to do so events are important so
let's move from the Behavior to
conversions and this is important
because we want to be able to measure
conversions on a website so analytics
has four types of conversions so if I go
to admin down at the bottom and then I
go to goals I could see that I have four
different types of goals that I can use
now right now I have event related goals
set up for the website for this
particular website so we just talked
about event tracking so if you're
measuring a button click on your website
you can certainly turn that into a goal
and so all you need to do is tell
analytics hey this is the particular
category this is the particular action
so for example if I click on this
particular goal and take a look at it I
can see that we have a category set up
that anything that resembles donate now
okay or donate go ahead and fire this
event as a conversion okay so event is
one type of goal another type of goal is
destination so somebody goes to a
specific page like a confirmation page
we can turn that into a goal so here I
could see if somebody goes to donation
Dash confirmation then analytics is
going to fire that goal as a conversion
and we're going to see a conversion
against a different metric or a
different dimension like Channel or
audience okay so destination is the
second type of goal the third type of
goal is duration so how long did
somebody stay on my website so in this
example if they stayed at least one
minute and 30 seconds or more then
analytics is going to count that as a
goal conversion okay so duration is the
third type and then the fourth type is
pages per session okay so if I look at
this example here if a user came to my
website and looked at more than three
pages in that particular session then
analytics is going to fire a gold
conversion so four types of goals you
don't have to set up all four different
types my recommendation is at least have
one goal set up if you're not sure what
goal to set up then at least set up a
duration or pages per session okay so at
least you can measure how long somebody
stays on your website or how many pages
they went to okay so when you actually
do have these goals set up you can go
back into conversions we can go back
into goals we can go back into overview
and we can measure our goal completions
over this period of time so here I could
see 313 goal completions total with a
goal conversion rate of 1.88 and then I
could see it broken down by goal type so
remember the only goals I have available
and set up all are event related goals
so 69 newsletter signups 156 donate
click buttons I have 32 contact form
submissions 37 email click completions
and then 11 phone number click
completions so I can measure engagement
as a goal and so goals generally are
important to the business so you want to
make sure that if you have a goal for
your website then you want to be able to
set that up as a goal in Google
analytics so that way when you're
looking at example channels if I go back
to my channels report I can then measure
Channel by goal conversion so these are
all goals but if I want to look at for
example how many people from organic
search clicked on the Donate Now button
I could see that I could see
year-to-date 10
887 users which meant 11 1000 sessions
76 clicked on that donate Now button and
that comes out to 0.65 conversion rate
okay so that's important so you want to
be able to measure any Dimension whether
that be Channel Source medium keyword
campaign mobile device could be
demographic gender or age you want to be
able to measure any Dimension against
the goals you have set up so you can
measure performance and that also
includes Pages or landing pages as well
so that's a quick overview of what you
can expect to see in Google analytics
again audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so a lot of data in Google
analytics but you want to be able to
take advantage of the data in order to
improve website performance now let's
jump over to YouTube analytics because
if you have videos on YouTube If you you
have a channel set up some playlists
you'll be able to get some really good
insights as to how your videos
performing and so here I could see I'm
in YouTube all I did was I went to my
account then I went to the beta the
studio version of YouTube and then from
there I went to analytics so my account
YouTube Studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
I could see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8 600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over 17
000 and I've netted 48 subscribers and
this is an overall okay so I can
actually see when I publish videos and I
can see the date they were published and
here I'm looking at you know total views
over this particular date range I can
also see specifics on a particular video
so I could see the top video in terms of
minutes here I could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here I could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview I could certainly look at some
other information if I click on reach
viewers I could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so here I
could see the different traffic sources
so 29 came externally okay here I could
see 25 came within YouTube itself I
could see how many times the video was
viewed and played via playlist via
suggested video so I could see different
ways in which the traffic found my video
and actually watched it here I could see
externally how people were able to find
my video us and I could see 46 percent
found it via Google search see some lots
of information here about sources of
traffic how the traffic got to these
videos so I could see then once the
traffic found my videos how many times
they actually saw it and viewed it and
then watched it so that's how many times
I was able to reach viewers via
different sources and then their
reaction to that how many times they saw
it and watched it here I can click on
interest viewers so again I could see
the top videos in terms of watch time I
could see the top playlist so here I
could see my partners playlist was the
top playlist so I could see some
interest here in terms of average view
duration and then here we have build an
audience so we can look at specific
audiences if we have been built in
YouTube to see how many people actually
watch my videos so here I get see 88
percent of the people who watched my
videos over the last 28 days were not
even subscribed so that tells me a lot
of people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them if they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in YouTube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good Insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if I just click on one particular
video I can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself I could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via YouTube search I could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it I could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or an
overview of my channel so that's all all
available to you in YouTube analytics
under YouTube studio so take advantage
of us if you're publishing videos on a
regular basis you want to hone in on how
your videos are performing so if you
have any additional questions about
YouTube analytics or YouTube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
YouTube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into YouTube itself especially
YouTube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about YouTube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spine tools very important
to keep tabs on what the competition's
doing and there are a lot of tools out
there so when it comes to social we can
use a freemium tool like Sprout social
to listen in on our competitors we can
use another freemium tool all social
blade there's a popular tool out there
called spyfu that's freemium as well Moz
we looked at Moz earlier for keyword and
organic Moz is a great tool for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and buzzsumo so that's another
freemium tool get there lots of tools
out there these are just examples of
some of the tools that we use here at
simply learn I use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition's doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in the ranking so the reason why
we have this is the top bullet point is
because SEO organic search is a
long-term strategy on page off page
website very tactical and creative
there's a lot going on with SEO a lot
going on and sometimes it takes a long
time to rank for something and a lot of
SEO does depend on relevancy relevancy
being how many quality backlinks are
linked to you so it's always good to
leverage what your competitors are doing
so you can see how you stack up and so
that's why this is up there as number
one we want to be able to really take a
look at what our competitors are doing
another example would be hey how much a
traffic a competitors gaining on certain
keywords this could go either way for
paid search organic search what are
competitors bidding on are they really
getting traffic from those keywords so
there are tools out there that help us
leverage what our competitions doing
okay we can also identify our
competitors top performing content for
Relevant topics okay we can determine
what our competitors website referral
traffic is okay we can pull our
component editor's data and compare it
with their own campaigns so lots of
tools out there to help you do this and
we may want to track the total amount of
clicks a competitor receives and how
much they pay for each keyword so let's
go ahead and take a look at a few
examples how we can leverage all these
bullet points that we just discussed and
so we're going to start out with Sprout
social and Sprout social is a tool I use
it's a social media platform there's a
lot of things you can do with Sprout
social definitely generate reports for
your social media platforms you could
set up post that get published at a
certain time and day but there's also
one particular tool in here called
listening and so what we could do is we
just put in for example RV rentals in
Twitter so what we're doing is we're
actually listening to see who else is
tweeting about RV rentals so we could do
this for Twitter we could do it Facebook
some other social media platforms the
whole idea here on Sprout social is to
get a sense of what our competitors are
doing so we could have easily put in a
brand name we're just going General here
because we want to rank for the keyword
RV rentals and so here we could take a
look at you know what some of these
particular brands are doing like go RV
rentals Cruise America RV we could see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword RV rentals now if I
want to hone in on a particular
competitor I could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand name
so RV share so here I can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting or tweeting how long ago the
time of day get an idea of what they're
actually saying what campaigns they're
promoting okay I can get a sense of
everything about out this tweet and so
here I can scroll down and I can see
what's been shared by other people for
this particular brand and I can see a
lot of people are as an example
retweeting this particular giveaway and
so to me it just gives me a sense in
this particular example on Twitter as to
what are competitors doing okay let's
start our attention to SEO so remember
that first bullet point we want to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
when it comes to backlinks and so Moz
has a great tool called link Explorer
and Link Explorer there allows us to
actually compare link profiles so for my
domain I can go ahead and put my
competitors domains in there and
definitely get a sense of you know how
many links my competitors have external
Intel internal I can get a sense of the
domain Authority I can get a sense of
page Authority linking domains so I can
really do a uh comparison across my
domain and my competitors domains to get
a snapshot of how I compare against my
competitors so this gives me an overview
of everything I need to know organically
now Moz also has a another great tool
under link Explorer called link
intersect and I like link intersect I
use it a lot because if our competitors
really have a number of external links
and domains pointing to their site and
they have a better domain Authority and
Page Authority then you know I want to
be able to you know see what they're
doing where they're linking who's
linking to them I want to get be able to
get a snapshot of why is their domain so
much better than ours in terms of
authority and so the link intersect
actually allows me to do that so I can
go ahead and put my competitors domains
in there and then I can find
Opportunities and so you just click on
opportunities and you can see where my
site intersects with their site and if
it doesn't actually intersect then I
have an opportunity to actually try and
get a link on that particular site so
that's what the link intersect report
does it allows me to see where my links
intersect with my competitors and if it
doesn't intersect then I have an
opportunity to generate a backlink so
that's ideally what the link intersect
tool is in Moz it allows me to really
get a sense of you know where I'm
linking and where my competitors linking
now what we can also do is also take
advantage of another report under moz's
link Explorer and the discovered and
lost report so we could put in our
domain or we could put even our
competitors domain in there and we can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so really within Moz
we can get a good snapshot of what
websites are linking to our competitors
we get a good snapshot of the overall
links to our competitor sites and
specifically what sites so the whole
idea is if it's good for our competitors
meaning they're linking from a site that
has a good domain Authority and low spam
score then it's probably a site I want
to be able to tackle as well okay so you
have discovered and lost okay you have
comparing link profiles and you have
link intersect so those are three good
reports you can leverage right in moz's
link Explorer tool now there's one more
report we can leverage in Moz and that's
the inbound links report and so we can
go ahead and type in our competitors
domain here and again we can get a
snapshot of what their domain Authority
is Page Authority for the home page but
really this is what we're after linking
domains so this particular domain has
over 9 000 linking domains so what we
can do is actually go through and see
based on domain Authority I can sort by
domain Authority where these pages are
being linked from and so here I can see
Reddit read it read it so a lot of
Reddit here which is a good site for
backlinking New York Times so you know
there's a lot of different uh sites here
Washington Post so I can get a good
snapshot of my competitor by seeing
every link that's pointing to them now
of course I don't want to go through 9
000 links I can really just hone in on a
specific link Source or link type or
link state so I can really filter it if
I wanted to I can export the report and
do some further analysis but really the
whole idea here as I could see what URL
is linking to this particular competitor
site what the anchor text is with the
page and domain Authority is so this
gives me a really really good Insight on
all the backlinking that my competitor
has and again if I'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so if we're not on Reddit
then we probably need to be on Reddit
because if that's where our competitor
is and they're getting good link juice
from Reddit which has a domain authority
of 90. then hey if it's good for the
goose it's good for the gander so they
say so inbound links is just another
good report you can leverage in Moz
under the link Explorer reporting tool
now if I want to get a good snapshot as
to what my competitor is doing on search
exactly well look no further than spy
food so spyfu is a another tool that you
can leverage from a PPC SEO perspective
you know from an SEO perspective you got
some back linking data as well just like
you did in Moz from a PPC perspective
you can get some good keyword insights
and so here I just went ahead and typed
in the domain and what this is going to
do is just give me an overall snapshot
but for my competitor's domain so here I
could see you know how many organic
keywords they're found for the estimated
monthly SEO clicks they're getting based
on the volume of those keywords okay I
could see here the keywords their top
competitors also rank for the rank
history 12 years so this particular
domain's been around a long time okay so
that's on the Organics I can flip over
to the paid side and I could see that
they are doing paid search I could see
5000 plus keywords they're bidding on
okay based on that what they're actually
paying and then I could see you know
some of the other competitors listed
here from a paid perspective and an
organic perspective I could see the
shared keyword overlap okay now again
you can pay for this because it's
freemium and get some really good
insights as to how your domain compares
to your competitors so I'm using the
free version and here the free version
spy Fusion just giving me some overall
data on the specific domain I entered in
and so I entered in my competitors you
can certainly enter in your own domain
to get a sense of organic keywords and
paid keywords so you can see top
keywords top paid keywords okay this is
Google ads okay so this is what
recommendations as to what to purchase
okay here you can see some even some at
Google ads history I could see exactly
what ad copy my competitor actually
wrote and for what keyword and then I
could see some organic ranking history
here as I keep scrolling down this
overview report so I can see for RV rent
where they rank and then I can see
inbound links just like I did in Moz spy
Focus providing me with some insight as
to hey what links are pointing to them
and what the domain strength is and how
many clicks they expect to receive so
this is all free data take it or leave
it but it's all free data available to
you under spyphus a spy view gives you
kind of an overview for free some really
in-depth analysis if you actually pay
for it and it just really hones in on
what your competitors are bidding for
paid wise and what they're ranking for
organic wise and so spy food is a really
good tool to leverage if you just want
to get a snapshot of how your competitor
uh overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to Google analytics because in
Google analytics under audience I can go
to benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all Anonymous data so I can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if I hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and I hone in on a specific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that I get then I can see hey
analytics in this case in this example
I'm sharing
8863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8 000 web
properties and I can compare those web
properties against my own so if we're
all in the same industry it gives me a
sense here as to how I stack up against
the industry as a whole in this case as
it pertains to channels so you can see
here red not good green is good so in
the industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and we can
adjust our Locale and if we do that
Google's going to be able to adjust how
many web properties are actually
contributing to the report and so when
analytics makes that adjustment it we're
going to be able to see in this case
just New Zealand so we're going to
adjust for New Zealand and we're gonna
go with the 4999 and so we could see
there are about you know 300 something
web properties contributing 47 web
properties now contributing to this
report so for focused on the New Zealand
region and this is the amount of traffic
we get we're now comparing us against 47
other Anonymous web properties so now if
I go back to the report after I've honed
in I'm looking at channels and I can see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how I compare against the
competition I can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session and recession
duration bounce rate but that's just
channels I can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your our industry so you're
getting a good idea as to how you
compare against your industry just by
making some adjustments in the
benchmarking report you obviously want
to make sure you're looking at the same
industry adjust for your country or
region adjust for the site size meaning
how many sessions you actually get on a
daily basis and then analytics will do
the rest they'll compare you against
those in your industry and so I find
this to be a good tool because it allows
me to stack up our site against those in
the industry and obviously if we're not
driving as many sessions especially say
from organic then we have our work cut
out for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmarking report now if
you want to get some good insight as to
what the competitors are doing and you
don't want to use a tool well look no
further you can always go to google.com
Okay so this is how we used to do it
back in the day before all these tools
became available you just typed in a key
word and we're going to type in RV
rentals and now we're going to be able
to see who's bidding on that keyword so
we could see we have a number of
different uh companies bidding on the
keyword we're interested in okay here I
can see some featured Snippets okay and
then I could see some organic search
results okay if I scroll down I'll be
able to see some other companies bidding
on that same keyword meaning they're
paying for RV rentals so if I clicked on
somebody's link here they're actually
going to pay Google for the click and so
this just gives me a good sense of you
know how many people are actually trying
to rank for this keyword or trying to be
found for this keyword so that's all I
did I just did a search now from an
organic perspective if you really want
to hone in on your competition you can
always do the syntax all in title colon
and then hit enter so now I could see I
have 163
000 results and when does that tell me
that tells me that I have a 163
000 websites with RV rentals in the
title tag so if you're trying to
optimize for the keyword RV rentals as
an example then you know that you have a
000 different listings ahead of you that
you need to jump over in order to rank
for the keyword RV rentals so using the
All entitled syntax and the keyword
right after that actually just gives you
a more accurate picture of how many
sites are actually ahead of you for a
particular keywords so that's the whole
idea so if I get rid of the syntax and
you can see for RV rentals I have 132
million but that's not really accurate
because not all these listings have the
keyword RV rentals in the title Tag and
Title tag if you're working on organic
search is one of the key important
factors for ranking so you need to have
that keyword in the title tag so that's
the whole idea behind you using the All
entitled syntax it gives us a good idea
as to what our competition is doing and
how many sites we have to jump over to
get to number one on Google Now if
you're running Google ads just as we did
with RV rentals we went up there and we
saw we typed that in as a query and we
saw how many advertisers there were for
RV rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns Google ads actually has a good
report that I really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and when auction
insights allows us to see is what
competitors or domains are bidding on
the same keywords we are and so what
Google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here I'm looking
at year to date and here we could see us
and I can see our competitors okay so I
could see impression share so for if
we're talking about one key word every
keyword has a hundred percent impression
share how much of that impression share
are you getting and when we say
impression share meaning eyeballs when
we talk about eyeballs are we getting a
majority of the eyeballs or our
competitors get a majority of the
eyeballs so we can see our average
position I can see how often I overlap
with my competitors okay I could see how
often I'm above a particular competitor
I could see what percentage I'm at the
top of the page versus my competitors
the absolute top of page rate and then I
can see how often I outrank my
competitors and vice versa how often my
competitors outrank me so I could see
all this good insight as to what
competitors are bidding on the same
keywords I am okay so this is if you're
running Google ads okay so if you're
running Google ads okay you can just
click on the auction insights report you
can find them at the top navigation just
by clicking on campaigns and by doing so
you'll be able to gain some insights as
to where you stack up from a paid search
perspective against your competitors so
let's turn our attention to paid
marketing tools so if you're doing some
advertising on Google Bing LinkedIn you
probably want to work within those
platforms as the tool of choice so you
know if you're doing paid search on say
googlesearch.com or display you could be
doing display advertising on you know a
network like adroll or Google or you
could be doing social media paid ads say
on Facebook so whatever it is you're
doing you probably want to work within
that platform itself to get the ideal
data that you need okay so here are some
of the tools some of the places you can
go of course if you work in Google ads
you also have Google ads ads editor that
you can leverage okay and I'll show you
that in a couple minutes you have Google
ads Keyword Planner of course both of
these are paid if you're running
campaigns okay so Bing if you're running
campaigns on Bing okay you get all this
good data that you can digest through
some reporting okay you also have some
third-party tools out there that you
also have to pay for and word stream
okay so word stream is a third party
tool that you can leverage Bing and
Google are actual advertising Network so
you would advertise on the platform
itself and get all the data you need
right in the platform and leverage a lot
of the tools that they have available in
the platform as I mentioned you could
also use Google ads editor so Bing also
has their own editor as well so and as
well as Facebook so you can use an
editor type version and I'll show you
that here in a couple minutes but let's
talk about why why we want to use the
tools in the platform itself well we
want to be able to monitor how our ads
performing so which ad receives the most
traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting are they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that okay so we want to monitor our
cost okay across different locations and
devices not only cost but we want to
also monitor how our ads are performing
across different locations of devices
keywords across different locations and
devices so we want to be able to measure
by device okay so we also want to
analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitor section
Google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so Google it's self does
provide some information in the case of
auction insights as to how your
competitors are performing against you
on Google search so that's on the paid
search side then you have display okay
so display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so there are
different types of networks out there
for example Admiral okayo seltra is
another paid version of or pay tool you
can use in wide orbit so these are some
of the paid marketing tools you can
leverage of course I like to stay if I'm
advertising on Google I like to stay on
Google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on
adroll for example then you want to
leverage ad roles reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and AD performance so
same kind of concept here we want to be
able to monitor whether we have the
right keywords and write customer
engagement so when when it comes to
display we want to be able to make sure
we're choosing the right audience of
course that means looking at not only
audience insights but our Target
insights as well are we reaching the
Right audience when it comes to display
and Google has a good breakdown that I'm
going to be able to show you here in a
couple minutes okay so we want to
improve our campaigns by monitoring our
competitors display ads as well so there
are tools available that'll help you do
that and that's on the display side if
we look at Social okay why what tools
can we use on social well you got
Facebook ads manager okay you got ad
espresso quiet tweepy you get all these
cool paid search tools again I usually
stick with where I'm advertising so if
I'm advertising on LinkedIn or Twitter
I'm going to leverage that platform but
just know that there are other tools
available for you so with social like
display it's all about targeting our
audience so for these some of the tools
like on Facebook we can review and
relaunch our ad campaigns based on
target audience we can measure
conversions and gain insights in this
example about Facebook users how are our
users interacting with our ads and then
we want to Target People based on their
activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel preferences Etc so
social allows us to do that and then
with Facebook as an example we can
monitor any a B test we run for example
if we're running call to action tests we
can measure the results that right in
Facebook and I'm going to show you an
example of that here shortly so let's
jump right into Google ads and look at
some tools available to us from the
search side of the house so for running
search campaigns right in Google ads we
could see campaign data we could see
keyword data we could see add data so
for example if I want to see what ads
are performing I'm just going to click
on my ads and extensions okay and here
are my ads and now I could see what ads
are performing in terms of clicks
click-through rates
Etc and so that way I can go ahead and
pause ads activate ads so that's right
here in the Google ads platform itself
now if I want to look at specific
keywords I can do that so I can see what
keywords are driving traffic and clicks
here I could just sort by clicks and now
I can see not only what keywords are
driving clicks I could see what the
click-through rate is I can see the
Impressions how many people actually
viewed my ad after click typing in a
keyword query that I'm betting on I
could see how much I've paid made by
keyword and more importantly I want to
be able to see conversions or conversion
rate and then with Google ads you have
quality score so we want to be able to
measure qualities for so this is a
Google ads keyword reporting and so the
great thing about the keyword reporting
is that there's some other features
available to me here so here I can add
negative keywords okay just by clicking
on negative keywords I can also see a
Search terms report and so when it comes
to search terms I can actually see what
specific keywords people typed in and
based on the keyword that somebody typed
in as a query I can see what match type
triggered that particular ad and so if I
see a keyword query that I don't
particularly care to be shown for or I
want my ad shown for then I can go ahead
and just select it and I can add it as a
negative key were okay so that tool is
available to you right in Google ads
okay and then you have the auction
Insight so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see basically you know who
else is bidding on the keywords and what
the impression share is what their
average position is what their overlap
rate is position above right top of page
absolute top of page right now Rank and
share so once we have Google has data
then they'll be able to share that
information with you okay so that's just
key words but there's a cool tool that I
really like and I leverage it for SEO
and pay-per-click and that's Google's
Keyword Planner so if you click on tools
and then you click on Keyword Planner
we'll be able to Leverage The Keyword
Planner and the whole idea behind the
Keyword Planner is do we want to
discover new keywords or for the
keywords we have selected we can get
volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if I click get started okay so
Google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much I
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
I happen to click on that keyword I can
add it to a plan and then once I've
added to a plan then I can go ahead and
look at that plan and measure what kind
of volume I'm going to get and how much
I can expect to pay so now once I've
added my keyword to that plan I can go
ahead and see how many clicks and
Impressions and costs and click the rate
and average cost per click I can expect
to spend so and this is based on a
maximum cpc2 dollars so I can go ahead
and adjust my plan accordingly if I want
to in order to see basically how much I
can expect to spend so that's the whole
idea behind the Keyword Planner in terms
of choosing new keywords and once you
choose keywords you're interested in
bidding on you can actually do a
forecast to see exactly how much you can
expect to spend how many clicks how many
Impressions you can expect to get and if
you have conversion set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of Google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so there are so many
different tools and features within
Google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so really I'm just going to
highlight some of the more important
tools and features so I mentioned the
Keyword Planner I imagine the campaigns
keywords and ads reports another thing I
would look at in Google ads again and we
mentioned this as one of our key
defining why would we use it bullet
point and that's because of devices so
we mentioned devices why would we use
Google ads reporting tool because we
want to look at devices and we want to
be able to see what devices are driving
traffic from what campaign and then the
cool thing about Google ads is right in
Google ads platform you can go ahead and
do a bit adjustment so if I increase my
bid adjustment for example on mobile
phones then my particular ad in this
particular campaign is going to show
more than on computer so I can always
decrease it for example do a bit
adjustment on computer and that means
I'm going to show my ads less so I can
go ahead and do bid adjustments based on
device that's the cool thing of working
writing Google ads platform is you can
make adjustments right here in the
platform based on devices well you also
have local locations too so we mentioned
that as one of the reasons why we want
to use some of these tools and if I see
a particular location I'm not interested
in advertising well I can always select
it and I can always just pause it or
remove it so or I can change the bit
adjustment on a location as well so I
can make a lot of different changes
right in the Google ads platform for
those seasoned and search advertising
paid search advertising especially on
Google ads you can always use Google ads
editor all you need to do is just do a
search for Google ads editor you can
download it so basically what Google ads
editor is it's a it's a tool it's the
software that you work your can with
your campaigns on locally so you're
making changes to your campaigns on your
computer and basically when you're done
making changes you can always upload
them to Google ads to the account on
Google ads in the cloud so to speak so
that's the whole idea behind Google ads
editor it's a great tool for you to use
if you want to make household changes
really quick for example I'm looking at
an account with a bunch of campaigns so
now if I click on one of those campaigns
I could see the ad groups here okay so
for example I just wanted to turn off
all these ad groups I can just highlight
them all and just click status enable to
paused and I can revert back if I want
to okay so you can make household
changes so here I could see the campaign
the ad group level if I choose an ad
group then I can see some keywords and
again I can make changes at nauseum here
I can copy I can paste I can delete okay
so I can make a lot of changes really
quick write in Google ads editor and
that's the whole point of editor is to
go ahead and work locally while somebody
else is working locally on the same
account you could both be working
simultaneously and being more efficient
on getting things done in the campaign
now if you are working with somebody
else on the campaign you want to make
sure that you get recent changes so if I
say get recent changes to all campaigns
what Google editor is going to do is
contact Google ads in the cloud and
download all those changes so here I get
to see the changes being download and
editor from Google ads and when it's
done it's going to highlight all the
changes that have been made and so once
I'm done reviewing those changes I can
go ahead and click done and now I know I
have the recent latest changes in editor
so now I can go ahead and continue to
make some changes and when I'm done
making changes I can go ahead and post
them so that's the beauty of Google ads
editor Bing has a version Facebook has a
version it allows you to again go with
the keyword level the ad group level
okay you can look at ads itself and make
changes to the ads okay you could do a
lot of different things write an editor
in fact you could do pretty much most of
what you could do in Google ads you can
do in Google ads editor and so that's
Google ads Editor to me I would
recommend it if you're experienced with
Google ads again it's software you have
to download it you're going to use it on
your computer as software but when you
make changes all you need to do is post
those changes or get recent changes that
have been made on Google ads and so
that's Google editor ads editor and
summary now let's go back into Google
ads and talk about display advertising
because display is a different network
but the platform's still the same and
some of the same tools are available
from the search Network as well as for
the Display Network right in Google ads
so if I want to take a look at a
campaign and AD group on the Display
Network I can just click on that ad
group and I can look at the ads that are
running for that particular regular Eye
Group on the Display Network so here the
difference being on the display network
is you can use image ads on the search
Network you can only use text ads so
here I can look at image ads and I can
see how they're performing in fact you
could even go a step further and use
responsive display ads so Google has
responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now I can see clicks
Impressions click-through rate Etc right
on on my ads and extensions report in
Google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so we want to be
able to see okay of the audiences we
have set up up what audience is
performing best okay so here I can see a
Breakout by audience again I could see
the same metrics I could see on the
search side I could see clicks
Impressions click the rate more
importantly I want to be able to measure
conversions okay so that's the whole
idea when you're in these platforms and
you're paying for ads is you want to be
able to measure against conversions and
you can also measure against cost per
conversion conversion rate okay so those
are some key metrics to measure up
against whether it's audience keyword
add whatever the dimension is so here on
the Display Network we can get a sense
of demographics okay so unlike the
search Network the Display Network
allows us to see demographic data and so
now I could see an age breakout or an
age range breakout that Google provides
us and I can see again based on the age
range breakout which age range has the
most clicks Impressions
Etc including conversions so you also
have the opportunity on the display and
I worked at keywords you have the
opportunity to add topics and you have
the opportunity to see placements or run
placements so here if I click on where
ADS have shown I can actually see where
my ads have shown up for this display
campaign and Google ads allows you the
ability to go ahead and you can exclude
it from the ad group exclude a specific
placement from a campaign so you could
take action on a specific placement and
I could see the type of placement
whether it's a mobile app whether it's a
site I can go ahead and see exactly
where that placement was so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the Google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media media paid search
advertising I just want to remind you we
do have you know a nice tutorial on
Google ads okay so take a look at the
Google ads tutorial we have set up on
YouTube okay if you search for Google
ads tutorial 2019 this is a good uh
tutorial on everything related to Google
ads so check out this video because in
today's webinar we're just mentioning
tools across the board and if you are
advertising on Google ads as most people
do then you can see just how powerful it
is and all the different features that
are available so take a look at the
video it's a nice complimentary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on Google ads and if you have any tools
or features on Google ads whether it's
the search Network or whether that's the
Display Network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in Google ads so let's move into uh
Facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on Facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here so here we could see if
we're in the Facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we could see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on Google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if I click on one of these ad
sets I'll be able to see an actual ad
that's running here and so for the
actual ad that's running I can then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so Impressions
similar to Google ads how many people
are actually looking at the ad and I can
see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so now I can go
in and I can go ahead and look at the ad
performance and go ahead and change out
that ad if it's not performing to my
expectation so if I click on more tools
and then creatives I can just simply
click on creatives and then I can
actually see the creatives I actually
have running for that campaign I
selected so now I can see all the
creatives that are running and I can see
the results of those creatives so
Facebook ads manager also has a
different reporting so if I click on the
reports pull down menu you can see here
I could see some standard reports by add
ad set age gender and then I can see all
reports here listed out by placement by
placement and device time a day country
Etc so if we just look at age and gender
we'll be able to get a breakout age and
gender here so you can see by campaign
I'm looking at all campaigns here and
I'm looking at just age and gender I can
certainly deselect one of these and I
can look at a specific time range so now
I could see who's looking at my ad
specifically so here I could see 35 to
44 female I can see the reach
Impressions and how often they're
actually seeing my ad now this is key
for Facebook because if somebody's seen
your ad a lot they're probably going to
tune out to it so that's what makes the
frequency metric so important on
Facebook because then we can go ahead
and you know turn off that particular
age and gender if we needed YouTube and
we could see how much we spent so this
just gives you some idea of the type of
reporting that's available in Facebook
ads manager now the great thing about
Facebook uh reporting and ads manager is
you know I can group or ungroup uh my
Dimensions if I needed to I could change
the view and arrange columns I can get
rid of columns just as you would in
Google ads reporting very similar
stature here so I have a lot of
flexibility here on how I review the
reports you know you got different
metrics that you can pick and choose as
well okay and you got lots of different
flexibility when you're looking at the
reports on how your campaigns are
performing now here I can pick and
choose I can choose campaign ad set ads
objective again I can choose different
demographics so I have a lot of options
available to me in terms of how I want
to you know view the performance of my
campaign view the performance of my ad
set or my ad now remember if you're in
Facebook you can always go in and edit
the campaign you can edit the ad set
remember in the ad set that's where a
lot of your decisions are going to be
made including how you want to drive the
traffic okay what your budget is okay
you can basically choose your audience
here so you're going to be able to
choose what type of campaign it's going
to be and based on the campaign you're
going to go ahead and choose the kind of
audience you want to focus in on you're
going to be able to choose the location
the age range the gender so all of this
is going to be set up in the ad set or
the campaign or the ad if you go ahead
and edit an ad remember you can do a b
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you writing ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
Facebook so if you want some more
information about all the different
features and tools and Facebook ads
manager check out the Facebook ads
tutorial 2019 a webinar that we did
earlier this year in addition you can
also look at another one that we did on
Facebook called Facebook advertising
tips and strategies so that should give
you some sense of everything related to
Facebook ads and how to take advantage
of the Facebook ads manager platform so
if there's anything on social that we
may have missed or that you use feel
free to add a comment below the video
we'd love to hear your feedback okay
let's talk about some affiliate
marketing tools let's turn our attention
affiliate marketing a lot of affiliate
marketing platforms out there the number
one probably is Commission Junction also
known as CJ the they're an affiliate
platform they have an a freemium model
meaning you can have a free trial but
basically you're gonna have to move on
and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click Inc a
win so a lot of these are Brokers per se
and when I say Brokers like for example
with CJ you as a merchant or you as a
publisher can get in touch with a
merchant you as a merchant can get in
touch with a publisher meaning CJ helps
bridge the gap between you finding
somebody to build your network with okay
so that's what really affiliate
marketing is and you really need a
platform to kind of put it all together
and and so a lot of a lot of affiliate
marketing platforms we're actually going
to take a look at CJ and go through some
of the features in the platform here
shortly but let's just take a look at
why we need these affiliate marketing
tools well these affiliate marketing
tools identify you know Affiliates
influors employees other Advocates you
want to partner with so again you can be
on the merchant side you could be
actually selling a product and you're
going to want somebody to help you sell
that product somebody with a website
who's an influencer who drives a lot of
traffic to their own site who you know
does sell reputable brand Etc so you
need somebody to help you introduce you
to these sites okay so CJ and some of
these other marketing platforms
affiliate marketing platforms do that
okay so these tools are there to do the
introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with Affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do I mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means my only endorsing
that platform there are plenty others
out there but whatever platform you use
you're going to want to be able to set
up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so you can set up
with terms and conditions for say 10 off
all sales as an example okay well you're
getting a platform that will help you
broker that contract okay contract terms
or program terms furthermore you're
gonna need a platform to help you track
hey is this affiliate helping me drive
traffic or is this affiliate driving
traffic to my products and is this
affiliate helping me sell so you the
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain High website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social so
you have a lot of benefits to work
talking with affiliate marketing in
itself and the tools available will help
you gain website rankings as one example
we want to be able to track certain
metrics okay so an affiliate marketing
you have earnings per click EPC as an
example most platforms measure EPC from
a seven day period to a three month
period okay you can also figure out what
the actual cost per click is just like
you do on say Google search you can
actually measure that in affiliate okay
you want to eliminate fraudulent clicks
Impressions and conversions so any
affiliate platform worth its weight is
going to help you understand you know
how many Impressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
Impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so these platforms are
really built on helping you manage your
relationship with the affiliate by
offering uh all sorts of reports and
tools you know the other big benefit
here to affiliate marketing tool is hey
we can influence our customers
throughout their buying Journey so we
could set up different promotions based
on hey did somebody go to the website
did somebody see our product does
somebody click on a product did somebody
go into the shopping cart with our
product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
Journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're going to have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really there to manage your
Publishers who do you want as a
publisher who do you want selling your
product you obviously want somebody
who's relevant somebody who's going to
be able to sell the product somebody who
has a targeted audience that's similar
to yours okay so we go into cj.com we're
going to log in and here you can see a
Publisher's link so we're going to click
on the Publishers link and remember when
you sign up Publishers you have to have
program terms and so if we click on
Publishers program terms we're going to
be able to see all the different program
terms available so here we could see the
different program terms we have set up
for certain Publishers so if we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher so as a
best practice if you have Publishers who
are actually performing well who are
selling your products maybe you want to
offer them a little bit more on the
commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe you know These
Guys these Publishers get better program
terms versus say other Publishers who
don't and so here we can see the program
terms basically you could see what the
terms are the action and the different
policies here so everything you need to
do to manage that publisher in terms of
payment is done under the program terms
now if the program terms are met the
publisher actually sells your products
CJ is the broker they're the ones who
are going to initiate the payment based
on the program terms so be careful in
the program terms you want to be able to
set them appropriately CJ has templates
CJ has some default program terms that
you could use and offer up to different
Publishers So based on the program terms
that's how your Publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
There's No Limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so here
we can see what Publishers are under
what program terms so again if your
publisher is performing well sweeten the
deal offer them a better program program
terms and so you can align Publishers
with different program terms and so
that's the whole idea behind program
terms is you want to be able to align
Publishers with that so when you sign up
a publisher they're going to get a line
with the program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our Network
these are our Publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know who's selling
who's not selling and so we can look at
all our Publishers by program terms or
by status okay so basically you can see
here the term status whether it's active
or not earnings basically what they've
sold over the last basically seven days
or three months so you could look at
basically how your Publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cj.com so when you're
looking at reports in cj.com or really
any other affiliate program you might
see the acronym EPC this stands for
earnings per click actually it's a
little misleading it's actually earnings
per 100 clicks so basically CJ
calculates you know how much are
publisher is actually making per click
you know just like paid search we're
paying Google X amount per click it's
the same thing here we can't or these
Publishers can't make any money if they
don't generate clicks so that's why you
have an EPC model or metric so to speak
so you can measure earnings per click CJ
does it over 70 period and over a three
month period so you could sort based on
seven day or three months to see who's
earning the most per click and in terms
of Publishers now you can select under
Publishers groups now you can group your
Publishers okay so if you have say a
group of Publishers in a specific region
like the United States or India or if
you're just focused on the United States
and say you have Publishers in different
states like Texas California Missouri
Arkansas well you could group those
Publishers into different groups and you
can look at your different group names
here so here we could see Canada and so
we have our Publishers grouped into a
group called Canada why because they're
based in Canada makes sense so you want
to be able to organize your Publishers
because the whole idea behind affiliate
marketing CJ is you want to be able to
get the best Publishers available for
your network and so as you get more
Publishers for your network you'll be
able to basically start grouping in them
where it makes sense now the example I
gave you is by geography you could do by
geography or you could do by publisher
status meaning my best performing
Publishers go into a group if they're in
a group then they get a line with a
certain program term so you could group
your Publishers Any Way You Want by
status meaning they're selling more
these are our best performing Publishers
or by region or you know by promotion I
mean how you group your Publishers is
totally up to you however take advantage
of the option to create publisher groups
because the whole idea again I'm gonna
repeat it is you want to get Publishers
and you want to start building your base
of Publishers because the more
Publishers you have the more chance you
are to sell your product remember if
nobody clicks on your product then
nobody's gonna buy your product so if
you have Publishers who are promoting
your product for for you then you have a
good opportunity to sell it so the more
Publishers you have on board the better
the opportunity so now once you have
Publishers you can start grouping these
Publishers accordingly to whatever makes
sense is a business decision just know
the options available in CJ to group
Publishers let's turn our attention to
social media marketing tools social
media always a great topic to talk about
so we're gonna finish up all our digital
marketing tools with social media we
talked about SEO paid competition
affiliate email you know web analytics
it's just appropriate to finish up with
social media because social media has so
many tools available so many okay the
first one I can think about here is
HootSuite HootSuite is a great social
media marketing tool to use okay it's a
freemium okay you can set up a free
trial here you basically a base account
and then you can use HootSuite to do a
lot of things anything from setting up
landing pages to actually publishing
content to listening HootSuite to me is
one of the most powerful social media
marketing tools available you got buffer
buffer is a paid version but you can
actually set up a low cost or free
account actually on Buffer and then move
to a paid account okay you got tweet
deck it's been around a long time that
is actually free and I would recommend
tweetdeck and we're going to take a look
at that here in a couple minutes okay
and then you got Sprout social Sprout
social is another social marketing
platform somewhere to HootSuite do a lot
of reporting a lot of publishing you can
a lot of listening and so we're going to
take a look at Sprout social today as
well before we do that let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to smartly efficiently you know
schedule and manage your post post okay
so you're not just working lightly with
just one platform like Facebook you're
probably on a number of different
platforms depending on your business
depending on your bandwidth depending on
what you're selling your products Etc
your audience obviously has a lot to do
with it you know it could be Instagram
Pinterest you want to be able to
consolidate all that and manage it in
one place and that's what social media
marketing tools do they allow you to
manage everything in one place so if you
can manage everything in one place then
these social media marketing platforms
need to be able to make it easy for you
to add and manage different accounts
okay so a lot of them have the ability
for you to add you know not just one
Twitter account but multiple Twitter
accounts and not just one social media
platform but multiple social media
platforms and a good social media
marketing so worth its weight will help
you monitor the results so monitor
social media posts that help Drive leads
and say cells in other words you're
going to have a lot of different metrics
associated with each social media
marketing platform okay which one is
actually doing its job okay so you want
to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform is log into one
place get a sense of what's been posted
what the engagement is did they purchase
Etc and what you want to do is be able
to individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in these social media marketing tools
okay you don't want to send out a
blanket message across different
platforms you want to be able to go
ahead and customize a post depending on
what that post is depending what the
product is what time of day what target
market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier you using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
Advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand Advocate
who's not a brand Advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual posts on real-time data so if
for example you post something using one
of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like Sprouts social and HootSuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further Ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are running ads on Facebook or
you're posting on Facebook as an example
or any platform in general that
platform's going to have its own metrics
if you will so for example Facebook has
something called Facebook insights
you'll be able to actually see you know
what's been posted based on you know the
last seven days in this example how many
page views you're getting engagements
recent posts so just to let you know yes
you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
Facebook ads okay you can go right into
Facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that that
you can measure all that in one place so
if we log into sproutsocial I can set up
these accounts right into Sprout social
so I don't have to log into Twitter
individually or Facebook individually I
can link them up all within Sprout
social and then I can go to reports just
like I can with Facebook insights and
then once I'm in Facebook excuse me once
I'm in Sprout social reporting then I
can go ahead just like I can in Facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me I can jump into you know Facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so I don't have
to log into Facebook directly I can see
you know the Impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time I can
see my audience growth I can see my
publishing Behavior how often my
publishing I can see the top post
individually I could see Impressions by
day you know a lot of this same material
same information
is already in Facebook insights so if
it's available on Facebook insights you
know you're definitely going to have it
available in a tool like Sprout social
so you want to be able to just
efficiently log in and jump from one
platform to the other so here you know I
can go to Instagram you know and look at
Instagram data or I can look at Twitter
information so you want to be able to
efficiently jump from one platform to
the other using in this example Sprout
social now as I mentioned as part of one
of the benefits of a social media tool
is that you could publish content you
want to be able to publish content
because you want to be able to organize
and schedule accordingly you don't want
to be submitting and Publishing content
right after one another okay you want to
be able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is Click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do you can schedule
it for tomorrow at a specific time and
there you go voila schedule so this is
on Twitter okay so you know we could
choose another platform here it's just
that easy to schedule so you want to be
able to schedule accordingly because
again when you schedule something then
you want to look at the behavior of it
so it's just as simple as going from
publishing to reporting and then based
on when something got published you
could see the reaction of it and react
to it so another thing here that I like
about it's about social heat Suite A lot
of these other platforms do it really
well you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being had for example uh mail delivery
you know if we do mail delivering
Twitter search we'll be able to see
what's been tweeted about mail
deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can refine our
search and choose a specific location a
radius to hone in if we're local okay so
this is Sprout social's example of
listening here let's take a look at
another example I'm in later.com so
later very similar to sprout social in
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing I like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so I could see
today I have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again I
have five profiles set up for this
account so I can pick and choose the
profile that I want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and I can
visually see it and that's important so
here I can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if I click
on this image here okay I can get a
sense of when it was used and I can view
it on a calendar I can out label for it
so that's another benefit later is that
they have this media library here they
have conversations so I can actually
connect to a platform and listen in on
conversations that are being hacked
similar to The Listening tool in Sprout
social and they have analytics so you
can actually see right in later.com how
your particular social media platform is
performing so I could see it here over
seven days I can see the number of
followers have increased I could see the
growth rate I can see the number of
Impressions that I received okay so I
want to be able to see how my particular
platforms performing over a period of
time so I can look at reach the law
profile views website clicks okay so I
can get a lot of good insights here
right in the analytics platform of later
you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something I
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments in price
Russians the reach and then if I wanted
to I can click on details and get more
specific information on it engagement
rate okay Discovery actions comments
saves Etc so later.com goes into some
nice detail about post performance they
even have data on hashtags so if you use
a hashtag you can actually see how many
times the hashtag's been used or saved
how many Impressions it's received okay
so they really go into some nice detail
here about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool I really like I've been using for a
long time and that's tweet Tech so what
tweet deck does is connect with your
Twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
Twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here I can see this is my feed here
okay I can see some notifications I can
see specific messages then on this call
I'm T activity okay so I can add
different columns here if I wanted to
and basically by adding columns you
could see I can look for what's trending
as an example so I'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now I
can go in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
Twitter so you can actually add a column
and pay attention to something really
specific okay so for example search okay
so right now I have men's health but I
could type in let's just say World Cup
okay so I could see the you got the
qriket World Cup you got you know the
soccer football World Cup going on so
you know we could pick a particular
topic to follow if we wanted to so again
here I'm following Men's Health so I can
now see you know everything that's been
posted on men's health now if I click on
for example one of these hashtags here
that's trending I can actually see who's
tagging or using that hashtag Friday
feeling in their tweets and so the whole
idea behind you know tweetdeck it serves
up a interesting overview so to speak of
not only your account but you know a
specific topic or what's trending or you
know other things that are being said so
if you really want to pay attention to
your brand or something really specific
like you know your competitors or a
specific product then you can just do a
search on that and so that's the great
thing about tweak deck it allows you to
kind of just look and listen in on
everything going on in Twitter now we do
have a good video out here on YouTube
how to start social media marketing so
if you haven't had a chance to look at
it take a look it goes over some of
these tools that we cover today like
Sprout social later.com you know
Facebook insights so it does cover in
more detail some of what we covered on
these social media marketing tools so
take a look at at how to start social
media marketing so we covered a lot of
different marketing Tools digital
marketing tools everything from SEO to
email to social to paid to affiliate to
competitor but there's also a few other
digital marketing tools that you can use
in different ways like video SEO for
example so vid IQ you know we want to
use vid IQ to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into YouTube you can see vid IQ
is a browser extension or browser a
plug-in if you will so I can go and take
a look at a specific a specific video
and see how many hours it's been watched
how many views minutes watch subscribers
Etc you know the great thing here I can
look at the entire entire account so I
can get good insights into my video or
my entire account here just by adding in
the vidi Q extension into my Chrome
browser so vid IQ actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid IQ because it's good
for video SEO okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so you
know if you're doing SEO and you have a
lot of content on your site well you
know what we want to be able to use a
tool maybe a third-party tool to give
some objective reasoning as to what more
we can be doing so you got tools like
SEO site checkup or site analyzer these
are pay tools but you know if you're
really heavily invested in SEO then they
may pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know Google's algorithms and so you
maybe you know want to invest in that
third-party tool so these are good tools
to use for Content optimization you know
there's also other he read it but you
know this Keyword Planner uh in Google
there's also a word stream there's a lot
of different keyword tools out there so
you may not have a Google ads platform
and so if you don't have Google ads then
you may not be able to gain access to
Google's Keyword Planner so having a
third-party keyword tool will pay divins
and say well because those dividends pay
off in the form of not only
pay-per-click but also SEO and if you're
heavily invested in content heavily
invested in Social then you may want to
take a look at the keyword tool keyword
it and it's primarily used for Reddit we
talk about page load time so we looked
at that in Google analytics we know that
it heavily impacts SEO so there are
other tools available you got a
third-party tool here that's free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
page speed insights by Google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of and and determining how you
can improve your page load time my
favorite topic conversion rate
optimization so you got a couple in here
crazy egg and zarget okay so I'm gonna
show you another tool called hot jar so
here if you log into hotshot.com you can
set up an account it's actually free and
with the free account you can have hot
Char measure the heat map not only the
heat map but the click mapping the
scrolling of a particular page and so
here you can see we're looking at a
particular page here so hot jar allows
me to you know see on that page where
people are clicking
um I can also see where people are
moving I can also see you know the
scrolling of a particular page okay so
you can see here on the page I could see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking mostly if
I switch over to move mode then I can
see on that particular page where people
are actually moving their Mouse and then
I have my scroll analysis so I could see
you know how far down people actually
scroll on the page and so again with a
paid account you can measure up to 10
000 page views with the free version you
can measure up to 2000 pages and so 2
000 Pages allows you to get some insight
as to what people are clicking on or
where they're moving or how they're
scrolling on a particular page and so I
definitely recommend hot jar they also
do funneling they also do forms polls
lots of other tools available in hot jar
so hotjar.com is a tool I would
recommend as well so one final tool and
I'd be remiss if I didn't mention it and
that's Google optimized so Google
optimize is a Google platform that
allows you to a B test and so a b
testing means that you have an original
page and you're changing one element on
on that page to see which one performs
better and so with Google optimize it's
just very easy to set up to run and the
whole point of Google optimize and a b
testing is to improve website
performance so here you can see I have
an account set up and optimized you can
see we're running one test here and
we're just testing one element versus
the original so we move photos to the
top of the page the original didn't have
the photos to the top of the page and so
we can go into reporting here Google
optimized does all the heavy lifting and
so here you can see we can look at
bounces or we can look at you know
basically a measure the test up against
the metric that's important to our
business and again the whole point is to
improve website performance and so
definitely take a look at Google
optimize we'll have another webinar in
the future on the topic but you know to
me Google optimize is free you can run
up to five tests okay and if you can run
up to five different tests and that
means you have the ability to really
improve website performance okay so
Google optimize is a tool that I would
recommend today we're going to talk
about why you would want to rank using
SEO and SEO is search engine
optimization also known as organic
search you also May is here a say
organic listings where we're going to
talk a little bit about why you'd want
to rank your website in organic search
okay what is search engine optimization
then we're going to follow that up with
how does Google rank websites so why
does it rank one website over another
and how do we get our website to rank
number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of SEO or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're going to finish that
off with the do's and don'ts of SEO so
let's get right to it and talk about Ys
basically Google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to you
know have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then Google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank those pages that they've indexed
from number one to Infinity depending on
how many pages are relevant to that
search query so really it's about
crawling indexing and ranking so
crawling is simply a process done by
which Google has Bots and what these
Bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how do they find
these Pages well they basically follow
links you might have heard the term
spidering but that's what they call
search engine spidering so basically
what Google's doing is they're building
a web so to speak all the links that
they're following and so when they can
follow all these links on your website
they're going to be able to crawl them
and when they crawl them basically
they're going to take that content and
store it on their servers so it's
available in their index So based on
this method Google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into Google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found then they're not going to show up
for Relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to Google Search and if
I type in the keyword simply learn okay
I could see I have one way in 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learn pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number 1 here organically and there are
one million 10 000 Pages related to the
keyword simply learn now when it comes
to organic search we don't want to get
it confused with paid search so anytime
you see paid search you're going to see
something that says add next to it okay
so we could see that there are paid ads
here but when it comes to organic search
those are generally below paid ads and
so that's where Google counts the one
million 10 000 results and so that's the
whole idea behind crawling and indexing
Google's able to cross simply learns
website and based on all the pages that
they gather they're going to make those
pages available in organic search so if
you type in a keyword and your web page
is not available for indexing then
you're never going to show up for that
keyword so that's why it's important to
make sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search Google search
it's the most relevant websites that are
in Google's index are going to pair in
the search results so in the example I
gave was simply learn well simply learn
is the brand name of the company simply
learned so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is SEO and why
SEO we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learned example simply
learn is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned Pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their Pages the page load time is
fast meaning these Pages load very fast
for the end user and Google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the the website okay and so the
user experience is very very important
there are other factors also like
language and location and so for example
location if you do a search say in India
the results are going to be a little bit
different than say the results in the
United States why because Google is
indexing as many web pages as they can
find so if somebody's doing a search in
India their results may be a little bit
different than the results show up in
the U.S because Google has different
Bots and these Bots are crawling
different pages at different times and
so Google's index is updating
continuously but it's not real time
syncing so if you do a search in India
you may not see exactly the same thing
because both search engines the Google
and India and the Google and the US are
may not be exactly synced up so an
example would be you know if you're
looking for Cafe so if you search a cafe
and say San Francisco
you're going to see different results
now if you do a search for cafes in
Mumbai you're going to see different
results there's going to be local search
here at the top there may be some paid
search but again you may see different
results because one location but two
Google search engines in India and
United States google.com aren't exactly
synced up exactly at the same exact time
you do that search so location is
important language is important and
relevancy is important along with user
experience so all those are important
factors in how Google ranks websites
okay so we're going to talk about the
types of SEO now so if we want to rank
for a particular keyword on Google we're
going to have to apply search engine
optimization and so there's two
strategies to search engine optimization
on-page SEO and off-page SEO so first
we're going to talk about on-page SEO so
on-page SEO is nothing more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on Google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in SEO keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for SEO and
why do I say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand and how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on Google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on Google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page SEO you can
change the title tag The Meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your Q words and so again
the primary components we're looking for
are how much traffic you can get or the
search volume how much competition there
is for that keyword and of course
relevancy okay you need to be able to
choose a keyword that's relevant to the
web page you're trying to rank for and
so let me show you example how to go
through this so the first thing we want
to do is we want to use a tool and the
tool I would recommend is Google Keyword
Planner and why do I choose Google
Keyword Planner because if we're trying
to rank on google.com or Google search
engine we want to be able to get the
data right from the source so Google's
going to be able to give us information
about how much volume a keyword has and
how much competition it has so let me
show you an example so if I want to use
Google's Keyword Planner and I want to
rank for the keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist then I'm
going to type that keyword into Google's
Keyword Planner and what Google is going
to do is they're going to give me some
some Trends about how much volume this
particular keyword gets over the course
of a year and so for that particular
keyword I can see that there are trends
that that appear for both desktop and
mobile so mobile is important because
people start their search process a lot
of times on their mobile device so we
want to be able to get data from mobile
as well as desktop and so we could see a
trend here that for each particular
month over the last 12 months we can see
how much volume this particular keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist gets per month and so on
average on average over the past 12
months I could see how to become a
digital marketing specialist is averages
30 searches a month and this is on
google.com and so Google gives us the
volume what they also give us is the
competition and so here I can see Google
says for that particular a key word the
competition is medium and so in the
Google's Keyword Planner what they also
do is give me other relevant keywords
that I might think about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword so how to become a
digital marketing specialist they're
going to also offer up other types of
keywords that are relevant so just
digital marketing Specialists social
media marketing specialist so for those
keywords I can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist I
can see the average volume is one
thousand per month on average of the
last 12 months I can also see the
competition is medium but for some other
keywords I can see the search volume
being high like digital marketing course
at 2900 per month but also the
competition is high and so what I would
recommend is a best practice is to
collect all your relevant keywords okay
and put all your relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet and when you put all these
relevant keywords in a spreadsheet you
want to get the data on those keywords
and the data I'm referring to is the
volume of competition so in this case we
have volume from Google planner Google's
Keyword Planner and I have competition
from Google's Keyword Planner and so if
I go into a spreadsheet and I put all
that information in here I'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that Google's
Keyword Planner if I go back just gives
us low medium and high and if I want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe I want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what I can do is go into Google and I
can type in that keyword so if I type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist I can see there's
76 Million results so I could see 76
Million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 per month on average and so what
I want to do is get a more clear picture
of the competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when I do that
I get a different result here I can see
only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular
keyword that we want to rank for in the
title tag okay so the title tag is what
you see when you type in a keyword or
search query in Google search and the
title tag is what you see at the top of
every search result and so now I can see
I typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all
entitled syntax and now I can see every
listing every one of these 136 results
have that particular keyword in it so I
could see every one of them how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and why is that important because now
that tells me I only need to climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from Google's
Keyword Planner but you want to get your
competition from Google search and again
that's simply typing in the syntax all
in title and then your keyword in this
example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page SEO so
okay you want to
great content for say a keyword like
digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use Google search see first
when they talk type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page SEO it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in Google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
Google will truncate the title tag so if
I go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag Google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword in the title tag and
somebody types in that keyword then
chances are it's going to be relevant
they're going to see it and they're
going to click through to your website
and that's the whole idea behind ranking
we want to get clicks so that's how the
title tag appears so when you optimize
it you're going to update the title tag
and this is how it shows up it's going
to show up at the top of your listing
okay and it's going to be bigger and
Bolder than anything else Google
displays so the second thing you want to
optimize is the meta description and The
Meta description is simply just a brief
description up to 155 I would say about
155 to 60 160 characters but probably no
more than that and so the meta
description is nothing more than a
summary of the web page itself so if I
go back to my Google search results I
see my title tag and I see the page that
this particular listing belongs to and
underneath that is where I can see my
meta description so in this particular
keyword query how to become a digital
marketing specialist I see the meta
description an ultimate guide on how to
build a career in digital marketing and
the skills required to become a digital
marketing specialist note that it's a
well-written meta description within 155
characters and it includes the keyword
digital marketing specialist so we're
trying to rank for how to become a
digital marketing specialist and here
you can see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description and the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave The
Meta description blank then you're
leaving it to Google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
SEO we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the URL and URL stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the URL so
important because that's what people see
so if I go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the URL also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
URL is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's is relevant to the keyword query
and that's important for the end user
and Google Google wants to know hey is
this the page that's relevant to the
user's query and if it is then this user
is likely going to have a good X user
experience after they click on the
listing so the URL is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
URL structure doesn't help at all
because not only does Google not
recognize the URL as being relevant but
the end user may not want to click on
that page given the the way the URL
looks so you want to try and avoid a
poor URL structure so the rule of thumb
is this if you don't understand what the
URL is then Google is likely not going
to understand what the URL is and so we
want to try and keep our URL structures
clean and when I say clean ideally you
want to make sure that whatever keyword
you're trying to optimize that's the key
word that's in included in the URL
nothing included that is not
understandable so again going back to
our example how to become a digital
marketing specialist it's very clean the
title tag is the keyword The Meta
description is cleanly written has the
keyword and then the URL is the other
element that the end user can see and
that URL includes the keyword in it so
after we've done those three elements
the title tag The Meta description and
the URL then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organization relational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from H1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an H6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building out a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an H1 or an H2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to Google that hey this
header with this particular keyword in
it is important so if you use an H6 with
the keyword in it it's telling Google
hey this is an H6 but it's not as
important so an H1 and an H2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you
could see an H1 is going to be at the
top of the hierarchy so that means it's
going to be bigger and Bolder then you
have an H2 which is going to be bigger
and Bolder than an H3 but not as big and
bold as an H2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content 10
accordingly but you're also signaling to
Google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
I click on that page I can look at the
content and I can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example I'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path Explorer you can see that's an H1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an H2 and so we're not stressing to
Google that that's more important than
nh1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
Google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to Google
what's important and also to organize
the content because Google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal link and if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to other pages on
simply learns website and so for this
particular content it also links to SEO
specialist PPC specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their web website that
are relevant to becoming a digital
marketing specialist and so this is a
best practice when you're optimizing a
web page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when I say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation they
can naturally and seamlessly go from one
relevant article or page to another and
so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building it
allows Google to identify you know pages
that they want to crawl and index
because they're linked to one another
but it also helps the end user because
it allows the end user to go from one
page to another and it's signaling to
Google hey this particular page is
linked to this page so we're going to
also index that page and so that's the
whole important part of internal linking
it's about the end you user experience
and it's about allowing Google to find
the pages on your website so they can
crawl them and index them so you can be
ranked for them and so also in addition
to internal linking we want to be able
to use natural language and so what do I
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what Google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the key
keyword digital marketing maybe we want
to talk about the types of digital
marketing or digital marketing examples
or what is a digital marketing strategy
or how to become a digital marketing
specialist so those are all relevant
keywords to digital marketing and more
relevant to the content because if you
try to rank for the keyword digital
marketing again it's probably going to
be a little bit broad probably more
competition and not as relevant to your
content and as a result probably not a
good user experience so think about some
other keywords that you could optimize
and rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify other keywords and
the natural language process what
keywords are more relevant for the
content and then another element to
on-page SEO is the sitemap and so with a
site map it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there are
two types of sitemaps one's an HTML
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that side map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an XML sitemap an XML is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is Google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for Google or other search
engine crawlers and so XML is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if I go to simplylearn.com and
simply we type in say sitemap.xml just
as an example I'm going to get this
particular page in this particular page
displays two XML sitemaps so these site
maps are there for Google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for Google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind SEO you want to be able to
have Google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page SEO which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag The Meta
description the URL the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking gain and
also updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page SEO
because without on page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off-page SEO and you could do all the
off-page SEO you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to
off-page SEO and so off-page SEO is
simply the process of linking or
promoting your website using link
building and so if you remember I talked
about this earlier on there's two types
of links internal and external linking
and so for on-page SEO we used internal
linking for off-page SEO we're going to
talk about external linking and external
linking allows us to improve our website
sites recognition or relevancy or
credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and Authority
because we want Google to know that our
web page is trustworthy it is recognized
by other websites and it is relevant for
a particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off-page SEO methods then
Google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off-page SEO synonymous with
link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we're have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
Authority and so what I mean by high
domain Authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us then basically our domain
Authority is going to improve and when
our domain Authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website than other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain Authority so it all starts
with linking to other high domain
Authority websites so linking to a high
domain Authority website for example
having a link on Wikipedia that points
back to our web page creates high domain
Authority for us and it helps Drive
traffic so some of the other benefits of
off-page SEO are in credibility so if
we're linking from Wikipedia to our web
page it does create credibility for us
it also helps us increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain Authority helps build
credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
pitch and then certainly not last having
a good off-page SEO link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high Authority
websites Wikipedia or say a social
platform it's going to increase our
brand awareness and increasing our brand
awareness increases our trustworthiness
and so if somebody is looking to say
become a digital marketing specialist
then likely instead of typing in digital
marketing Specialists on Google they may
type in our brand name in this case
simply learn and so these are all the
benefits to off-page SEO so it's nothing
more than having links on other websites
that are pointing back to ours and again
there's lots of benefits its drives
helps Drive traffic and increases our
Authority so those are things that we
want to take advantage of when we want
to rank and the key behind off-page SEO
or link building is always going to be
content so from an on-page SEO
perspective having quality content
allows that content to be optimized for
Relevant keyword and ranked but also
from an off-page SEO strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or it can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
link back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural it's
well structured it reads well and so
that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off-page SEO is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to spend a lot of
time or a bit of time on others websites
so remember the example I used earlier
in this presentation about having an ice
cream blog and ice cream recipes well it
probably wouldn't be a bad idea to say
spend some time on other blogs related
to desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to vegetables or
other items that some people could link
from so the whole idea is understanding
who else is out there who has relevant
content that you could share so you
could share your content with them they
can share their content with you and
generally that's how it works naturally
anyway in the web sphere if somebody
likes your content they're going to link
to it they don't necessarily have to
wait for you to ask them but it might
not be a bad idea to understand who else
is out there that has content somewhat
of yours so that you can you know get a
link on that particular website or blog
post and so some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just Facebook or Twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's media there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
Reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has say a Blog about cakes
having their link on your blog post so
there's nothing wrong with it because it
also adds to the user experience and if
you're going to ask somebody to put an
external link on theirs you might want
to be open-minded and make sure sure
that you're are able and willing to put
an external link on your blog post or
website pointing to their content that's
how the web Works especially if the
content's a quality relevant and of good
nature how does a search engine work so
let's talk about that for a minute so we
know that millions of people use search
engines we know that we want to be found
on search engines but how do we actually
get our content in the search engine so
that's the important part that we need
to understand if we have our own website
and we have our content so these search
engines want your content in their
search engine index so how do they get
your content well they send out Bots or
files and we'll just call them spiders
so they send out these spiders to crawl
your website and the whole idea behind
using the insect spider is because we're
talking about the world wide web and so
if Google for example sends a bot to
your website they're going to crawl your
website and spy to your website they're
creating a web of pages so all they're
doing is following link and every page
and Link that they hit they're going to
bring back to their server so these
spiders scan your websites they just
follow links and and they take all the
pages and content that they're able to
gather when they hit your website and
they're going to pull all that
information back into their own index so
if you think about Google they're
crawling or spidering millions and
billions of websites all those millions
and millions of websites are sitting on
Google servers so when somebody does do
a search query Google because they have
all these websites in their index are
able to quickly determine which website
is the most relevant for that search
engine query so that's generally how
search engines work so let's talk about
the types of seos so if we want our
website to be found on these search
engines in Google or these search
engines have crawled our website then
what we want to do is we want to
basically look at it from a two-pronged
perspective it's a two-prong strategy so
the first strategy we're going to talk
about today is on page SEO so those are
on-page seos defined as is what we do on
our website to be relevant for search
engine query on a search engine so again
on-page SEO is what we do to our own
website off-page SEO is the other the
second part of that SEO strategy and
off-page SEO determines what we do off
our website to be relevant for search
engine query and so off-page SEO
generally is synonymous with link
building and we'll talk about that a
little bit more as we go forward but
really when you want to do SEO when you
want to be found for a keyword on a
search engine you're going to have to
apply both on-page SEO and off-page SEO
so let's talk about on-page SEO and so
this is the first part of our SEO effort
we want to focus on on-page SEO first
and so on page SEO is the method of
optimizing elements of web pages
remember these are all the items we want
want to do on our website to be relevant
for certain search queries so it's
basically the idea behind this is to
make our web pages more relevant for
specific search queries on search
engines and so there are a number of
different elements on our website on a
particular web page that we want to
manipulate or optimize if you will to be
relevant for a search engine query and
so let's start around the idea that you
know you there's a number of things you
can do so let's start with schema first
and so schema is nothing more than it's
a collaborative effort between Bing
Yahoo Baidu Google and the idea is
really they want to understand more
about the content of your website and so
the idea behind this is that you want to
be able to provide Snippets of
information to these search engines so
they understand a little a bit more
about what your web page is trying to
portray or convey so that they can find
out exactly what's relevant to that
search engine query so it's nothing more
than Micro Data or bits of information
that you can add to your website or web
page in order to provide a little bit
more enhanced information to the search
engines so if you think about it's
collaborating with the search engine so
the more basic information you share
with the search engines that the better
off they have to understand what your
web page or website is all about and so
the more information they have the
better of an opportunity you have to be
ranked for that search engine query and
so if you have a website with reviews if
you have a website with images if you
have let's say a website with products
with prices in other words you have an
e-commerce website and you're trying to
sell products well to me you want to
employ employee schema because again
schema is Snippets of information that
are provided to the search engine so
they can better understand so you can
certainly provide Snippets of
information in the terms of images or
prices or particular products and how
much is left in stock so all this
information these bits of information
you can provide to the search engine so
that they can better understand what it
is you're trying to sell how much it
cost how much is in inventory what
people think about the product Etc so if
you have a website that sell products
you probably want to employ schema and
so when you do employee schema again
Snippets of information provided to the
search engines the search engines are
going to better understand and then
they're going to present that
information in the search engine results
so if you have ratings and reviews you
can provide Snippets of information to
the search engines the search engines in
turn are going to present that
information in the search engine results
so if you have positive reviews then
somebody typing in in this example shoes
they're going to be able to see that you
have positive reviews for your website
so that's the whole idea behind schema
is to provide Snippets of information so
again it's not just related to reviews
also for images so if you have images
you can provide Snippets of information
to the search engine so they can see you
know what the shoe actually looks like
when they type in in this example Puma
shoes or like I mentioned inventory
Snippets of information about your
inventory the search engines are going
to provide that information search
engine results so if somebody's looking
for women's training shoes or women's
Puma shoes and they see your product and
they see oh this is in stock great let
me go to this website and purchase these
shoes so that's the whole idea behind
schema is making sure you present
information critical to your website so
that the search engines better
understand what your website's all about
it also helps with the relevancy because
the more those search engines know about
your website the more relevant your
website becomes and the better chance
you have to rank for a particular
keyword there's also some other
information here involved with schema
and those are site links so site links
additional pages on your website okay
that show up in the search engine result
and so again the more information a
search engine has about you the better
chance you have to be found the better
chance you have to get a click so site
links are just additional links on your
site that appear in search engine
results and that's all a benefactor of
having a schema so here you can see in
this example we have additional web
pages that show under a certain search
engine result and so by having more
links in the search engine results you
have a better chance of getting the
click so if you want more information
about schema I would recommend going to
schema.org so when you go to schema.org
you can actually click on a link that
allows you to see all the information
you need to get started with schema.org
okay so it's got a lot of information
available to you it describes what it is
you have to do in order to get your
information in a set for the search
engines to better understand focus on
for on-page SEO is title tag and so
title tag is what shows up in the search
engine results so if you've ever done a
search engine query meaning you've gone
to Google typed in a query using a
keyword like Italian restaurants you're
going to see specific search engine
results and the title tag is what
appears in those search engine results
so a title tag is important because it's
the title of a web page that appears in
those results and so the title tag is
something that's important because if we
want to be found for a specific keyword
we want to make sure that keyword is in
the title tag because that keyword is
going to describe what the page is all
about and so if we want to be found for
that keyword let's just say Italian
restaurants in Florida for example
that's going to be part of our title tag
so when somebody types in that
particular keyword query Italian
restaurants in Florida then we have a
good chance of showing up because the
title tag which is the title of the page
is going to have that particular query
in it and so you can edit the title tag
and when you edit the title tag you want
to be able to put that particular
keyword in the title tag so if we do a
search on Google for example so if I go
to google.com and I type in Italian
restaurants in Florida
here I can see under the local search
results and here I could see Italian
restaurants in Florida Central Florida
Italian restaurants in Miami so you can
see that these are highlighted so the
title tag is not only stands out but
allows you to you know showcase exactly
what your page is all about and it helps
with the relevancy of that keyword query
so when you're trying to optimize your
website using the title tag for specific
keyword you want to keep it in mind a
couple parameters because title tags
show up in the search engine results but
certain search engines particularly
Google has character limits around the
number of characters you can use in the
title tag and so we want to keep that in
mind so ideally we want to format our
title tag appropriately and so to me the
most optimal way to optimize a title tag
using a particular keyword that you want
to be found for is to you use that
keyword in the title tag and then
separate that with your brand name so if
you actually have two keywords then you
can use the primary keyword first then
the secondary keyword and then the brand
name so to me this is the most optimal
format but keep in mind there are
character limits but if you look at this
format to me it's the most easiest
format to abide by because it makes your
title tag more relevant you don't have
to worry about necessarily fitting in
excess keywords in the title tag because
again the title tag has character limits
so if we take a look at our example in
Google search results if you go over
those limits and the title tag is
generally between 60 and 65 characters
long and so if you go over those limits
let's just say your title tag is more
than 65 characters Google in this case
is going to cut off the characters and
so here you can see the ellipses after
the title tag now if you follow all the
format that you know we had simply learn
recommend you could see if our keyword
is Italian restaurants in Florida and
then separated by the brand name this
gives you an optimal format for the
title tag it also makes it relevant for
the keyword query so you want to keep
that title tag probably no more than 60
characters because if you flirt with
putting more than 60 characters then the
search engines are going to cut off that
title tag and then that's not going to
look good and it's going to also become
less relevant so we want to keep the
character counts in mind so if you abide
by that format of the keyword and then
maybe the secondary keyword if you have
one separated by the brand name then you
should be good to go with making sure
your title tag is relevant for that
keyword query so let's then turn our
attention to the meta description so the
meta description is just a short
description about the content on your
web page so if the title tag is the
title of the web page The Meta
description describes the page okay so
it's a description about what that page
is so the meta description appears under
the title tag and then the URL so if we
go back to our Google search results we
look here at Italian restaurants in
Florida Maggiano's Little Italy is the
brand or the restaurant we could see the
URL which is underneath the title tag
and then here we could see the meta
description and so with the meta
description you have a little bit more
room to work with in terms of character
counts but the meta description just
like the title tag is just as important
because one it shows up in the search
engine results two it describes what the
page is all about and three it allows
you to optimize The Meta description so
the meta description becomes more
relevant for that search query that
somebody types into that particular
search engine so the optimal length for
a meta description you can go up to 300
characters but I would not even
recommend even flirting with that limit
because just like the title tag search
engines in the case of Google will
actually cut off The Meta description so
if we look here back at our search
results if you go over those limits
you'll see that the search engines will
cut off the copy of the meta description
with and they'll just put ellipses so we
don't necessarily want to go over those
limits so my recommendation is to keep
that meta description probably
165 characters to two no more than 200
because we're trying to describe not
only what the page is all about but
we're also trying to optimize that meta
description so it becomes relevant for
the search engine query and so you want
to keep it short and concise so if we
look at our example here Italian
restaurants in Florida Maggiano's does a
good job it's a book and event space
make a reservation at Maggiano's in
Florida to enjoy delicious few Maps
menus and more so very concise meta
description it includes their keyword
query that they want to be found for
Italian restaurants in Florida and so to
me it's short and concise describes what
the page is all about and
allows them to fit it all in within the
character limits so here in this example
we want to be found for Amazon Puma
shoes so the brand here is Amazon so
Amazon wants to include you know Puma
shoes not only in the title tag but they
want to try and fit that into the meta
description however the whole idea
behind the meta description more than
anything else is described what the page
is all about okay you want to be
relevant for the search engine query but
you also want to sound natural as well
you want to be able to really the whole
idea between the title tag and amount of
description is to get people to click on
your link because remember there there
are nine other listings on the Google
search engine results page for page one
so we want our meta description and our
title tag to stand out so we want it to
be relevant but we wanted to stand out
so it's important you write that meta
description according to what the page
is all about but you want it to stand
out uniquely and accordingly so once
you've done the title tag and The Meta
description you want to focus your
attention on the header tag and so
header tags are used on a web page to
really separate out content and so you
have headers and subheaders and so
ideally you want to be able to optimize
the header tag and the sub header and so
if we think about headers there's a
hierarchy for headers so there's between
a header one and a header six and so
we'll just shorten the word header and
we'll call it an H1 so H1 is really at
the top of the hierarchy for headers and
so if we use a H1 on our web page then
what we're trying to explain at the
search engines is listen this particular
keyword phrase in our header is is a
header and we're emphasis we're trying
to emphasize what it is we're trying to
say and that's how really the search
engines interpret headers they see an H1
H2 H3 h4h5 and H6 they know that if
you're using an H1 you're trying to
really emphasize something so if you put
that keyword in the header tag what
you're telling the search engines is hey
I'm really emphasizing this particular
keyword and so the search engine will
interpret that as important and if you
use your keyword in that header then
really what you're saying is hey I
really this keyword is really relevant
to that query so naturally the other
benefit of a header is it really breaks
up the page as well so the header you
can use subheaders and subheaders are
nothing more than say a lower H tag so
if you have a header that's an H1 you
can use an H2 or an H3 as a subheader
and so forth and so on because what
you're really trying to do is not only
organize the content in your web page
but you're trying to emphasize that for
Google so if something's an H2 or an H6
you're basically telling Google or the
other search engines this is not as
important as say in H1 so if we take a
look at our example that we've been
using for Italian restaurants in Florida
and if we click on Maggiano's we could
see that they're using headers so if we
click on Maggiano's we could see that
this is a header here we want to bring
everyone together Maggiano's Italian
restaurant in Florida so they're using
that header to break up the text here
you can see they're using another header
here excellent Italian food and an
excellent experience to match so that's
a header to break up the content okay
they're not using subheaders they're
just using headers but that's fine
they're really trying to emphasize the
content by putting in that header and so
how headers help not only organize the
content but they help emphasize the
actual keyword it is you want Google to
recognize so if we're not sure if
something is a header we could simply
just Mouse over what we think is a
header and we can just right click and
if you right click on something you're
going to see a menu and if we click
inspect element then basically what that
browser in this case Firefox is going to
do is show us the HTML of that
particular thing of that item that we
right click so here we could see in this
particular case this is an H2 tag so
it's an H2 so if we scroll down and we
Mouse over this we could see this is
also an H2 as well so this particular
page is using H2 tags not H1 but in H2
so what they're explaining or trying to
convey to the search engines is listen
this is an H2 it's still relevant we're
still trying to put emphasis on it but
not as much so we want to be able to use
our H1s and our H2S accordingly so
remember in H1 is you're providing the
search engines with information by
telling them hey this is the most
relevant this is we're putting emphasis
on this keyword and H2 nuts as much as
an H1 and an H3 not as much as an H2 so
use your headers accordingly not only
just to break up the text not only for
styling but for emphasis for the search
engines so headers are very important
elements for on-page SEO okay let's turn
our attention to the URL structure okay
so URL stands for uniform resource
locator and so are you around is the
specific location of a web page on the
internet so basically if we're found in
the search engine results one of our web
pages are gonna go along with the title
tag and The Meta description and the
search engine results page so if I go
back to our search engine results for
Italian restaurants and in Florida we
could see that the particular URL in
question here is
locations.masianos.com Florida so that's
the URL that shows up along with the
title tag in The Meta description so if
we click on that link that's exactly
where we're going to go so URL structure
is important for on-page SEO so why is
it important because not only does it
show people where they're going but we
have an opportunity to optimize that URL
for the search engines to make our URL
more relevant for that search query so
just like the title tag just like the
meta description just like the headers
we can also manipulate the URL so if we
look at a URL it consists of really the
protocol and the protocol means it's
either a secure site or non-secure site
so in this example we could see it's
https and that means it's a secure site
and so ideally search engines like web
pages or websites that are secure so
after the protocol you're going to see
the domain and then after the domain
you're going to see subdirectories okay
so that's generally the breakout with
URL structures you have the protocol the
domain and subdirectories and then you
may have more subdirectories so if we go
back to the example we've been working
with if I go back to Maggiano's you can
see here this is a secure site https you
can see the domain in this case it's
actually a sub domain so maggiano's.com
is the domain but they decided to put
locations Dot maggiano's.com and that's
okay we call that a sub domain and then
here you can see they have one
particular subdirectory after the domain
and that's Florida so a well structured
URL not only provides the users with
information about where they're going
when they click on your link and the
search engine results but more
importantly it also provides the search
engines and some information about what
the web page is all about so going back
to our simple example with Maggiano's
the search engines know that hey if
somebody clicks on this link they're
going to a page about Florida pretty
simple the URL structure is pretty
simple to understand we know it's a
secure site we know it's maggiano's.com
and we know the sub page is Florida or
the subdirectory is Florida you want to
be careful like everything else since in
SEO there are parameters just like the
title tag has parameters up to 65
characters The Meta description tag has
a limit of up to 165 characters a
well-structured URL also has character
counts but the idea here is we don't
want to get into numbers when we talk
about character counts for URL structure
really the rule of thumb or the best
practice for your url is to keep it
short and understandable okay if we keep
it clear concise not only does the end
user know where they're going but the
search engines know what the page is all
about so the rule of thumb is always if
you don't understand the URL or what it
means then the search engines are likely
not going to understand what the URL
means we want to keep the number of
directors and subdirectories to a limit
so ideally here you can see in this
example xyz.com we want to optimize that
URL we could put the targeted keyword in
the URL if we'd like to but we want to
keep it probably to a minimum of one to
two subdirectories the shorter this the
amount of set directories the better off
we are because that means that not only
the end user will understand the URL but
the search engines will understand the
URL as well so we always want to make
sure that URL is readable again for the
Yan user and the search engine and so in
this example you can see amazon.com
men's shoes slash sneakers slash Puma
very easy to understand as an end user I
know that I'm going to a puma page for
men on amazon.com now when you get into
URLs with Dynamic parameters in them
then ideally you as an end user is not
going to really know where you're going
to go so in the example here the middle
example I can see that I'm going maybe
to a shoes page but I have no idea what
the rest that URL means and then the
other example where you have a very low
URL readability I have no idea as an end
user where I'm going to go so as an end
user I need to be able to have
confidence in knowing where I'm going to
go once I click on a link in the search
engine results so if I don't have that
confidence if I don't understand what
the URL is then you'll then the search
engines aren't going to understand as
well and it's not going to bode well in
terms of relevancy and again the URL
structure is an important factor for
being relevant and if we're not relevant
then the chances of us are ranking
higher is not going to be as good
because our URL is not readable so
ideally what we want to do is make sure
we're using keywords that the end user
and the search engines understand and if
we need to separate out those keywords
in the first example we could see men's
shoes we want to separate that out with
a hyphen and so ideally if you have a
URL that's readable and it's short and
concise then again your chances of
ranking higher on the search engine
results page bodes better than if you
have a very long Antiquated unreadable
URL so let's focus our attention on
image alt text or alt tags if you will
so alt tags or text tags as they're also
known as allow uh the search engines to
understand a little bit more about
what's on the page in terms of images so
images are a prominent part of every web
page on the internet unfortunately
images are you know usually files that
are not readable by search engines so we
want to be able to provide some
alternate text so that the search
engines understand what those images are
all about so again it gives us an
opportunity to communicate with the
search engines so that they better
understand what the image is all about
to make the page more relevant so
generally if an image fails to load on a
web page as an example well if you have
an ALT tag then the all tag is going to
show in place of the image not loading
more importantly if we have an ALT tag
in the search have spidered our website
and somebody's actually searching for
images then the alt tag is used as a
descriptor for the image so it also
helps us get found for the images on
search engine results pages and so like
everything else we've talked about with
on-page SEO there are character limits
to all tags you know generally the rule
of thumb is 125 characters for an ALT
tag and the alt tag is used in the HTML
so we want to surround our image with an
ALT tag by putting in a descriptor and
so ideally if you're trying to be found
for a particular search engine query
then you want to use the search engine
query as part of the alt tag and so let
me show you an example here going back
to Maggiano's we look at their web page
and we actually inspect one of their
images on this webpage if we look at for
example Pinterest or Facebook we can
actually see in this example that the
image here has an ALT tag it's Pinterest
and so you want to be able again to put
in all tags for all your images so it
better communicates with the search
engines what the image is all about it
also allows the search engines to rank
images in the search engine results
based on that alt text and what the
keyword query was so all tags play an
important role because again if the
image doesn't load on the web page for
some reason then the alt tag is there as
a replacement it's also there to help
the search engines rank those images and
understand the page a little bit better
so you always want to be able to put in
the keyword query that you're trying to
be found for in the alt tag and so b as
descriptive as possible you have 125
characters to use so B is descriptive
make get easy to read because again this
is what's going to show up in the search
engine results Pages for images okay
let's turn our attention to internal
links so when it comes to SEO internal
links also play a vital role because
basically an internal link which is a
link from one page of your website to
another page of your website
um allows Google to or other search
engines really to follow the pages as
they index your entire website so it
serves that purpose of allowing search
engines to index so it definitely
improves the indexing but internal
linking also has many benefits and one
of the other benefits is it helps
spreads what we call link juice and so
link juice is basically a way another
way of saying you know this page is
important because it has links from
other pages on our website so if we link
I have a link from one page to another
other and a couple of other pages on our
site linked to that same page then
search engines tend to take notice and
they tend to note that you know if one
particular page has a number of
different links point to it then this
page may be important and so that's what
we mean by link juice it's a signal for
the search engine to determine what
pages on your website are important
because of the links that point to it
and so if we look at this example here
we could see that you know there's
usually a navigation on a website that
point to pages and every page on a
website tends to have a link but if more
than one page has multiple links then
again that signals to the search engines
that hey you know this particular page
seems to be important because it has a
lot of links pointing to it our
attention to sitemaps so site Maps
basically allow us to list all the web
pages on our website so we could do that
and in a couple of different ways but
when we do it it basically is going to
and help the search engines find our
Pages easier just as I mentioned a
minute ago about internal linking when
you have one link point to another page
on your website it helps the search
engines find these Pages quicker while
sitemaps do the same thing except
sitemaps are an entire list of links on
your website and it allows the site
search engines to find all your pages in
your website fairly easily but it also
helps the end user too so if you have a
big website like Amazon has a huge
website with a lot of different products
well if you're looking for a particular
product you could do a search for it or
you can look at the site map and the
site map will list all the particular
pages on the site and so it's also good
for the end user as well so when we talk
about the end user and we talk about
search engines they're really two
different types of sitemaps you got the
HTML version which is for the end user
that's going to be nothing more than a
link on the website usually in the
footer and so when you click on that
site map link you'll get a list of all
the links on the website okay so that's
an HTML sitemap then we have the site
map for the search engines you know the
spiders that want to crawl our site so
that's the XML sitemap and an XML is
just a different format it's just a way
to format all the links on our website
so the HTML site map is HTML written in
hypertext markup language designed for
the end user if you click on it it helps
the end user navigate the website
quickly because they can find what
they're looking for and so generally
that is an HTML now if we turn our
attention to the XML sitemap that's
basically designed for search engines
and thing about the search of the XML
sitemap is we work with Google to go
ahead and and submit the sitemap to
Google so Google can quickly understand
what pages on our website so for example
if if I went to a website let's just say
valleyfig.com so if I went here and if
I'm a search engine I'm going to want to
know all the URLs that are on this
website well as an end user I can also
just type in
sitemap.xml usually that's the XML file
where all the URLs are located and here
I can see all of the URLs on
valleyfit.com and so the idea behind an
XML site map is we want to communicate
that XML file to the search engines and
so Google in particular has what they
call a search console and search console
if you go to google.com webmasters so
search console as a way to communicate
with Google and one of the ways to
communicate with Google is to submit a
site map so we want to submit our XML
sitemap so if our XML sitemap is located
in the root directory so after our
domain valleyfig.com
sitemap.xml we know that that file is
sitting in the root directory I can go
into search console and I can submit my
sitemap and when I submit my sitemap
then I'm basically communicating with
Google telling Google hey Google instead
of trying to find all our web pages on
our website when you crawl the website
we're going to go ahead and submit the
sitemap to you so we're going to tell
you all the pages on our website and so
by doing that by submitting our
sitemap.xml file to Google it speeds up
the process because Google's able to Now
understand all the pages on our website
that have been submitted and then once
we submit those pages then Google's
going to quickly index a majority of
those pages if not all of those pages
and so that's the benefit of having an
XML sitemap for the search engines is
that we can quickly submit that file to
the search engine so our Pages get
submitted and indexed quicker so
continuing on with on-page SEO we now
turn our attention to page speed and so
page speed also known as page low time
of a particular page of a particular
website is important for SEO why is it
important because Google has millions of
users use their search engine and Google
wants their users to have a good
experience and so if Google ranks
websites based on relevancy they also
want to take into account page speed
because if a website does not load
faster a web page doesn't load fast then
it would be detrimental for Google to
rank that page High because what's going
to happen is that page is going to get a
number of clicks and then the user
experience is not going to be that great
and so therefore it's going to have a
negative impact not only in the end user
but Google as well and so page load time
then becomes important for on-page SEO
so really when it comes to page load
time we really want to pay attention
into how long it takes our web pages to
load in terms of seconds because if a
page loads slow then chances are the
user experience is not going to be good
even from an analytics perspective
meaning if I go to Google type in a
query click on a link and then it's that
link takes me to a website where the web
page loads very slow chances are I'm not
going to spend a lot of time waiting for
that page to load I'm going to leave
that page and if I leave the page then
it's going to cause up what they call a
bounce so I'm going to bounce from the
page and that's just not good for the
entire search ecosystem and so we want
to pay close attention to page load time
because the faster a site or page loads
Google's going to recognize that and
that's going to help with ranking and so
how do we understand how our Pages load
well we can look no further than web
Analytics tool like Google analytics for
example people so if we turn our
attention to Google analytics if I go to
say valleyfig.com analytics account I
can look over the last 30 days and I can
see okay on average our page average
page load time for the entire site was
five seconds around five seconds and
ideally we want our Pages load as quick
as possible I would say the rule of
thumb on page load time is probably no
more than three to four seconds okay but
there are factors involved with page
load time so a couple of factors are the
browser that people use so some browsers
load pages differently than other
browsers the other factor involved with
browsers is the device so you could be
on a mobile device and say Internet
Explorer versus on a desktop using
Chrome and you're going to have
variation in terms of average page load
time so definitely browser device plays
a role but also country plays a role the
infrastructure how much bandwidth is
available so you could be in say San
Francisco United States and be on a
high-speed Network versus another city
or another country where you're not
necessarily on the same high-speed
Network you're on a lower bandwidth or
lower Network and that's going to affect
the page load time as well so in
analytics you can actually see the
breakdown of time per country and then
of course the page itself so when we
talk about average page load time for a
website we're talking about the average
for the entire site but we can actually
look at in Google analytics the average
load time for every page on the site so
ideally if you have a particular page
you want to rank organically in the
search engines and the average page load
time is not suitable or it's very high
then you want to address what the issues
are and so the great thing about Google
analytics is you actually have feed
suggestions so if I go to speed
suggestions in Google analytics I'm
going to be able to see the average load
time for certain pages on the site and
then what Google's going to do is
actually give me some feedback so for
example I can see that the home page
loads about 5.59 seconds and so if I
click on page speed suggestions then
Google is going to give me suggestions
on how to speed up the page load time
not only on desktop but on mobile as
well so when you click on page speed
suggestions you're actually going to go
to a tool a Google tool called page
speed insights and then page speed
insights is going to allow you to see
how quick your page loads and then it's
going to be able to give you feedback on
what to do in order to speed up the page
load time not only for the page but for
the site and the great thing again is
you can see it for desktop and you can
see it from Mobile so page speed is
important we want to be able to keep our
page load Time Low no more than probably
again three to four seconds because if
it's any more than that Google's going
to take notice the other search engine
is going to take notice and they're not
going to want to rank that particular
page high on Google so some ways to
increase your page speed you always want
to optimize your images you never want
to have images that take a long time to
load you want to use a simple website
design now I know flash as an example
has long been disbanded but you don't
want to use other technology that's
really going to slow the page load time
of course where your website is hosted
does matter so the server it's hosted on
could be shared with other websites and
so that may eat into how quick the
server responds to people trying to load
your web page and so you want to keep
that in mind so server response time
does play a factor in loading and then
of course optimizing your code you want
to never have unnecessary code on your
website and when I say a necessary code
some examples could be tracking code if
you're doing any search advertising
let's just say on Facebook or Bing you
try to want to minimize the amount of
extra code you put on a site because
that code has to execute and that eats
into the page load time so you want to
be cognizant of how much code you put on
your website because that will eat into
the page load time so let's talk about
featured Snippets so featured Snippets
is the search result that generally
shows uh up at the top of the search
engine organic results so it's
informational content and you'll see it
above organic results but you'll also
see it below search advertising and so
some of the common featured Snippets you
may see are in the form of a paragraph a
table or or a list and so paragraph
Snippets tend to be the most popular and
let me show you an example of a featured
snippet so if I go to say google.com and
type in machine learning here you can
see some paid search ads okay and why do
I know they're paid search ads because I
can see ad next to them but if I look
below the paid search ads but above the
organic search results I see a paragraph
featured snippet and this is nothing
more than again just some an
informational content about machine
learning and really the whole idea
behind feature Snippets is really
they're just informational and really
it's informational and and what Google
likes to do is pull content in there
that really answers a question so if
your content doesn't necessarily answer
question then you can't expect your
content to show up as a featured snippet
so the whole idea here is with the
search engines is really Google searches
through a number of different sites to
find content that will best answer a
user's question like for example what is
machine learning okay so if we ask the
question what is machine learning we can
expect to find a feature snippet and so
really what users do a lot when they
type in a query they use prefixes like
how does or how do or how to or what is
and so those types of questions are
normally asked as part of the search
query so if you could answer those
questions then generally Google's going
to recognize that and if it's relevant
it's going to show up as a featured
snippet so the whole idea is to really
create truly high quality content so
about feature Snippets is if you have
true high quality content that answers a
question then chances are your content
may show up as a featured snippet so the
whole idea is you know work to create
high quality content that provides a
really good answer to really basic
question it could be anything what is
machine learning what is a fig you know
how to ride a bicycle how do i surf all
these are related questions that content
can answer and Google wants to make sure
as part of a featured snippet that they
provide content that answers that
question and not just content the best
content that does the the best job with
the most relevant information answer
that person's search query so here we
can see our three examples you have a
table format so if we want to type in
aviation jobs we can see Snippets of
information about the latest job
listings for Aviation you can see in the
middle screenshot what is machine
learning so that's our paragraph
featured snippet and then if you type in
something like building a fence it's
going to give you a list of you know
ways to go about building a fence so
these are all answers to questions the
query may not necessarily be in question
form but the snippet is there just in
case you want to know more information
about that particular query so generally
that's how featured Snippets work and
the great thing about featured Snippets
it's open to everybody the key is to
have quality content if you have quality
content that provides answers to
questions then chances are your content
can show up above organic search results
which will give you more visibility
drive a lot more traffic to your site
and quality traffic because likely it's
answering somebody's question so let's
do a a recap of everything we talked
about with on-page SEO so before we move
on off page remember on page SEO is what
we do to our website to enhance our
website to be found in the the search
engines for Relevant keywords so it's
all about relevancy and remember before
you do anything to your website you need
to start with the basics of keyword
research you need to find keywords that
are highly relevant that have volume and
low competition and so when you can
focus on your keywords and you find out
and finalize what keywords you want to
be found for then you're going to
conduct on-page seo on-page seo consists
of number of different factors some of
which we talked about today starting
with schema remember we want to have
structured data to better communicate
with the search engines what our web
pages are about then we talked about
title tags so title tags appear in
search results remember 65 characters we
want to make sure our keyword is in the
title tag followed by our brand name and
then we talked about meta descriptions
meta descriptions allow us to you know
talk specifically about what that page
is all about meta descriptions fall
under the title tag and the search
results we talked about headers H1
through H6 H1 being the biggest in the
hierarchy of headers and having an H1
tag with your keyword provides the
search engines with an identity of how
strong or how important something is on
a page it also organizes the page with
headers and subheaders and it breaks up
the content so it's easily
understandable by the end user we also
talked about alt tags so remember images
on its own are not recognized by search
engines so we want to surround those
images with all tags with words that
help the search engines identify what
that image is they also serve a purpose
in the browser if an image doesn't load
then we can actually see what the image
is all about with the alt tag we talked
about featured Snippets there are lists
okay their paragraph crafts okay they're
they're different types of Snippets and
really the whole idea again behind
Snippets is answering a question with
quality content we talked about page
speed identifying how quick our Pages
load in Google analytics so if your
pages don't load very quickly then
Google actually provides suggestions to
speed up the page load time of a
particular page and some of the culprits
that you want to look at are making sure
you have images that are of good quality
but also not a lot in size you want to
make sure they're optimized you want to
look at your server response time you
want to make sure you optimize code so
there's a lot of different factors of
page load time you just want to keep an
eye on what pages are are not loading
quick enough and remember we want to
keep it as low as possible but no more
than three to four seconds we talked
about internal linking internal linking
to a particular page from one page to
another provides LinkedIn is and Link
juice is nothing more than an indicator
for the search engines to identify what
pages tend to be more important than
another based on the number of links
pointing to that page and then we also
talked about site Maps so we talked
about the two types of sitemaps HTML and
XML htmounts for the end user XML is
primarily for the search engines XML
generally is going to be a file called
sitemap.xml and we could take that XML
file and submit it to Google search
console and so that expedites the
process of indexing your site and helps
your site not only get index faster but
will help Google understand how many
pages are on your site and then get
those pages indexed so that they can be
found so that you can generate traffic
so all these are factors with on-page
SEO that you want to address before you
move on to off-page SEO okay let's um
turn our attention to off-page SEO now
that we have covered all the essentials
for on page we still need to focus our
attention on off page remember earlier I
mentioned that SEO is a two-pronged
approach we have to focus on on-page SEO
first and then to complement our efforts
and to continue our efforts and to
continue the effort of being relevant
for certain keywords we need to do what
we call off-page SEO and those are our
actions we take that don't involve our
website directly meaning we've already
updated the title tag The Meta
description the alt tags the headers Etc
we want to do things off our website
that's going to allow Google and other
search engines to recognize that hey we
are relevant these pages are relevant
for certain keywords on our website and
so really when we talk about off-page
SEO it's really the technique of
promoting your website using link
building when we say technique of
promoting our website using link
building that means establishing links
on other websites that's what we mean by
link building and so establishing links
on other websites really enhances our
SEO efforts because it improves first
and foremost and improves The
credibility of our website so if we're
on a you know a very popular website
that is known to be reputable then
having a link pointing from that website
to ours just improves The credibility of
our own website not necessarily in the
minds of the search engine but in the
minds of the end user uh the other
benefit here is it increases our domain
Authority and let's take a minute to
talk about domain Authority so domain
Authority is simply just a score between
1 and 100 and so in digital marketing
even including SEO as a marketing
channel everything is measured terrible
and we want to be able to measure
everything we do digitally and so off
page SEO is measurable one of the
metrics involved with off-page SEO is
domain Authority in other words it's a
score between 1 and 100 for our domain
so how does Google how does Baidu how do
these other search engines see our
domain how authoritative is our domain
how reputable is our domain and so
having links on other websites pointing
to our domain increases our reputability
increases our Authority and so I'm going
to show you an example so if you
remember back on on-page SEO I when
we're talking about keyword research we
use a tool called Moz moz.com and I
would recommend using moz.com to measure
domain Authority so if we go to mods.com
and mods.com has a tool called link
Explorer so if you put in your domain
you using their tool link Explorer
you're going to be able to see your
domain Authority and domain Authority is
a score between 1 and 100 and basically
it's simply just scoring your website in
terms of authority how does these search
engines see your site out on the world
wide web the higher the score the better
and so recommend using mods.com link
Explorer to measure the domain Authority
so the more links we have on external
sites pointing to our own site in theory
the higher the domain Authority so we're
going to come back to moz.com quite
frequently as we talk about off-page SEO
because we need a tool to help manage
our efforts so we're going to come back
to mods.com but let's let's talk about
some of these other benefits to off-page
SEO so we know it helps with the
credibility it increases our domain
Authority but what are some of the other
intangible efforts that are also
measurable well well it increases our
referral traffic and by increasing our
referral traffic meaning if we're in a
reputable site that gets a lot of
traffic and there's a link pointing our
site then naturally we're probably going
to see traffic coming from that site and
we can measure that in tools like Google
analytics we can measure referral
traffic and so that's that inherent
benefit to doing off-page SEO because
we're trying to create the relevancy of
our own website we're trying to be found
for Relevant keywords but yet at the
same time we can increase traffic to our
website and then certainly not lost in
all this is improving our page ranks so
the idea here is you need on page and
off-page SEO to work together to improve
our rankings and improving our rankings
in the search engine results will
inherently increase our rankings and
drive traffic to the site from search
engines and that's ideally what we're
trying to do we're trying to accomplish
traffic from search engines by improving
our rankings but at the same time we
improve our credibility and we crew
improve our standing in the search
engine world and we also increase
traffic to our site from all these other
websites and so there are a lot of
benefits to off-page SEO
um it's just let's talk a little bit
more about some of these other benefits
because according to a backlinko a web
page with more backlinks is going to
rank higher than a page with fewer
backlinks but let me just say this with
back linking especially from sites it's
all about credibility it's all about
quality over quantity so we want to pay
attention to quality over quantity so
let's harken back to moz.com and here we
could see we have a domain authority of
35 but we have a lot of links inbound
links from other websites pointing to
our website we have
575 domains out there on the internet
pointing to our domain valleyfig.com and
so if we want to take a specific look at
these domains we can just simply click
on linking domains and here we can see
all the different domains pointing to
our website now again it's about quality
not quantity so if we look at the Domain
Authority and that's a score that
measures the credibility of a website we
could see the domain Authority on some
of these domains like npr.org has a
domain authority of 93 and so to me that
helps boost the domain Authority for our
own website our own domain it also has
the chance of driving that traffic it
also increases the credibility but in
the end having quality links from other
quality domains is going to increase our
own rank on search engines and that's
the whole idea behind it so we could
actually see that we have quality
websites and quality domains linking to
our domain now you can also use another
tool I mentioned this earlier with
on-page SEO when I was talking about
sitemaps so if you go to search console
so that's a Google tool we can also look
at a link report and see what other
websites are linking to us so this is
Google's way of communicating to us what
websites are out there linking to us and
so here I could see the top linking
sites to our website valleyfig.com is
the crumby kitchen has
1443 links pointing back to our site
cookscountry.com Whole Foods magazine
mine perfect kitchen these are all Sites
with links pointing back to our site so
search console is a good tool it's a
good alternative tool especially the
links report is a good alternative tool
to get an idea of the types of sites
that are linking to your site now what
you're missing here in search console is
the domain Authority but you can use the
link Explorer tool in moz.com to measure
the domain Authority for any domain it's
just a matter of going to the tool
Itself by going to moz.com by going to
the link Explorer report and just typing
in the domain and from there you'll be
able to see the domain Authority so it's
all about quality over quantity I can't
stress that enough so when it comes to
off page really it's Anonymous with link
building so it's the most effective
method for off-page SEO and it's simply
just getting links from other websites
to your own so it's not as easy as it
sounds especially when we're talking
about quality over quantity but building
these links to our website will help our
rankings and that's the whole idea
behind off-page SEO we want to be able
to link from other websites to ours so
that we can help our rankings in
addition to some of the other benefits I
just mentioned so Google recognizes
backlinks as one of their top ranking
factors so in addition to some of the
on-page SEO tactics that I mentioned
earlier including title tag and meta
description and URL structure and
headers all those are important but at
the same time it's a balance so Google
wants to know hey yes we understand
you've optimized your title tag for
keyword but how does the rest of the
internet see your website are is your
website worthy enough to add a link from
a particular quality website to your
website so if there are a number of
quality links then your site must be of
quality as well and so that's the whole
idea behind link building being an
important factor because again it's
about from a Google's perspective it's
about the user experience they want to
make sure that sites ranked on page one
of Google are quality sites quality
sites that load well that have good
content that have fresh content not just
sites that have a gazillion links
pointing to them with you know keywords
stuffed into the title tag so it's an
ecosystem Google's and other search
engines want to protect that ecosystem
with quality so that's why link building
is an important factor and so there are
different types of links so when you
have a link pointing from one website to
your own okay the link could be a follow
link or no follow link and the whole
idea behind follow or no follow is
simply hey we know that Google and other
search engines they're spidering the
entire Web the whole idea is for them to
collect as many pages as they these
search engines can bring them back to
their servers so they can serve them up
in their search engines well as Google
and these other search engines spider
these sites they're following what
they're doing is they're following links
it's as simple as it gets they're
following links from one link to another
so remember we talked about internal
links earlier on on-page SEO internal
links are just links on your web pages
pointing to other pages on your own
website well when it comes to external
links so links pointing from one website
to your website that website that's
linking to your website has an
opportunity to say hey Google you can
follow this link or don't follow the
link and so if they choose to not follow
the link meaning they put a nofollow tag
into the anchor text then Google's going
to follow the link but not recognize the
link itself and what I mean by that is
hey if you have let's just use Valley
fig has a link from Wikipedia if
Wikipedia has a link pointing to
valleyfig.com but the link itself is no
follow then what Google is going to do
is not recognize the link itself they're
not going to recognize the link so
therefore you're not going to get credit
or link juice as we say you're not going
to get any Jews from Wikipedia to Valley
fig but if it is a follow link then what
Google's going to do is recognize the
link and give you credit for the
backlink and by giving you credit for
the backlink that's going to inherently
increase your domain Authority it's also
going to likely increase your rankings
so you want to pay attention to the
types of Link building that's out there
no follow and so anytime you try to
establish a link on an external website
just make sure it's a follow make sure
it's not a no follow because if it's a
no follow link then you're not going to
get the credit from the search engines
and so the whole idea behind link
building in terms of SEO is to get some
credit from a quality website to your
website and so if we look here a follow
Link in this example is one where the
ahref or the link itself doesn't have a
no follow in it but if a hyperlink does
have a nofollow in it then that means
you're not going to get the credit for
the backlink so remember no follows they
don't allow search engine crawls to
follow the link so if that's the case
it's not going to pass any linkages when
you don't pass quote unquote link juice
you're not going to get credit for the
backwink and so if you don't get credit
for the back length then if we go back
to our tools that we have available for
measuring off page SEO so if I go back
to let's just say Moz or even let's just
say search console you know I'll be able
to see all these links here these links
that are showing up are follow links why
because Google's recognizing the link if
they were nofollow then we wouldn't see
the link in here so that's something to
keep in mind as well and so just keep in
mind if it is a no file you'll see D in
the hypertext itself the nofollow tag
and you can always check that the HTML
of any particular link and so when we
talk about link building we talk about
off-page SEO really we're talking about
how to get links on quality websites and
how do we do that well I've listed here
a few ways to do that so you could do
guest blogging or blogging in general is
a good off-page SEO slash link building
strategy and I'll talk about more of
that in a minute but we can list our
websites in reputable and trustworthy
directories I mentioned Wikipedia as an
example even though Wikipedia may not be
classified as a directory but there are
other directories out there you can ask
for testimonials so if you're working
with clients or other websites you could
ask for testimonial or they can provide
a link pointing back from their site to
your site it's about relationships
really is what it comes down to it's
relationship bill building and that's
what a link is relationship building or
you could do content on social media so
these are just examples of ways to
generate links but let's go back to the
blogging part because blogging to me is
an essential part to off-page SEO and
why is that because anytime you are part
of a Blog you're generating content and
not only are you generating content
you're generating fresh content that's
likely to be interesting to the end user
and with that content yes you can
optimize that content but the beauty
about blogging is really anybody can do
it but if we want to connect blogging
with relationships if we're a food
blogger then we can write on other food
blogs as a guest writer and we can have
that blog post linked back to our own
blog as an example or we can have other
bloggers in the same industry write a
guest blog for us on their own blog and
point their link back to our site
blogging creates a lot of opportunities
for link building because again it's a
fresh canvas with interesting content
and when you have interesting content
then the opportunity for backlinking is
going to be there because if you're
writing about something that's
interesting the natural you're going to
want to link to something else related
to that that's interesting and so that's
the opportunity that blogging creates so
again it's vital to get links from
authoritative web pages then multiple
links from low quality web pages so
going back to the link Explorer report
we want to be able to pay attention to
those domain authorities or those
websites with low domain Authority and
really you should pay attention to
really quality sites okay you want to
pay attention to Quality sites and so
when we talk about links there's inbound
links there's outbound links we're
interested in those inbound links we're
interested in getting links from high
quality websites pointing to our own
website and again that could be in the
form of a Blog it could be social media
it could be a partner site okay these
are all inbound links they just need to
be followed make sure they're not a no
follow so it's simple just getting a
external link that's a follow to your to
your own website and so the one thing I
want to mention here though on inbound
links from external websites and that's
making sure that not necessarily every
inbound link points to the home page we
want to be able to have links point to
internal pages so let's harken back to
search console as an example so search
console or links report shows us links
pointing from external websites to our
own website but what are those linked
pages so if we look at some of those
linked Pages here we can see the top
link Pages we could see on valleyfig.com
recipes is the topped link page then the
home page then the about us then slash
International so we want to make sure
that if we're trying to generate
backlinks from external websites to our
own website we want to make sure that
they're pointing to Interior Pages not
necessarily the home page and why do I
say that because one of the benefits to
link building an off-page SEO is ranking
so the whole idea about ranking is to
get some of our other Pages ranked not
necessarily the home page the home page
is just a doorway into your website if
we have interesting content out there on
the web and it's a food blogger as an
example and they're talking about a
particular food item well they're going
to want to link to a page that's related
to what they're blogging about that
particular food item they don't want to
link to the home page the home page is
just a doorway and so that's the whole
idea behind link building we want to
link to multiple pages on the site why
is that because if I tell take this
particular page valleyfig.com recipes
and I just put that into Moz and I look
at the link Explorer report for this
particular page the domain Authority is
still going to be the same 35 that's
what valleyfig.com is 35 however there's
also another metric called page
Authority so page Authority is likewise
with the domain Authority it's a score
between 1 and 100 and so the more
external links pointing to an internal
page with high domain Authority that's
likely going to increase the page
authority of that page so in other words
if we have good links from other
websites pointing to that page then it's
going to increase the page Authority for
that page and ultimately the domain
Authority for that page and so just like
the domain Authority in this case Valley
big every page under the domain has a
page Authority score so the higher the
score the likelihood that that page is
going to rank in the search engine
results okay so that's the whole idea
behind link building is we want to
improve the authority of the pages not
just the domain but also more
importantly we also want to keep the end
user in mind so if it's from a blog or
social media the link pointing from that
blog or social media platform should
naturally point to something related to
what you're talking about not just the
home page because again the home page
more or less is the Gateway into the
website so we want to get people to
where they want to go we want to
naturally create a link from good
content to some other good content so
that's the whole idea behind backlinking
so outbound links will direct a user
from our own website to another website
so the idea here is it's okay to have
outbound links on your own website it's
a natural ecosystem of the World Wide
Web okay what I would recommend here is
not to have so many in a Century Located
place for example don't have one page
when nothing but external links on it
you know sprinkle these external links
these outbound links throughout your
website but also if it's not a
reciprocal link meaning if a guest
blogger is not linking to your website
but you're just linking to theirs and
they didn't ask you to then maybe
consider a nofollow tag maybe you know
ideally you want to make sure that these
links are just natural in nature so
don't just have a habit of putting
outbound links because the whole idea
behind outbound links is you want to
keep people on your website but if it's
a natural link going from one content to
another and you think the end user is
going to benefit then no problem but
just don't get in the habit of putting
external links on your website because
that means that hey that user that's on
your website May click on that link and
leave your website and not come back so
keep that in mind as well because you
don't necessarily a benefit from an SEO
perspective by having outbound links on
your own website you want to do it as a
courtesy if somebody else is linking to
you you want to do it for the end user
if you feel the benefit from additional
content another website but from an SEO
perspective it doesn't necessarily
directly enhance your own website in
terms of ranking turn our attention to
duplicate content so a lot of us have
websites with a lot of content sometimes
we go ahead and take our website and
revise it create a new one or register a
new domain and put content on that new
domain and so we may find ourselves in a
situation at one point or the other
where we have two websites with the same
content or could be the same website
with a lot of content but some of that
may be duplicate as well so we want to
try and stay away from duplicate content
but for some of us we may stumble across
it accidentally we may find ourselves I
was having content that's duplicated and
so we want to try and prevent that
because that's a No-No in the world of
SEO so if we have duplicate content
appearing in more than one URL there are
ways to rectify not having the search
engines recognize the content twice so
some examples of duplicate content are
for example a spammer text an article
and post the same content on his website
or like I mentioned before you create
another website or register another
domain and have that particular content
on the old website still or you're
writing a blog post and you tag it or
categorize it and the content shows up
under the tags under the categories and
just shows up in general so there are a
lot of scenarios where you can find
yourselves with duplicate content and so
we want to rectify that we don't want
duplicate content we want the search
engines to recognize the original source
of the content and so basically if you
have two versions of a web page you may
result in duplicate content issues
another example of that would be for
example if you have products you may
find that that same product may be under
two different categories so how do we
Rectify that well there are a number of
different ways and so the simple way is
what they call a 301 redirect to the
original URL so if you find yourself in
a situation where you have a new website
with the same content you could simply
set up a redirect and we call it a 301
redirect because 301 refers to permanent
so it's signifying to the search engines
that you're permanently moving from this
page to this page the other way is
through a canonical attribute and so the
word canonical may not register with
some of you so let's just uh take a
minute to talk about what a canonical is
basically a canonical tag it's a page
level meta tag so remember that meta tag
description we talked about an on-page
SEO well think about this as another
type of meta tag and it's placed in that
HTML header of your web page so
basically all it does is by placing this
meta tag it tells the search engines
which URL is the original version to be
displayed in index so it's the purpose
of a canonical is to keep the duplicate
content out of the search engine index
so we want to consolidate our page rank
our page Authority our domain Authority
all two original content that's the
whole idea of having a canonical and
it's a quick solution so all you need to
do is add a canonical tag to the header
so let me show you an example if you
have a site let's just use CNN as an
example CNN.com has a lot of content
sometimes given the breadth of content
that they have they may run into
duplicate content so they send simply
just put a canonical tag into their
their header and so by doing that
they're able to tell the search engines
hey this page this domain is the
original if you find yourself with
multiple sites well you can also use
Google search console so remember we use
Google search console in earlier
examples when we talked about links to
your site or we talked about that site
map on page SEO well if we go into
search console we could basically say
look Google because search console is a
Google tool we want to confirm that this
is our domain so this is the domain you
should be focusing on so you can
leverage search console to communicate
with Google regarding which site is
important which is the one that should
get indexed you can use the canonical
you can put that on any page either
website or you can set up a three one
redirect so those are the ways to fix
duplicate content issues 301s are the
easiest is canonicals tend to be
temporary because they're just the page
level and then search console is a a
good method because it communicates with
Google directly and it allows Google to
crawl various web pages differently than
if you didn't tell them okay so if you
didn't tell them they're just going to
grab anything they can so by
communicating via the Google search
console tool it allows you to tell
Google this is the domain I want to
focus in on so let's talk then now about
how the Google algorithms work so we'll
shift gears here and we'll talk about
how these algorithms work on Google so
Google uses advanced concepts retrieve
data so what they do is they're
spidering they're spidering they're
collecting web pages and they're taking
all these web pages back to their server
and anytime somebody does a query
they're delivering those web pages
within milliseconds they're delivering
results based on your query so that's in
general how it works so it uses a a
combination of different algorithms to
deliver the best results they want the
best results and so some of the most
popular algorithms below are Google
Panda Google penguin and Google rank
brain so these are all things that
Google has done to make sure that
they're constantly tweaking their search
engines to deliver the best results so
let's talk about some of these these
popular algorithms and before we talk
about these popular algorithms let's
just make one thing clear that Google's
always tweaking their algorithms on
their search engine and so if you want
to get an idea how often they do it well
they do it every day they're constantly
tweaking it but they what they do is
they release major changes to their
algorithm a few times a year so if you
want to get a sense of what those
changes look like well you could go to
moz.com and you can go to Google Dash
algorithm Dash change and you could see
here that hey Google changes its search
algorithm around 500 to 600 times while
most of these are minor Google again
rolls out major changes like Panda like
penguin that affects search results in
significant ways so you can go here and
you can go all the way back to 2000 and
see some of the algorithm changes that
have occurred over the last few years
and you can see here the last major one
was done in August of 2018 that was the
medic core update so they're constantly
making changes to their search engine to
deliver a more concise more better
ecosystem for the end user so if it's a
better search engine for the end user
end users are going to come back so the
whole idea is continuing to tweak the
system that the algorithms to better
show more accurate results and so let's
take a look at some of the the major
algorithm changes that they've done in
the past so the first is we'll talk
about Google Panda and Panda was an
algorithm that was released back in
2011. so here we are in 2019 is a few
years ago but still significant in that
really this algorithm emphasized high
quality content because before Panda
there was a there's just a lot of
content out there on the internet and
there was a lot of spam content there
are a lot of duplicate content and so
really the idea behind panda is for
Google to really deliver in their search
engine results Pages high quality
content so what it did was it removed
web pages that had low quality or
duplicate content so that was the whole
idea behind you know the algorithm
nickname Panda it removed low quality
and duplicate content and that kind of
cleaned things up a bit where if you did
a search query now you'd actually see a
better better results and one thing
about panda is because there's so much
quality because Google's indexing so
much there on the internet that it's
constantly being updated it's updated
regularly so the next one we're going to
talk about is Google penguin so penguin
was released after Panda and with that
focused in on was low quality links so
remember we talked about link building
we talked about quality links over
quantity so naturally you're going to
have links naturally from all websites
whether that be high quality or low
quality the whole idea behind this
algorithm is to sever the links that are
low quality and so the idea behind that
was they focused on two areas so they
focused in on Links games and keyword
stuffing so that's what penguin focused
on was link schemes were basically link
almost link farming where you produced
Mass amounts of backlinks and not all of
them were good quality they weren't
natural link links links should be
natural from one high quality site or
blog to another high quality cider blog
and by creating lengths games you've
created an ecosystem where links just
went to irrelevant low quality spam
related pages and so Google's Penguins
algorithm update focused in on that
effort to remove or combat pages that
had poor links from being indexed in
their search engine results and then
they also combated keyword stuffing
keyword stuffing is nothing more than
taking your targeted keyword and
stuffing it into the content of your
page or title tag your meta description
so any sites that were caught up doing
that basically suffer the consequences
because what penguin did was take care
of sites that basically were accused of
keyword stuffing or had characteristics
of keyword stuffing and they removed
sites that had a lot of links pointing
to it from poor quality sites and vice
versa sites that really had a lot of
external links pointing to other poor
quality sites so that's what penguin did
they took a look at those two areas and
so we talk about link schemes again
penguin's aim was to decrease the
ranking of web pages that created
artificially by using black hat
techniques and basically what I mean by
black hat techniques that artificially
creating length that just didn't make
sense just for the sake of getting the
backlink just for the sake of passing
link juice and so that's what a link
scheme is or was and so Google basically
tweaked their algorithm to combat those
poor link schemes and so keyword
stuffing as I mentioned a minute ago
it's just repetitive usage of the same
keyword and that just basically suffers
the content is the thing that suffers
here and when the content suffers the
end users suffer so Google is all about
quality content and when you have
quality content and that quality
contents and text and users find what
they're looking for chances are they're
going to go back to the search engine to
continue to find what they're looking
for with the end result being presented
with quality content so keyword stuffing
really dilutes the quality of the
content and then let's talk about the
third algorithm which is rank brain so
rank brain is a processing algorithm
that uses machine learning and what that
does that machine learning interprets
search queries that users search on
Google so for example if rankbrain sees
a word or phrase that isn't familiar
with basically the machine can make a
guess as to what words or phrases might
have a similar meaning and filter the
result accordingly so basically take
these search engine queries and present
them in a way that's logical so that the
end result can be something that's
relevant to what you're looking for and
so for example if you're searching for
online marketing you will get results
related for digital marketing on search
changing remote Pages why because
rankbrain will interpret that particular
keyword and they're trying to basically
match based on all the data they
collected what words or phrases might
have a similar meaning so online
marketing digital marketing have similar
meanings now that we've talked about
some of the different algorithm changes
that Google has made over the years and
continues to make let's um segue into
the types of SEO and so when we talk
about the types of SEO we're really
talking about doing what's right what's
expected versus doing something that you
know is trying to cheat the system and
so you may hear the terminology black
cat SEO white hat SEO or gray hat SEO
and so the whole idea behind these
terminologies is that hey what are we
supposed to be doing here in terms of
following best practices in order to get
our Pages ranked on the search engines
for the keyword queries because covet
and so let's talk about website
architecture now so basically when I say
website architecture what I mean is we
want to give the search engines an idea
of how our websites built so website
architecture and the structure of
websites important and so every website
has a hierarchy it starts with the home
page the home page is the top page it's
the the domain it's where most people go
to find other pages of your website and
so generally you're going to have a
scenario where you're going to have a
home page with you know if you sell
products multiple categories and in
those categories you're gonna have
multiple products so the generally
that's how a web architecture flows it
flows from top down and the reason for
having a good website architecture is
internal links are spread equally so you
want to make sure again not to apply a
black hat method or a gray hat method of
pointing all links to one page you want
links naturally to spread throughout
your web website because not just from
an SEO benefit but from an end user
perspective you want users to flow
through your website naturally so if
you're planning on developing websites
from an SEO perspective you know could
take these things into consideration so
we want to take into account the site
architecture navigation we want to take
into account the URL remember we talked
about URL structure and on-page SEO the
rule of thumb is if you can read it the
search engines will read it so we want
to keep it clear and concise and
relevant to the content of that page
when we talk about responsive design
we're talking about multiple devices so
you don't build a website just for
desktop especially when mobile is being
used by a majority of the users around
the world so you want to build a website
that's both desktop friendly and mobile
friendly we also want to take into
account A robot's text file and a
robot's text file is simply just a text
file that allows the search search
engines to index certain pages it tells
them what not to index and so you can
always find the robot's text file
normally if you go to a website let's
just say we go to valleyfig.com and then
we type in robot or robots.txt file here
we could see if I type in robots.txt
file here this basically is a file a
text file that's in the root directory
and it simply just gives the search
engines an idea of what they're allowed
to index and what they're not allowed to
index anything with a disallow means hey
search engines please don't index these
pages so that's what a robot's text file
does and every site should have it
because there's some pages on your
website that you inherently don't want
the search engines to index and you want
to optimize for the Crawlers so that
means that making sure that your pages
are available and that means also
submitting a sitemap remember we submit
our site map via the Google search
console so good site architecture not
only makes content easy to find but also
helps to gain traffic because hey if
your site is easy it's well organized
it's built multiple devices the URLs are
easy then all that's going to be
appearance the search engines and when
it's apparent to the search engines it's
going to get indexed I want to get
indexed then you're going to get found
and you're going to get the traffic so
it's just a natural progression it's
best practice so some important features
of good architecture are again that URL
structure code your site navigation and
CSS or HTML make it easy for the search
engines to follow build a comprehensive
structure for an internal linking
meaning they should be natural internal
links if a page is relevant to another
page then create an internal link if you
have a very big website with a lot of
content or a lot of products then create
a breadcrumb navigation okay so we're
maybe from there with that on Amazon as
an example
amazon.com has a lot of products and if
you're navigating from one product to
another in one directory or one category
to another category then Amazon creates
what they call breadcrumbs to help you
navigate back to where you were quickly
so these are all good best practices for
good side architecture good side
architecture equals search engine
results so responsive design helps to
make your website mobile friendly it
will increase the amount of time the
user spends on your website which may
improve site ranking so let's talk a
second about mobile friendliness so if I
go back to Google search console there
happens to be inserts console a mobile
usability report and so if I click on
that report basically what it's going to
show me is pages that are do not follow
Google's best practices so some of
Google's best practices are making sure
that the text is easy to read that
clickable elements aren't necessarily
close to one another and the viewport is
set to the appropriate device meaning
the screen is set to the appropriate
device okay and so basically if we are
found in violation then the page is
affected are going to get flagged by
Google and if the page is affected or
flagged by Google then those pages won't
get indexed and so we want to keep an
eye on the mobile usability report in
Google search console so remember it's
better to have a good site architecture
that bonds can easily index so Bots will
give preference to web pages with
relevant content and in the end it will
help your website rank better and as a
side note always use a site map to make
it easy for the Bots to crawl your
website so we covered that and on page
as a reminder if I go back to search
console and if I click on sitemaps I I
can go ahead and submit my sitemap so if
I created an XML version of my sitemap
called
sitemap.xml and I submit that basically
what I'm doing is I'm saying Hey Google
here's my sitemap file and in that
sitemap file are all the pages on my
website that want to get indexed and
when you submit your sitemap to Google
basically they're going to discover
those URLs and index those URLs and
their search index and that expedites
the process of getting indexed it
expedites the process of getting found
on search and it expedites the process
of getting clicks on your search results
pages and and having that traffic go to
your website where they can enjoy the
user experience and convert and remember
the robots text file is there to allow
Google and other search engines to know
what pages to crawl so good website
architecture like for example Amazon
they use breadcrumbs they have a
hierarchy in terms of of categories okay
so you can see how it's evenly dispersed
on the left side on the right side of
poor website architecture is very
slanted in One Direction a lot of
internal links no bread crumbs the
navigation isn't very clear so we want
to make sure things are simple and easy
last metric we want to look at is
backlinks so content having more
backlinks from good domains will
effectively improve your SEO performance
we talk about backlinks with off-page
SEO and remember quality over quantity
and so we can measure backlinks going
back into Moz we can use moz's Link
Explorer tools so remember if I type in
a domain Valley fig I can get some
metrics related off-page SEO including
my domain Authority but more importantly
I can see what links are pointing to my
site in this case valleyfig.com so I can
see they're 575 link domains I can see
there's 7900 inbound links and so just
by clicking on that I can get a idea of
the types of websites that are linking
to my site and their domain Authority
and their spam score Google search
console so if you go back into search
console you can also just click on links
and we should be able to get an idea of
you know what websites are linking to
our site and more importantly we want to
be able to see not only what sites but
what pages they're linked to remember we
want our backlinks pointing to Interior
Pages not necessarily the home page so
here I can see the top link page for
valleyfair.com is slash recipes so we
want links pointing to our interior page
is not necessarily the home page that's
what's going to help your performance
your rankings for all your pages not
just your home page so having quality
back links pointing to Interior Pages
help boost the domain Authority and the
page Authority for that particular page
so again using Moz link Explorer tool or
using the links report in search console
are good sources for you to identify
backlinks so when we look at these these
reports we want to look at the Domain
authority of these sites that are
linking ours the number of outbound
links to the site or specific pages on
our site we want to be able to look at
the ratio of Link distribution you know
we want to be able to look at how many
follows and no follows so most of this
if not all of these metrics are in Moz
so if I go back to Moz I can actually
see you know which ones pointing which
ones are followed the total quality of
the link that's pointing to our site
again bam so Moz link explore or report
tends to give us all the information we
need in order to measure and get a sense
of our backlinks that help us with
off-page SEO so there are other tools
out there there's hrefs again search
console there's other SEO platforms out
there that'll help you measure backlinks
okay now that we covered everything with
on-page SEO and off-page SEO and really
everything SEO in general let's take a
little quiz and if you could go ahead
and just put your answers in the comment
section below so just a little quiz here
and we'll start out with question one
which of the following type of sitemap
is specifically designed for search
spiders so the answer is either a HTML
sitemap or B XML sitemap so go ahead and
put your answers in the comment section
below I'll give you just another second
to think about that okay another
question for you you from a search
engine perspective which of the
following link types could cause a
negative effect on your rankings it's
either a purchase link or B no follow
link so again if you could if you know
the answer or just take an educated
guess go ahead and put the answers in
the comment section below okay next
question a websites robots text file
serves what function is it a tell the
Bots what pages should be crawled and
not crawled or B tells the Bots what
links should be follow and nofollow so
if you know the answer you feel good
about your answer go ahead and put it in
the comment section below today we're
going to talk about SEO tips and tricks
so let's get started and throughout this
series we're gonna have a few tips to
share with you and we'll start out with
tip number one up for smarter ways to do
keyword research and so if you listen to
any of our SEO tutorials in the past you
know keyword research is the first step
but the most crucial step in starting
SEO so when we do keyword research we
want to be able to basically find
keywords that we feel are relevant to
our business that we want to be found on
search for and so here are a few tips
that can help you do that research in a
more efficient manner the first thing we
want to do is identify a list of
keywords that are relevant so we only
want to focus on relevant keywords for
our business that's a given so what I
would suggest is as a best practice
maybe you know put down some of these
keywords in a spreadsheet so think of
them as a theme of keywords because when
you do research you're going to want to
include a theme of keywords related to
one another so you can pick the best
ones out of that theme and so as an
example if we have a company that sells
dried figs in a spreadsheet as an
example if I show you a spreadsheet
Maybe be we want to focus in on just
dried fig and maybe we want to focus it
on dried fig recipes so go ahead and put
those in a column you know some of these
keywords that you know you want to be
found for so that's really the first
step they need to be relevant so put
them in a spreadsheet so that you can
build keywords around that list then we
want to choose keywords and when we
choose keywords we want to have some
criteria around choosing them and so we
always want to choose keywords with a
lot of volume and what I mean by volume
I mean how many people on average type
in that keyword or a related keyword per
month the second criteria is the keyword
a product fit meaning you know is the
keyword relevant you always want to stay
true to relevancy the third is
commercial intent what is the intent of
the keyword is it trying to get us a
sale is it answering a question so what
is the intent of that keyword and then
last it's difficulty so we want to
definitely take a look at how difficult
a key word is to writing for on organic
search so that's some of the criteria
you may have some additional criteria
that you want to use but this is the
criteria basically for choosing keywords
so again we want to prefer keywords with
high volume you want to be careful of
seasonality so remember seasonality in
this example Christmas tree you're only
going to have a spike you know during
the winter or excuse me the October
November December months so be careful
of seasonality when choosing high volume
keywords and again keywords that are
relevant to your product even though it
doesn't have much search volume reality
always trumps uh volume or any other
metric commercial intent so we want to
look at keywords that for example have
Buy in them they may have low search
volume but if somebody's typing in that
keyword then we can insinuate that the
consumer who typed in that keyword is
ready to make the purchase so we want to
look at what the intent is of that
keyword and then again the difficulty
always opt for keywords that have low
difficulty or competition and so in
order to get these metrics we can use
third-party tools and I'm going to show
you a couple of examples of third-party
tools you can use that will give you
some of this information so your first
tool I'm going to show you is Google ads
Keyword Planner so if I'm having Google
ads account I could simply go to tools
and then choose the Keyword Planner and
from there I want to find new keywords
so if I choose the keyword dried figs
because that's the key word I put in my
spreadsheet that I'm interested in
optimizing for and then maybe drive fake
recipes that was the other keyword theme
so if I enter those two keywords in just
to begin with basically what Google is
going to give me is the average search
monthly volume so here I can see dried
figs I have an average monthly search
bomb 8100 that means on average over the
last 12 months that's how many people
have typed in that keyword here I can
see a little bit of a trend I just hover
my mouse over that graph I could see
again for seasonality impact if there is
any seasonality what the volume is on
average per month then I could see the
competition is high and because this is
Google ads because it's paid search
they're going to give me a sense or an
idea of what I should be bidding on the
keyword now that's another topic for
another day but it's good information to
have because if you're not ranking for a
keyword you could decide to bid on it
for paid search so don't discard the
bidding information go ahead and put it
in a spreadsheet for later use but for
now we're focused in on keywords that
are relevant how much volume how much
competition okay so once I get this
information here I can simply go back to
my spreadsheet and put that information
in there what's the volume for dried fig
what is the competition now for
competition notice that Google ads gives
us a high or low now if we're trying to
measure ratio between volume and
competition we want to get an actual
sense of what that competition is so
what I always do as a best practice is
go into Google search if I go to Google
Search and I type in dried figs I'm
going to see the actual volume is 34
million 500 000. so I could see that's
the actual search volume for this
particular keyword however if I add a
syntax called all in title before that
keyword with a colon space and then hit
enter Then I could see the actual volume
reduces to Thirty one thousand and
basically what this tells me is that 31
000 listings or results have the keyword
dried figs in the title tag so if a web
page has dried fig or targeted keyword
in the title tag then ideally we can
insinuate that that page is trying to
rank for that keyword so therefore in
order for us to rank number one on
Google we have to jump over 31 000
results so we want to be able to include
this information into our keyword
analysis so if I go into our keyword
analysis here and I go ahead and enter
in that information so what's my keyword
my keyword is dried figs okay my volume
was 80 100 my competition was 31 000 and
so that gives me a ratio of 81 divided
by 31 000 if I make that into a
percentage basically 26 so that's my
keyword Effectiveness index or Kei or
ratio between volume and competition and
so that's a way that you can gather
information is by using Google ads enter
the information into a spreadsheet and
then sort all your data by Kei you could
sort it by volume you could sort of a
competition all these metrics matter
alternatively as another tool you can
use Moz so Moz has a keyword Explorer
tool okay so if I type in the keyword
dried figs I'm focusing on the United
States I could say that Moz says hey
look there's anywhere between 4 300 and
6500 in terms of volume out of 100 the
difficulty is 41. and so I can expect a
click-through rate of you know 41 and so
basically the great thing about moz's
keyword Explorer tool is I can also look
at the serp analysis search engine
results Pages what serp stands for and I
can analyze the serp for a particular
keyword in Moz so I want to be able to
understand what my competition is doing
in so here I could see if I really want
to try and optimize for that keyword I
could see what the other pages are
ranked for that keyword in the on page
one I can also see what local results
show up for that keyword so here I could
see that we have a number of different
sites listed here so if we want to be
number one these are the sites that are
basically above us that we need to climb
over to be number one on Google so I
find that the keyword explorator in Moz
is very helpful for understanding your
competition as well as getting a
alternative check on volume and
competition or difficulty if you will
and so remember we want to identify a
list of keywords that are relevant I
can't stress that enough we want to
choose keywords based on difficulty we
want to choose keywords based on volume
on Commercial intent and more important
relevancy we can also identify Trends
from a site search query like Amazon and
know what your competitors are ranking
for so we can also go back into Moz and
we could see just by typing in some of
the keywords we're focusing on we can
see if our competitors are ranking for
the same keywords just by using that
keyword Explorer tool and then another
thing we want to look at is LSI or
latent semantic indexing so that's a
fancy word which basically means we want
to find keywords related to the topic of
the page you're trying to optimize so if
there are other keywords on that page
then you could sway in that direction
and so when it comes to choosing
keywords you want to choose always a
primary and secondary keyword and so if
we go back to our spreadsheet it doesn't
necessarily always have to be just one
keyword it doesn't necessarily have to
be dried figs we could choose another
keyword that has a good volume to
competition ratio so we want to choose
keywords that are always relevant and if
we're analyzing nothing but relevant
keywords then we want to be able to
choose keywords that have a good ratio
between volume and competition so you
always want to choose at least two
keywords per page we could also stay up
to date on industry news as we'll help
you learn new jargon so it doesn't hurt
to subscribe to sites like search engine
watch or search engine land they have
lots of good tips so here I'll show you
what that one of those sites look like
if I simply just go to search
enginewatch.com I find this is a good
resource to stay up on the latest news
when it comes to search engines here we
could see the Y SEO and front-end
developers are the perfect search
marketing team another article about
optimizing your channel YouTube channel
five easy steps so there's a lot of
information here on search engine watch
that pertain to SEO and keyword research
we could also look at other third-party
sites like Wikipedia Reddit and core for
example so if I go to quora I can do a
search for dried figs and I could see
what's being written about that topic so
that should give me some ideas to build
a keyword a list around so for example
the health benefits of dried figs okay
our dry figs safe for diabetes best ways
to eat dried figs so those are all good
keyword themes that we could build a
keyword list around and I did that
simply just by typing in dried figs on
cora so that's a a good tip for you to
leverage when you're trying to build out
a keyword list okay let's uh talk about
tip number two which is publish high
quality content to get more traffic to
your website so it's all about content
so we've already done the keyword
research we still need to kind of merge
the two but when we talk about merging
the two it's not just building content
around those keywords it's much more
than that when it comes to SEO and so
that's why we always talk about high
quality content so let's talk about some
of the tips that can help you create
high quality content so first tip is we
want to be able to publish longer and
engaging content longer running game and
content tends to rank higher in Google
why because you have more content to
work with and when you have more content
to work with you can optimize it you can
structure it you can insert different
assets like videos and images and by
keeping it long you're gonna likely keep
it engaging and so Google tends to lean
in favor of content that is well
organized structured and long because it
is more likely to be engaging for the
end user we definitely want to include
this target keywords so you want to be
able to you know insert those keywords
into those meta tag descriptions into
those title tags into those alt tags but
you want to work them in naturally you
don't want to force anything content
should be naturally written because if
it's naturally written it's going to be
engaging so we want to use LSI keywords
and the content so LSI or basically
latent semantic indexing basically just
means different terms and concepts
related to your target keywords so feel
free to use terms that are similar to
what you're currently using these
keywords can definitely be used for SEO
because they can create more visibility
and potentially higher rankings because
it gives you an opportunity to use
keywords that are natural and work for
different variations and let's look at
examples so if you're optimizing an
e-commerce category page and your
keyword is one mix used for men so we
want to use keywords closely related to
one mixed use for men for example
running shoes for men or sport running
shoes for men outdoor sports shoes or
air cushion shoes let's take a look an
example of Amazon so if I go to Amazon I
could see the one mix shoes from end
page and if I look at this page I can
see a lot of product and each product
has basically some content associated
with it I.E the title Battle of the
particular product and so you want to be
able to use different descriptors for
this particular product for example
men's running shoes or breathable
lightweight gym sports shoes or
lightweight casual sneakers or walking
casual sneaker all of these are LSI
related keywords they are similar to
what we're trying to optimize for so you
don't necessarily always have to be
brand heavy or stick with one keyword
you could definitely show variation
especially on the e-commerce side if
you're dealing with different products
so we want to make the content readable
with the help of visuals subtitles and
bullet points so if your e-commerce you
want to make sure that page is laid out
properly easy to read here I could see
the descriptor along with the title all
kind of merged together and so there's
no breakout of okay this is the product
name this description it's kind of one
all in one which I like it just makes it
more natural sounding okay and you can
see these are all broken out uh pretty
well laid out page and Amazon is more or
less you know consistent in terms of how
their pages are laid out so make it
readable add visuals add subtitles add
bullet points it helps break out a lot
of the content especially if you have a
long amount of content or a large amount
of content so the use of subtitles
bullet points and visuals will help
break it out structure it and make it
more engaging for the end user you
definitely want to write an effective
and organized content in order to reduce
the bounce rate so there is correlation
between engagement and bounce rate the
more you structure the more you add
visuals the more you add subtitles the
more engaged somebody's gonna be the
less likely they are to bounce from the
pitch we also want to share customer
reviews and ratings so if you have a web
page you sell products even if you don't
sell products it's always good to have
testimonials or some type of customer
review so if we go back to our example
on Amazon and we clicked on a product
one of the running shoe products we look
here we can see the image we could see
kind of the description well I may not
be so interested in buying this product
I want to know a little bit more about
it well that's where the breaking point
comes in that's where the decision
Factor comes in where if I read other
reviews then I can possibly have my mind
made up to buy this product so here I
could see that not only their reviews
but there's testimonials so I could see
that here you can see that there's a lot
of stars and you can see the kind of the
review title these running shoes are
very comfortable and lightweight so you
have a lot of different feedback and so
reading custom reviews is always helpful
because even though you're making the
decision it kind of will help sway you
in one direction or another at least it
does for me so that's the the beauty of
a customer review and a rating we want
to be able to use those to our advantage
and then you want to be able to update
your content on a regular basis this so
and that goes for testimonials and
reviews you want to make sure you're
always getting reviews because if you're
always getting reviews then that's just
adding to the particular product and so
if you're always updating your content
on a regular basis as well then Google's
going to be able to see that and Google
likes fresh content okay we also want to
include the benefits of the product so
if you're selling a product any product
you always want to include the benefits
you want to do as much as you can to
make your product engage into the end
user enticing so that they can buy it so
in addition to customer reviews or
adding content about the product you
want to include benefits so if we go
back to Amazon here we could see Amazon
list a lot of the benefits or one mix in
this case list a lot of the benefits so
here you can see all the descriptors
about the particular products it's got
Rubber Sole it's got a breathable
textile lighting you get free hot
quality socks with every shoe so these
are some of the features and if we can
continue to scroll down we can see some
of the details about the fabric type the
specifics about the fabric and a lot of
information on this product page even a
sizing chart so a lot of different
features that will help the end User
make the decision so don't hold back add
as much information as you possibly get
as much information as you have
available it doesn't hurt because in the
end what you're trying to do from a
product perspective is sell the product
and you can't really sell it unless you
have information that's going to
convince the user that this product is
what they want to buy so include the
warranty size recommendation return
policy and some offers so it should all
be listed on the page easy for the end
user to see so can't stress it enough
provide as much product information as
possible go back here here it has a
sizing chart what colors are available
again some of the descriptors if I
scroll down here I can see some more of
the benefits you know waffle rubber
outsole soft deodorant insole again
fabric type it's got all sorts of
information it's got images about the
fabric itself the shoe itself how it's
structured so a lot of information about
this and it even does a comparison and
so there's a lot of information about
this particular product so don't hold
back add as much as you can to get bench
the end user so in the case uh the one
mix on Amazon you know they had a sizing
chart you know they had an FAQ they had
additional information what other
products do customers view from one mix
and then testimonials so these are some
of the basic bits of information you
want to add on your page if you don't
have customer views it's okay add FAQ in
its place again the end result is to
convince the customer to purchase the
product and then build a comprehensive
internal linking structure of web pages
so every product page should link to
similar products so if I go back here
here I can see other products from one
mix so you should always have a linking
structure so that if the end user
doesn't want to particularly buy that
particular product then you have links
available so they can go to another page
and then add different varieties and
related short videos of the product so
if we go back to our product page you
know they have different varieties that
they're showcasing here they have the
size chart they even have a size
convertible chart so if you're dealing
with metrics you can go over to us
metrics vice versa you can add a video
you know show a video uh if you're
selling running shoes several videos
somebody working out you know it doesn't
have to be a full-blown commercial per
se but it could be a short 30 second
video of what the shoe looks like on
somebody else's feed so that they could
see somebody walking with those shoes on
so video doesn't have to be a big
production you could do it right from
your phone so review your content before
where you publish this goes without
saying you want to do that just you make
sure you include everything possible
because when the content does get
published remember Google is going to
index that content when they index it
it's going to show up in the search
results so we want to make sure we have
all the information readily available
not only for the end user but for Google
as well we want to be able to analyze
our meta tags in url to improve
click-through rate so this is important
because the meta tags I.E the title tag
and The Meta description and the URLs
what shows up in Google search results
so we have title tags the first that's
the first important element that's what
shows up in the search results so what
we want to do is we want to optimize the
title tag and when we optimize it we
want to use modifiers and when I say
modifiers I mean you know feel free to
use the word best or cash back or free
shipping or discount so for example if
you're selling running shoes 25 best
sneakers or up to 70 off or free
shipping or buy shoes on discount very
action oriented but you know it includes
these modifiers that are going to help
somebody click on that link so some tips
for optimizing the title tag in addition
to the modifiers we want to watch the
title length and we want to include
those Target keywords in the title tag
so remember you're likely gonna have two
keywords to work with you want to have
at least one of those keywords in your
title tag so with the modifier you know
up to 60 to 65 characters in length with
that targeted keyword should get you a
good title tag that's going to get
somebody to click on it so let's look at
an example so if I type in the keyword
best recipes for dried figs you know
here I can scroll down here's my title
tag stands out my URL is right
underneath that and underneath the URL
are is the meta description and so here
I can see some modifiers 188 best autumn
dried fake recipes or 25 fantastic fig
recipes or 10 best cooking dried fig
recipes so these are all modifiers
they're going to help somebody get the
click get them to click on your link and
go to your website so when you don't hit
the 65 character limit if you go over
that Google's going to cut off the title
tag so we want to avoid that at all
possible so the whole idea is you know
like 10 best cooking dried fake recipes
by yummly that's a good enticing title
tag okay it takes into account a
modifier includes the targeted keyword
and is under the 65 character count some
additional tips for writing meta
description we always want to provide a
unique description for each web page of
the website so no duplicate meta tag
descriptions every page use needs to be
unique then we also want to be specific
about what we're offering so if you have
say you're selling headphones and you
have a particular particular set of
headphones from a different specific
brand include that in the meta
description if you have that particular
product from that brand on sale include
that in the meta description so you want
to be as specific as possible the whole
idea behind a meta description is to
describe the page but also to get the
end user to click on your link so here's
an example of using modifiers and
describing a page if we look at Amazon
again we can see this example here and
if we look at it on Google search
results so if I type in Amazon Bluetooth
headsets ten dollars are on sale here we
can see a lot of Amazon listings in
Google search here you can see the use
of modifiers in the title tag and also
in the meta description here we could
see that you know this particular
headset Bluetooth headset is on sale 50
off so if something's on sale feel free
to include it be descriptive about the
page let people know where they're going
and use those modifiers don't be afraid
to use numbers in The Meta description
even if it's the price itself even if
it's not on sale but it is the price
included it's not going to hurt the more
information you can include in a meta
description the better chance you have
of somebody clicking on that link use
numbers symbols you know percentages off
always help use catchy words like
discount or cash back when you're
competing with other listings on the
page so if you have something on sale if
it's on clearance list that it's on
clearance here I can see they even
included the coupon code so feel free to
list as much specific information about
that page as possible the whole idea is
you're competing with your own web pages
but in other cases with competitors so
the meta description along with the
title tag and the URL helps separate out
you from the rest of the listings on
search engine results and we don't want
to keyword stuff we want to keep it
within 100 160 something characters or
160 65 characters because Google will
break off The Meta description just like
they do with the title tag and so we
want clean natural written meta
descriptions that separate you from the
competition so that means including the
keywords we're making sure those
keywords are naturally included in the
meta description so if I go back again
to valleyfig.com and I could see the
meta description hey welcome to the best
resource online for dried fig recipes
Savers sweet snacks are healthy dried
fig recipes we've got it all they start
cooking with figs and so it's natural
sounding it does include the keyword
it's not keyword stuffing it's natural
sounding that's hopefully going to get
that person to click on this particular
website let's turn our attention to the
URL so we want to make sure that the URL
is basically taken into account best
practices so if we take a look at this
particular URL here it doesn't
necessarily look as attractive as we
would like so first of all I don't
understand some of it so that makes it
unpleasant boring and messy to say the
least so you want URLs that you know
basically are clean and understandable
so in other words we want to make them
SEO friendly because if they're SEO
friendly somebody understands the URL
then they're likely going to click on it
so the old rule of thumb is if you can
read the URL then the search engines can
read the URL so here are some tips for
creating friendly URLs for SEO make it
readable you want to include the target
keyword in the URL so if it's dried figs
the URL should include dried figs if
it's dried fig recipes make sure it's
dried fig recipes now avoid using too
many subdirectories in the URLs so we
want to keep it as close as possible to
the root directory and match the URLs to
titles most of the time so let's go back
to our example here here here we could
see this is valleyfake.com recipes not
necessarily dried fig recipes but
recipes nonetheless it's in the root
directory okay so at all costs now this
is in some cases unavoidable given that
you may be dealing with an e-commerce
website that's calling you know content
from a database so if that is the case
you're going to have some Dynamic
parameters in the URL which is fine just
make sure you avoid having too many of
those Dynamic parameters it's
understandable about parameters but the
rule of thumb generally is no more than
two different parameters in the URL so
prefer to create short URLs that's
really the way to go the shorter the
better is the rule of thumb and you know
if you're going to break up the URL then
use hyphens instead of underscores it's
just cleaner it's a more understandable
search engines tend to read it a little
bit easier if it's hyphen so here's what
a friendly only URL looks like for
search you got your domain you got a
subcategory broken up with a hyphen and
then the product so that's like just to
clean URL for particular e-commerce site
that has categories and subcategories so
again we got amazon.com your category
can be Electronics your subcategory it
could be earphones and your product
could be boat earphones it's that simple
let's start with talking about rich
Snippets this is tip number four so we
want to add Rich Snippets to improve
your website's visibility on serps so
tip number four is all about rich
Snippets so let's start out by asking
ourselves what is a rich snippet so rich
snippet is simply just a term used to
describe structured data markup that you
as a website owner can add to your HTML
so hypertext markup language or HTML is
what is basically constructs a page so
if we can add more information into that
that will internalize search engines
like Google to better understand the
information that's on that web page so
the more Google understands about that
web page the more they can put into the
search engine results page so rich
Snippets is basically some structured
data markup that we can add to our
existing HTML and so if we want to add
Rich Snippets to search engines then how
would you prefer your products to be
displayed well if we have products then
we want to make sure that maybe we have
reviews or maybe we have so other
information in there like links to our
site okay so there's a lot of different
types of Rich Snippets that you know we
can add that Google can recognize and
add to the search engine results so if
you have a product then there's a lot of
things we can add like specifically
product reviews so we want to be able to
add more information to the search
engine results by working in some rich
Snippets so basically the whole idea is
to set up the rich snippet to drive
targeted traffic okay so because the
more information in the serp the more
likelihood you're going to get the click
and the more likelihood that click is
specific traffic so some of the benefits
of structuring the data for Rich
Snippets are as I mentioned increasing
click-through rates you know also
increasing conversion rates so when you
get the traffic from organic search to
your website if somebody's looking for
specific product and you have a number
of different good reviews showing up
let's just say five stars out of five
stars and you have a hundred reviews
showing five stars then you know
somebody's probably going to send take
some trust in your brand in your
conversion rate probability is going to
go higher it also helps improve your
search engine visibility because you're
adding more information so in other
words the more Google knows about your
page the likelihood it's going to rank
that page and it's more likely that that
information that's contained in that
rich snip it is going to get featured in
either the knowledge graph which is that
graph on the right side or in a featured
snippet which usually shows up at the
top of search engine results so in other
words the more information you give
Google the more they can use that
information on their search results page
and there's no disagreeing that the more
information that you have in your search
engine result the likelihood of getting
more traffic increases so for Rich
Snippets you could always start with
images so some of the common properties
that you can add to your product page if
you have a product page just a page
itself is an image you can always start
there you can always add a description
you can always add in ratings and you
can always add in reviews so these are
some of the most common attributes you
can add as a rich snippet so if you add
that Google picks it up it's going to
include that information in the search
results okay some others are offers
prices site links links to your site and
product availability so all the
information can be conveyed to Google
Google understands what you're trying to
pass along it's going to include that in
the search results so did you know that
according to hrefs over 99.58 of
featured pages that have structured data
already rank in the top 10 list of the
Google search results page so in other
words if you have Rich Snippets in your
page your chances of ranking in the top
10 of a Google result is going to be
very very very good okay let's talk
about tip number five optimize your site
structure for great user experience so
let's go over some of the tips that you
would do for planning a good website for
SEO and so tip number one is you want a
Ural structure that follows your sites
navigation hierarchy so obviously home
page interior pages so depending on what
type of site you have obviously the
navigation needs to follow that site's
navigation that site hierarchy and it
all starts with a home page you want to
optimize your home page to try up
traffic to your product pages so the
home page is nothing more than a doorway
into your website and so the site's
navigation should link to all those
different products so if you have an
e-commerce site with sub categories or
categories subcategories then you want
to be able to make sure your navigation
reflects that you want to build a
comprehensive structure for internal
linking as well because when you're from
the home page obviously you want to be
able to easily navigate to other Pages
however when you're on other Pages you
want to be able to have a link pointing
back to relevant pages and not
necessarily on the home page so this
serves two purposes one for the end user
obviously you want the end user to
navigate through your website sites
seamlessly right second for the search
engines they're following links they
want to be able to understand how your
website flows and links together so you
don't want a scenario where it's a
one-way street from the home page to
Interior Pages you want basically a home
page to Interior interior to other
relevant interior pages and that could
be a lateral or that can be a situation
where it's a hierarchy for example home
page category subcategory subcategory
Etc you want to be able to make sure
your site is constructed in a manner in
which the search engine can read it so
CSS or cascading style sheets or
hypertext markup language HTML are your
two most common languages that's
basically what browsers load that's what
search engines like to index it just
makes it easy for them to understand
what your page is all about remember we
talked about rich Snippets in the
previous tip writ Snippets are nothing
more than some supplemental HTML to
describe what the page is all about so
that the search engines can understand
that page and include reviews or include
site links in the search engine results
so this is all based on HTML so the more
you provide the search engines in a more
structured manner via HTML the more the
search engines are going to stay on the
page adding breadcrumbs to your product
pages is also a good practice if you
have an e-commerce site and you have a
category then a subcategory then a sub
subcategory then a product page what's
probably not a bad idea to make sure you
have a breadcrumbs so that was that way
somebody can easily go right back from
the product page to say the category
page or to the subcategory page directly
without having to hit the back button or
having to go through the navigation some
good examples I think Amazon does a good
example of using breadcrumbs given the
amount of products they have on their
site so go check out Amazon if you want
a good exam Temple for breadcrumbs and
then canonical tags we want to make good
use of canonical tags and that's in
order to avoid duplicate content so a
canonical tag is nothing more than a
link element basically or an HTML
element that basically prevents
duplicate content issues so in other
words if we have a canonical tag as a
meta tag basically we're telling the
search engines this is the preferred or
canonical version of a web page okay so
use this web page so it signals to the
search engines which page they should
basically index and pay attention to and
avoid at all the other pages that have
similar content so that's the idea
behind a canonical tags so that's a good
best practice and then optimize your
site for desktop and mobile I can't
stress the mobile part enough most users
begin their Journey on mobile so if
you're not sure about what the search
engines like or don't like you can
always refer to Google search console
for an example so if you go to Google
Search console they have a report called
mobile usability so if you click on
mobile usability you can see what pages
they like what pages they don't like
from a mobile perspective and if you
have errors they're going to tell you
what those errors are so if your website
has text that's too small to read
They're going to tell you that these are
the pages with this error and so that
allows you to go and address those
errors because from a Google perspective
if you have if a page has a mobile
usability error then Google will not
index that page so leverage Google
search console to get a sense of what
type of Errors your site has from a
mobile perspective you also want to
prefer to keep your checkout page simple
so again from an e-commerce perspective
you want to keep the checkout page as
simple as possible for obvious reasons
you want the end use user to have a good
experience and you obviously want the
conversion so when I say keep a checkout
page simple really now with today's
technology you can create a one-page
checkout process you want to optimize
your site map so when we talk about site
Maps we want to make sure that it's a
file an XML file that basically includes
all of our URLs and we can then turn
around and give that site map to the
search engines so if you have a sitemap
in XML make sure you go to Google Search
console so if I go to Google Search
console and I click on sitemaps I can
just simply just tell Google where my
site map is located and when they
recognize that sitemap they're going to
be able to basically index the URLs from
that sitemap so we could see here how
many URLs they discover and how many
they index so make sure you create the
site map in an XML format submit the
sitemap via Google search console and
then you can can go back and see how
many pages they've indexed versus how
many you've submitted and you want to
make sure that sitemap is dynamic
meaning anytime you publish a URL that
URL is added to the sitemap fixing
broken links so broken links is not
something you want but it's something
every website has it's unavoidable you
know people publish Pages all the time
there's test Pages there's all sorts of
reasons why a site has broken links you
want to be able to address those and
again going back to Google search
console we can basically see just by
looking at some reports what pages I
have broken links and which ones don't
so we could certainly look at search
console to get information about
basically what pages are broken which
ones aren't and then we want to prefer
predictive searches and integrate
product typographic errors on your
search bar so basically have a search
bar that's a best practice but it
anticipate knowing what people are
typing in so that means maybe going into
Google analytics and looking at the
Search terms report so we can go into
analytics and look at Search terms to
get a sense of what people are searching
for but you know when we talk about
integrating product typographic errors
we're talking also about fonts so we
want to make sure we're using the latest
fonts so that we don't run in any issues
on our website uh people not being able
to read based on a specific font that
you're using and then as a best practice
what I found and this is not necessarily
for everyone but using a live chat
widget sometimes helps in fact I would
even go beyond sometimes on most the
time again depending on your business
but I see most businesses now have live
chat enabled and so basically having
live chat enables somebody who has a
question to immediately reach out to
somebody versus picking up the phone
versus sending an email it's just
instantaneous is gratification in some
ways so inserting live chat on a website
is more common practice than not
nowadays given it it lends to a better
user experience tip number six improve
your page speed and reduce the bounce
rate so let's talk about page speed and
how page speed correlates with higher
bounce rate if it's a high page load and
so according to Crazy page speed is an
important overlooked SEO tactic because
for every second delay and Page load can
result in 11 fewer page views sixty
percent decrease in customer
satisfaction seven percent decline in
conversion rate so you know you can see
here regardless of how specific the
numbers are when you have a page that
loads slow you're going to have lower
user engagement and a poor user
experience so you have to pay attention
to page speed and so since 2010 Google
has been using page speed as a factor
for page ranking in the search engine
results so here's some tips to focus on
making sure your pages are optimal in
terms of speed so enable browser caching
okay you can reduce plugins if you're
using Wordpress as an example you know
disable plugins you're not using get
using a simple website design going back
to tip number five stick with CSS and
HTML don't do anything fancy in terms of
Technology because it's only going to
complicate matters optimize your code
Minify files meaning hey if you're not
using any code just get rid of it
because code has to execute and that
slows down page load time so if your
website has numerous CSS and JavaScript
files basically Minify and combine them
and so that's what we're talking about
there you know you don't necessarily
need a lot of you know JavaScript on
your page you can leverage Google tag
manager or you know other features that
help minimize the number of JavaScript
files you have and so you can also get
some of these ideas by going into Google
analytics so in analytics under Behavior
under site speed under page timings you
can basically see how quick each page
loads and then if you click on speed
suggestions right below page timings
what happens is Google is going to
actually give you some suggested ways to
increase speed so if we let this report
load we'll be able to see some speech
suggestions per page and so here you can
see for example the home page has an
average page load time of 4.89 seconds
you can see right next to that we have
page speed suggestions seven total so if
we click on that basically what it's
going to do is going to launch another
Google product called page speed
insights and what page speed insights is
going to do is it's going to analyze the
page in question whether that be the
home page or an interior page and what
they're actually going to do is not only
analyze the desktop version of your
website but also the mobile version and
so now we can see opportunities to
improve our page speed by making sure
the images are properly sized making
sure server response time is changed
again defer unused CSS not using CSS
that's or getting rid of CSS or
minifying it so there's lots of things
you can do and again this is desktop and
mobile so on the mobile side we could
see some of the other issues too that
are causing High page load and so
analytics site speed reports page speed
insights are good ways to get an idea
really excellent ways to really address
page load time issues so again these are
just some of the common issues with page
load time there could be other factors
so leaning on those page speed insights
reports will definitely help reduce page
load time so basically according to
Google a website should have you know
time to First Bite lesser than 200
milliseconds milliseconds are very very
fast so in case your website is slower
than 200 milliseconds such as 500
milliseconds or more you need to improve
it so you don't even have to measure it
by milliseconds you can even go by
seconds which is what most of us count
time and again you can see that simply
going into these speed suggestions
report in Google analytics so ideally in
terms of seconds you want something
that's about you know four seconds or
less three seconds or less obviously as
fast as possible so case study Walmart
Walmart reported the following results
so Walmart experienced a two percent
increase in conversions for every one
second of page speed Improvement so
think about that there's definitely
correlation between pay age load time
and speed so in conversions and user
engagement so the quicker your page
loads the higher the engagement so with
that Improvement they also experienced
an increment in Revenue so meaning the
pages load people had a better user
experience they were able to check out
easier and that led to more Revenue so
they were able to measure Revenue
against milliseconds and that's
something you can certainly do in
analytics you can correlate Revenue with
bounce rate you can correlate Revenue
with page speed tip number seven build
quality links and increase their domain
authority of your website so Google's
top three search ranking factors
includes link building so you need to
have quality links from quality sites
pointing to your site and so that's a
factor in terms of ranking so that's
falls under off page SEO you need to
build references and links on quality
sites and so building quality links to
your content can give your product or
category Pages or even content or blog
posts a boost in the serps so it's all
about quality over quantity so it's
always building quality links not
quantity so let's talk about what kind
of strategies you should Implement so if
you implement these strategies then
you're going to likely see a lift in the
serps so earn backlinks from relevant
and authoritative web pages so what's
authoritative well authoritative is
subjective to some degree but it's also
measurement in others so you could use
Moz as a good tool to measure page
Authority or domain Authority so if I go
into Moz Moz has a page in domain
Authority score between 1 and 100 and so
you can actually see what sites have
good domain or page Authority just by
entering in the domain so so relevant
you obviously want to rank to something
that's relevant so if you're in the food
industry something food related you want
to promote your content regularly on
social media so social media I always
consider it a whole low hanging fruit
when it comes to backlinking you know
there's so many different social media
platforms available Facebook LinkedIn
Twitter there's so many varieties from
images to Pinterest and Instagram to
video being YouTube so there's lots of
ways to get your content out on social
media that will allow you to not only
promote your band build a community but
also establish a reference back to that
page you can opt for guest blogging okay
so you can reach out to another blogger
and blog on that platform and it can be
reciprocal as well a blogger can
certainly you know blog on your platform
and have a link back and it works both
ways influencer marketing so influencer
marketing is working with somebody who
has a large amount of followers who can
influence those followers to you know
mention you in a hashtag link to your
particular product or brand or even
drive traffic to your site so you want
to take advantage of social media
platforms and start your own page as
well so Facebook's a good example it
could be you have any YouTube channel if
you're into video you can certainly set
up a YouTube channel build a following
around YouTube as well so always start
your own page if that's the platform of
choice the last thing you should do is
set up a page on social media and not
keep it updated you could certainly
participate in forums you can
participate in other websites like quora
or Reddit that's very you know content
based content driven user driven I
always recommend starting your own blog
blog is a good way to not only generate
content but it's a good way to
incorporate different types of content
so you can set up different types of
content and categories it's a good way
to incorporate different assets like
images and video that's a good way to
get users engaged by having comments or
having social share buttons it's a good
way to leverage that content onto other
social media platforms so there's lots
of benefits to blogging very few cons
the only con would be if time gets trade
but it's better to have one blog post in
one month consistently than not blogging
at all so getting listed on high quality
link directories like Yahoo directory is
still a way to add a link from a high
quality site and then make use of broken
link building so again on the last tip
we mentioned search console search
console certainly has reports available
for you that allow you to see what pages
on your site are no longer there and
allow you to see what pages they're
linking from and you can also do
testimonials there's lots of ways to
generate quality links in a way you
almost have to get creative but create
it in a way that's going to generate
quality not quantity quality is the key
so even if it's one source whether that
be somebody else's blog so be it as long
as it's quality that's what counts so
let's talk about some of the key
takeaways from today's tips so remember
tip number one we want to opt for
smarter ways to do keyword research so
remember we want to look at volume we
want to look at competition we want to
create themes put them in a spreadsheet
so we want to be smarter in which in the
way in which we choose our keyword tip
number two remember publish high quality
content to get more traffic when we say
high quality content remember break up
the content use different assets
organize it structure it you know make
sure it's answering somebody's questions
then we talked about in tip number three
analyzing your meta tags and URLs so we
want to make sure that title tag meta
descriptions are creative these
modifiers like numbers or promotions you
know we don't want to go over character
counts we want to make them unique and
distinct so that somebody clicks on them
then we talked about rich Snippets and
tip number four remember Rich Snippets
are just additional HTML that
communicates the search engine so the
search engines can understand exactly
what's on your page so if you have
recipes if you have reviews if you have
videos if you have images if you have
ratings all these things can be added to
the serps just by communicating with the
search engines vs Rich Snippets tip 5
optimize your site structure we want to
make sure that you know you have good
inbound links you want to make sure you
incorporate breadcrumbs you want to make
sure users can navigate your site more
easily and then in tip number six if
your pages load fast then it's going to
enhance the user experience it's going
to increase user engagement and increase
conversions and then tip number seven we
want to build quality link quality to
increase the domain Authority so
remember we can use mods to measure
domain Authority it's all about quality
whether that be via influencer marketing
guest blogging directories social media
setting up a social media page there's
always something you could be doing to
generate a quality link to your website
today we're going to talk about keyword
research so what are we going to talk
about when we talk about keyword
research we're going to talk about why
we would do keyword research for SEO
we're going to talk about the types of
keywords that we need to research we're
going to talk about some methodologies
best practices on how to do keyword
research some alternate suggestions
we're going to talk about keyword
clustering and then we're going to talk
about some tools that you can use to do
your keyword research so let's start
with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipes step by step piece of
recipes with sausage homemade pizza
toppings pizza dough recipes thin crust
pizzas she's doing a lot of different
topics on pizza recipes well what Jesse
needs to do is understand what's going
to drive traffic to these blog posts if
she's writing about you know different
topics around pizza recipes so she's
Unsure how these blogs are going to
drive traffic so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keyword to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and shoes in the queue words to align
with your content so that's really the
idea why we would do keyword research
because some of the issues is with
keywords that are poorly chosen are they
could have slow search volume for
example you may choose a keyword that
just a lot of people aren't using to
search for or they can be highly
competitive so if you choose a keyword
that's very broad or popular it can be
very competitive and take you a long
time to be found for that keyword or you
could just make the mistake of choosing
a keyword that isn't aligned with your
content or you can choose keywords but
use them incorrectly with your content
so these are some of the issues that you
can encounter if you just go about
choosing keywords randomly without due
diligence without the proper research so
low search volume will lead to less
traffic High competition you may not
even rank at all okay if somebody finds
you for a keyword that's not relevant to
the topic they're just going to leave
the page and if you're not using the
right keywords and or if you are using
the right keywords and not using them
correctly in the content then your pages
may not even be found an organic search
so you really have to take care and
choosing the keywords to me that's the
most important step with SEO is keyword
research so we're going to talk about
the types of keyword research then so we
have short tail keywords and we have
long tail keywords so if you write a
blog post about pizza recipes well what
are you going to choose a short tail or
long tail so let's talk about short tail
keywords first so short tail keywords
are keywords that are usually three
keywords in a phrase or shorter in some
cases it may be two keywords in a phrase
or shorter so shortcut keywords usually
have high search volume which means
likely means higher competition but what
it also means it could be lower
conversions because short sale keywords
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short show keyword but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
short taking words may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with long
tail keywords chances are you're going
to have lower competition that's one of
the benefits but you're also going to
have lower search volume but with longer
tail keywords the keyword is probably
going to be more relevant with the
content you're writing about so
therefore the conversion rates likely
going to be higher so that's really the
difference between short-term keywords
and long tail keywords if you want to
look at simplistically short tail
keywords are Broad in nature it's going
to capture a lot of eyeballs but those
eyeballs may look at your content is not
relevant versus long tail K words that
may be very relevant but not as many
eyeballs on them so short tail keywords
the characteristics they're not as
specific usually they're less than three
words they have high search volume and
high competition so if you just choose
pizza recipes could take you a while to
rank for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the
keyword is Broad in nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail keyword that may
not be exactly what you're writing about
in your blog post so it may draw a lot
of traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long take word is
probably going to be greater because not
many other websites are trying to rank
for that same keyword and so the benefit
of that is if you have let's just say
homemade pizza recipes with mushrooms
that's a long tail key word but if
somebody's looking for that type of
pizza recipe then you know you're going
to track the right traffic and chances
are that traffic's going to engage or
convert based on the type of conversion
you have in place so example would be
homemade pizza dough recipes that'd be
another example more than thick keywords
in the phrase very specific we're
talking about homemade pizza dough
recipe so we're not talking about just
pizza recipes so it's a little bit more
specific in nature longer tail so these
keywords are used for targeted Pages
including blog posts if you're writing a
blog post specifically about pizza
recipes with homemade dough then this is
the key word you likely would want to
use versus just pizza recipes so let's
look at an example between a short tail
keyword and a long tail keyword and to
accentuate the differences we're going
to use Google's Keyword Planner tool so
Google's keyboard Planner tool is
located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click on
tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a key
the word over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
gonna click get results and what
Google's gonna do is it's going to show
us the volume of those keywords so for
pizza recipe we could see the average
monthly search volume is 33 100 for
pizza recipe so note that pizza recipe
and pizza recipes are closely related
keywords and so what Google does is they
consider that a close variance so
meaning if somebody ties a piece of
recipe then they're also in Google's
eyes looking for pizza recipes so it's a
close variance and so for the keyword
pizza recipe which is short tail we
could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received 33 100
queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here I
could see for this particular keyword
here the volume per month is 33 to 1000
and then I could see the actual volume
over the past 12 months and then for the
long tail keyword I can see homemade
pizza dough recipe again close variants
homemade pizza dough recipes I could see
over the past 12 months with the search
volume is for this on average it's 2400
but I could see here in December the
volume went up to 3 600 but for example
in May it was 1900. so it's gonna
fluctuate a bit over the past 12 months
but on average is about 2400. so shorter
tail a lot of more volume longer tail
not as much volume but nonetheless there
is volume here and so these are the
difference between a short tail and a
longer tail and so well Google's Keyword
Planner also does is allow us to get a
sense of what the competition it is and
so here I can see the competition is low
for both of these keywords fair enough
so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of Google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2400 search queries for that keyword now
whether you get all 2400 clicks for that
keyword remains to be seen chances are
you're not going to get all 2400 you're
going to get a Lion's Share of those
clicks but you're going to at least get
some volume on it so even the longer
take keywords have a lot of Promise
because there is some search volume here
for this keyword how to do a proper
keyword research so we looked at
Google's Keyword Planner tool and Google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose keywords based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search File volume search
volume is a good indicator of the
potential traffic we can obtain so again
for the key word homemade pizza dough
recipe we know that it averages 2400 a
month in search volume again we may not
get all 2400 but we're gonna get a line
share of that we also need to look at
competition and so Google's Keyword
Planner gives us a high medium or low in
terms of the competition but if you're
somebody who wants to get a better sense
of what the competition is and you
should because competition is a key
component in choosing keywords and so
what I want to do is get a sense of how
many people are actually optimizing for
that keyword so Google's Keyword Planner
tool is going to give me a low medium
high really what I want to do is get a
better sense of that numerically so what
I can do is go into Google search and I
can type in pizza recipes and I could
see there's about 1 billion results
that's a lot of results however that
means that every potential web page out
there on the internet that mentions
pizza recipes is going to be included in
this number here and so I want to get a
better sense of who's optimizing for
pizza recipes so I'm going to put in the
all entitle syntax and so what that is
going to ask Google to do is tell me all
the websites that have pizza recipes the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
so if I do all entitled colon space then
pizza recipes my result drops down to
336 000. so what that tells me is that
there are 336
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if I want
to focus in on my other keyword if I
choose my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if I type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variants and I just click
enter or type the keyword in hit my
enter key I'm going to get 35 Million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition I
have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2160 different results so here I can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites or web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 000 so I'm going to
type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition in but
my competition was I typed that keyword
back in
2160. so I'm going to put two thousand
one hundred and sixty so now I have an
idea of what kind of volume and what
kind of competition I have now you want
to do this for a number of different
keywords and when you do it for a number
of keywords what you do want to do is
obviously choose a relevant keyword that
has high volume and low competition so
another way of saying it is the volume
or ratio of volume to competition and so
basically what we could do is take
volume divided by competition if I make
that a percentage I can see it's 0.35
percent is the ratio between volume and
competition if I do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
I can see that 111 so this just kind of
proves the point that yeah I'm still
going to get some volume but I have a
better chance of ranking for this longer
tier keyword homemade pizza dough
recipes so you want to be able to do
that for number keywords and examine the
volume the competition and the ratio
between volume and competition for your
themed keywords in this case pizza
recipes so relevancy you want to choose
keywords that are very relevant to the
content that you're writing and then
again commercial intent what keywords
are going to drive more conversions and
revenue for the business so when we talk
about commercial intent we're talking
about you know are you choosing keywords
that are going to get somebody to do
what you want them to do so we could say
You Know download pizza dough recipes so
somebody's typing in the keyword
download pizza dough recipes then
chances are they're going to find you
come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
Google's Keyword Planner tool in the
Google ads platform we want to Target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the Google's Keyword Planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we can get
a sense of any particular Trend going on
or season out so for example if I saw a
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
graphs that you know the Keyword Planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny Halloween costumes well we know
that for Halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
September number all the way through
October and then it's going to drop
after October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a key word that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitled
syntax find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a key
word that is going to be relevant to
your content don't choose a keyword
that's not relevant if you choose a
keyword that's not relevant it's not
going to bode well for user engagement
so the difficulty of a keyword ranges
from 0 to 100 and Google's keyword tool
so it's going to be easy it's going to
be medium it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again Trump's volume
and competition so always choose
relevant keywords first so when you do
that you're always almost guaranteeing
that at some point somebody's going to
find your content because somebody out
there might be looking for it and if
they do you're going to get found and
then the engagement is going to be
better so understand your business find
keywords that are relevant to your
business and then focus on those
keywords that'll help you with getting
the right traffic to your site always
keep in mind the commercial intent so
these keywords are more specific and
result in conversion rate for example
buying is a good commercial intent
keyword so if you really want somebody
to come to your website and buy then
focus on those types of keywords in the
case of the pizza recipes maybe it's
download could be our commercial intent
keyword again there may be low search
volume but those are the the type of
keywords you want to focus on because
that's the type of traffic you want to
drive to your site so some other
examples a commercial intent keywords or
discount deal your coupon shipping you
don't don't be afraid to use some of
these keywords as part of your longer
till keyword phrase again the volume may
not be high but the traffic quality is
probably going to be better so keyword
research is the foundation for SEO so if
you have chosen your keywords properly
then if you do get ranked for those
keywords then it's going to lead to
better engagement with some conversions
and so when we talk about keywords we
also want to talk about our primary and
secondary keyword so every page should
have at least a primary keyword and then
a second carry keyword to work with so
primary keywords are really defining the
nature of your content the secondary
keywords are relevant to the primary
keyword so why do we choose a primary
and secondary keyword because you may
choose a keyword as a primary keyword
that is relevant to the content but may
not necessarily rank very high or have a
lot of volume that secondary keyword is
also relevant to the primary keyword but
also relevant to content and you may
rank for that secondary keyword so you
always want to go with two keywords
versus just one keyword you want to give
your yourself a chance to rank for at
least two different types of keywords of
relevant nature so for web page there
can be several secondary keywords but
only one primary keyword so your primary
keyword is always going to be relevant
to your content secondary keywords can
be relevant to the keyword but and you
may have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so for primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
the secondary keywords are also related
to content and play off the primary
keyword and so what we want to do is go
to cool Google's Keyword Planner tool
and get an idea of the volume for
healthy diet plan and then also the
volume and competition for some of these
secondary keywords like healthy diet for
weight loss healthy diet food low carb
diet healthy meal plans and diet plan
weight loss so if I go in to Google's
Keyword Planner and type those keywords
in I'm going to choose get results and
now here I could see healthy diet plan
keyword I'm focusing on is my primary
keyword has an average monthly search
volume of 9900 and then some of my
secondary keywords healthy diet foods
diet plan weight loss low carb diet you
know Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
that as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan to go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan nine thousand nine
hundred what's my competition so my
competition is seventy four thousand
seven hundred and that's going to give
me a ratio of volume to competition of
13 so that's what my content's about
that's a considered a short tail keyword
because it has a lot of competition and
so my ratio is 13 and what I want to do
is I want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key
release two keywords I want to be able
to find my primary keyword that's
relevant to my content and then I want
to be able to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also also related to
the content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again I'm how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keywords and LSI stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are LSI or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you focus in on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to Google search
for example if I type in healthy diet in
Google search all I need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and I can see
searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top Google's also given me
some other suggestions here so they're
saying low-fat diet veganism gluten-free
diet so there's lots of different
suggestions right in Google search bar
so all of these are LSI related keywords
so if you're optimizing a page for a
healthy diet then you could choose
low-fat diet as a secondary keyword you
can use gluten-free diet as a secondary
keyword it really depends on what the
content is but you always want to
support your content with as much LSI
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in Google search so it's
important because if you have a Blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or is snake so Google for
example uses LSI keywords to understand
what the page is specifically focusing
on so if you're just focusing on Python
and your content you want to support
that with LSI keywords and so that will
allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you can certainly
found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a key word I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what males are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these can be
keyword phrase that you can use so the
answers are right here in Google so Cora
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions in a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good eye it's a
good place for you to go to get some
ideas about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing quora so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're gonna probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna get some
responses to the the top big healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is
you're getting kind of an idea of what's
trending what people are talking about
and if you use tips for a healthy diet
habit for example and you optimize for
that well again that could turn around
and bode well for you because you could
be featured in Google as a featured
snippet at the top here you can also
turn around and use LSI related keywords
for healthy diet habits and you can
simply just look for those LSI keywords
right in Google remember at the bottom
or at the Top If you scroll down I could
see some related LSI keywords at the
bottom so writing Google as well you
could see in the Google search bar that
Google provides some LSI related
keywords to your query so if I go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes I
can see here Google's suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for man healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
LSI related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about LSI keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
can be found at the top of Google and
they can be found at the bottom you can
also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
they're being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on Quorum so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so Google
collects all the keyword query is that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start to type in
recipes I could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet Google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in Google itself I can see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes I can also get
the search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google is going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google is going to suggest okay maybe
you should choose healthy food or
healthy eating or how to lose weight so
those are allocyte related keywords that
Google provides in the keyword plan
which is built into the Google ads
platform another option for you is
Wikipedia so Wikipedia is a vast
platform of content so we could turn
Wikipedia into our own assets and use it
to our own Advantage by finding relevant
keywords in an easy fashion so with
Wikipedia we can identify a list of
keywords in The Meta description itself
we could choose keywords from the first
paragraph of Wikipedia that has many
relevant keywords or we could take a
look at keywords from the Wikipedia
content section so we can also see
additional Pages like the see also
section that gives relevant keywords
that you're looking for we can also look
at the references section as they
contain relevant keywords so go to
Wikipedia as an example and I type in
healthy diet into Wiki pedia here I can
get just in the first paragraph alone I
can see some additional keywords that I
might choose to use like micronutrients
I never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but Wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
I can look at categories like dietetics
and diets I can also look at the
references section so I can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further than
the first paragraph you go no further
than the see also section the references
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags in
the search so you can also do that as
well so if I type in healthy diet
Wikipedia and search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where people post
content and discuss a variety of topics
so that's what Reddit is so with the
help of subreddits and in the individual
can find relevant keywords with with
high search volume so in Reddit there's
an easy way to find out keywords they
have a keyword tool called keyword it so
the keyword it gives the average monthly
searches for a particular keyword so if
we type a Word in key Reddit and choose
keywords from the auto generator list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volumes so if we go to the keyword it
and Show an example of that for example
healthy food if I get keywords I can see
what keywords are relevant in the search
volume of that keyword so if I just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
Keyword Planner tool in Google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com type in your keyword click
get keywords and what it's going to do
is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to really take
advantage of the keywords that we're
optimizing for to gain higher ranking so
if we can cluster keywords together in a
theme and that theme of keywords is
relevant to a specific page of a website
then we have a better opportunity to
rank so in other words why do we have to
Target just one keyword when we can
Target many so keep in mind you know LSI
keywords we want to group a bunch of
keywords together that are similar for
Content so for example after some
keyword research you can thematically
group keywords into a core topic so for
example we can cluster these group of
keywords together like for example what
is SEO how does SEO work intro to SEO
what are the basics of SEO all of those
are related to the chord theme what is
SEO another cluster keywords for example
could be SEO techniques SEO best
practices tips and tricks website
optimization on-page SEO techniques Etc
so those are clusters of keywords okay
that we can group together in themes and
if we group keywords together in themes
we can apply that to a particular
content on our website so the whole idea
behind clustering keywords it's going to
provide more diversity more of an
opportunity for us to be found so that's
the whole idea behind clustering so some
additional steps remember stay up to
date on industry news to brainstorm your
ideas first and identify a list of
keywords like a thema keywords that you
can cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword SEO best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword pause
if I go to keyword the keyword Explorer
tool and Moz and just type in SEO best
practices what it's going to do is it's
going to give me some volume related to
that particular keyword but more
importantly what it's also going to do
is going to show me what pages are
already ranked for that particular
keyword so therefore I can get a sense
of who is already ranking for that
keyword so here I can see Moz
mozmedium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of what web pages are ranked for a
particular keyword or group of keywords
I want to rank for myself so if we look
at tools for keyword research look no
further than Moz that's the mods of the
tool I would just choose but you could
also use Google's Keyword Planner which
we used in the example so for example if
I go back to the Google ads Keyword
Planner if you're in Google ads you
click on tools you click on Cleveland
planner and what Keyword Planner does is
it provides you for a particular keyword
the average monthly search volume of the
past 12 months it provides you
information on seasonality so if I hover
my mouse over a graph I'm going to be
able to see the volume per month over
the last 12 months what the keyboard
planner also does is it provides me some
additional ideas for my particular
keyword and in addition to that it's
going to provide me some sense of how
competitive that keyword is by telling
me whether it's low medium or high in
terms of competition so there's sem Raj
there's also other additional keywords
tools out there like word stream or href
or the Reddit tool keyword it and then
Moz is is another tool I particularly
use so if I go to Moz again here I can
just type in a keyword that I'm
interested in it's going to give me the
search volume of that keyword it's going
to give me the level of difficulty so 50
out of 100 so it's halfway between
difficulty and easy and then it's going
to give me some additional metrics like
for example what my expected organic
click-through rate would be if I were to
rank for this keyword but more
importantly what I like about this is we
could see exactly what other sites are
linked to this particular keyword we're
interested in so here I can look at the
top 10 list so this is mazusky word
Explorer tool so that's what this tool
is and it's part of moz.com so there's a
lot of tools at your disposal I
particularly use Moz I particularly use
Google's Keyword Planner and those are
the tools I use but there are lots of
tools out there let's go with the
scenario that you have a friend named
Sam and he has a website where he sells
shoes but Sam doesn't understand
why his website's not ranking number one
on Google and so typically the ranked
number one on Google there are some
factors involved and those are factors
that are going to help Sam get his
website ranked number one on Google so
he can sell his shoes get traffic and
convert that traffic to conversions so
there are factors involved and so what
are those factors well it always starts
with keyword research so in order to
rank for a website where you sell shoes
or you sell products other products like
clothing or food or you're at automobile
website you know you're a mechanic it
doesn't matter whether you're selling to
customers or selling to other businesses
you have to start with the keyword
research and so we're going to go into
really explicit detail on how to conduct
a proper keyword research and then the
second factor involved is high quality
content so in order to rank high on
Google search you need to have high
quality content so we're going to go
over what's involved with creating high
quality content then we're going to take
that content we're going to opt the
optimize it using on page elements and
website level factors so we're going to
take into account what's involved with
your website and what's involved with
specific pages on your website in order
to rank number one on Google then we're
going to get into the off-site
engagement so when it comes to ranking
on Google you need to optimize your
website and you need to do some elements
off your website you need to be engaging
off your website meaning on other
websites and so we're going to talk
about what's involved with offsite
engagement so SEO being a major channel
for most companies and websites where
the opportunity to drive a lot of
traffic is there but you have to earn
that reward the reward is a lot of
traffic but you have to earn the reward
there's a lot of work involved and so
ideally what we want to do is follow
what we call the 80 20 rule when it
comes to search engine optimization and
ranking on Google and what do we mean by
the 80 20 rule well 80 20 means we're
investing 20 of our effort and 80
percent of the results are obtained so
we want to invest 20 and get back 80.
that's basically what we mean by 80 20.
so for example if 20 of our targeted
keywords bring in 80 of the traffic then
that's following the 80 20 rule or 20 of
our landing pages Drive 80 percent of
the overall traffic that's following the
80 20 rule or 20 percent of our
backlinks pass 80 percent of our link
choose that's the 80 20 rule meaning
these targeted keywords these targeted
landing pages these trying to Target
backlinks using off-site engagement we
want to put in 20 percent of our effort
on those keywords landing pages and
backlinks in return for 80 percent of
the results so without further Ado let's
get started with the keyword research
let's talk about that keyword research
search for a website with shoes and it
doesn't really matter what particular
product you have if you need to rank
number one on Google it all starts with
the keywords as I mentioned before and
so in this example if you have a website
where you sell shoes for kids you're
going to want to be found for certain
keywords so the obvious keyword here
would be shoes for kids well every
keyword that you target has search
volume associated with it so that means
when we talk about search volume we're
talking about how many people on average
type in that keyword or related keyword
on google.com or Google search and
there's always an average number of
searches associated with every keyword
and we call that search volume how much
search volume so obviously if we're
going to Target a keyword we want to
have as much volume as possible however
there's always going to be competition
for those key words meaning there's
always going to be other websites who
want to rank number one on Google for
the same keywords and we call that
competition or difficulty so for every
keyword you're going to have volume and
you're going to have competition or
difficulty and the difficulty ranges as
well depending on the tool you use and
we'll get into that in a minute but
search volume is how much on average
people are typing in that keyword or
close variance of that keyword and the
difficulty is measured in terms of how
many other websites are trying to rank
for the same keyword and so ideally when
it comes to keyword research we want to
find that nice balance we want high
volume and we want low competition but
at the same time we want to focus on
keywords that are highly relevant to our
business so if we're selling shoes for
kids and shoes for kids is highly
relevant has high volume and low
competition then that's a keyword we
want to Target so we always want to
focus in on those three areas so there's
always a trade-off with keywords so
shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to Target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
Google for that keyword and so the whole
idea be on keyword research is analyzing
and choosing the best keywords so we
want to identify a list of keywords that
are always relevant we want to choose
the keyword that your competitors are
ranking for and we want to use
third-party tools to choose keywords to
identify which keywords have low
competition and what keywords have high
search volume so one thing to take into
consideration when you're doing keyword
research is that the longer the key word
phrase or in other words long tail
keywords or keywords with three keywords
in the phrase or more you're going to
always have less competition but there's
always a trade-off with long tail
keywords meaning the longer the keyword
phrase there's going to be less volume
but the trade-off is less competition
and so what we want to do is we want to
brainstorm some ideas and find those
relevant keywords so let's look at an
example here so if we go to Google ads
so Google ads has a total Keyword
Planner and let's just say I have a a
website where where I'm selling dried
figs and if I'm selling dried figs I
want people to buy these dried figs
however in order to attract them I want
to be able to show them that hey we have
a bunch of recipes and if I show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to use in these recipes and so we're
going to look for keywords related to
bread recipes because if we can optimize
for our recipes page for bread then that
will attract an audience who wants to
make bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example I'm
going to give here and so if I look at
the Keyword Planner and Google ads if I
just type in bread recipes what Google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so I
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60 500. and so in order
to do keyword research what I would
recommend is keep a spray spreadsheet
and so the idea behind the spreadsheet
is to document the volume and the
competition you're getting for certain
keywords so if I go into a spreadsheet
here my theme of keywords is bread
recipes my keyword is bread recipes and
my volume therefore is going to be sixty
thousand five hundred however if I go
back into Google's Keyword Planner
Google's telling me the competition is
low so that's great I want high volume I
want low competition but how low is low
so we want to be careful so if we're
going to put in numbers into a
spreadsheet we want to figure out what
that competition really is for the
keyword bread recipes so if I go to
Google and just type in bread recipes
I'm going to be able to see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now with 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want want to do is put in a syntax and
we want to put in the syntax all in
title and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites or trying to
rank for bread recipes and if we put in
the syntax all entitled colon and then
our keyword bread recipes we'll be able
to see that there are 998
000 results that's a lot lower than 771
billion so that means that 998
000 sites or listings have the keyword
bread recipes in the title tag and the
title tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if I look down and
scroll down here I can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one Google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that there are 998 000
results with bread recipes in the title
tag then this tells us that those are
the websites who are trying to rank
number one on Google for that keyword
and therefore those are the websites we
need to jump over in order for our
website to rank number one on Google and
so therefore I'm going to put in 998
000 in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now I could see for the
keyword bread recipes I have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my Kei
or keyword Effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition is six percent so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my Kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is six percent so remember we want more
volume than we want competition so
anytime you do a keyword research you're
going to find a number of different
relevant keywords so if I go back into
Google's Keyword Planner if I typed in
bread recipes you could see that Google
is going to give me a number of
different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say I have another
keyword that I want to think about
optimizing for being ranked on Google
for and that's banana bread recipe very
similar keyword has bread recipes except
it's a little longer tail now if I type
in banana bread recipe and Google's
Keyword Planner now I can see the
average monthly search volume has
actually gone up it's 368
000. I can also see the competition is
low so those are good signs so now I can
see 368
000 I'm going to go ahead and put that
in my spreadsheet now I'm gonna go into
Google I'm gonna put in my syntax on
title I'm going to put in banana bread
recipe I'm going to hit enter and now I
can see I have 233
000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe in the title tag so if I
look at the title tags I can see banana
bread recipe banana bread recipe banana
bread recipe on all the listings in the
Google search results so that tells me I
have 233
000 results that I have to jump over in
order to rank number one on Google so
I'm going to put 233
000 in my spreadsheet now I can see my
Kei or my volume to competition ratio is
157 158 percent and so to me that's a
lot better number to work with or in
other words that's a lot better keyword
because it's just as relevant and it has
a higher ratio of volume to competition
so therefore banana bread recipe is is
going to be a better keyword to optimize
for in order to rank number one on
Google so that's the whole idea behind
keyword research you want to brainstorm
ideas there are plenty of tools out
there so the tool I recommend is Google
ads Keyword Planner Google's going to
give you how much search volume they're
going to tell you the competition but
then you're going to go into Google
search you're going to use the syntax on
title to get a more accurate read on the
actual competitive number and so to find
out how keywords that your competitors
are ranking for you can use those
keyword tools that I mentioned another
tool that I use is Miles so Moz if you
go to moz.com they have a tool called
keyword Explorer so if we just type in
the keyword for example bread recipes
it's going to be able to tell us how
much volume and the difficulty so you
can use other tools that you're just
disposal figure out the volume and the
difficulty there are plenty of tools out
there but the one thing I would just
make sure is you use everything at your
disposal so you can use social media to
find the most shared article for a
particular topic or keyword like bread
recipes you can check other platforms
that have a lot of shared content like
Reddit and quora where you can ask
people about certain topics using
keywords to figure out how much
competition or volume there might be you
could stay up to date on industry news
to get an idea of what types of keywords
are trending but when it comes to
keywords and keyword research remember
for every web page we want to be able to
pick two keywords we want a primary and
secondary keyword so when we do keyword
research and we enter all our keywords
into our spreadsheet we want to be able
to have a number of different keywords
in this case we're focusing on the theme
bread recipes we want to have different
keywords because we want to be able to
choose a primary keyword and a secondary
keyword because we want to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket meaning we
won't want to put all our emphasis just
on one keyword to rank for we want
multiple keywords to try and rank for so
the primary key work and to find the
nature of our business the secondary
keyword could be just highly relevant to
our keyword at the end of the day we
want to choose multiple keywords to try
and rank on Google for that page so for
example we have a Blog and we're using
ice cream recipes and we're blogging
about ice cream recipes we can have the
primary keyword that is about ice cream
recipes or homemade ice cream recipes
we're going to always want to find out
what the volume and the competition is
our secondary keyword could be built
around around other similar keywords
like low-fat ice cream recipes or fat
free ice cream recipes or low-fat
homemade ice cream recipes those are
complementary keywords just like our
bread recipes and banana bread recipe so
one thing we want to do when we do
keyword research is we want to be able
to Target one keyword per content when
you can Target many we want to be able
to Target multiple keywords not
necessarily Target one keyword and so we
want to be able to Cluster keywords so
we don't want to Target just one we want
to Target multiple keywords per page and
when we talk about clustering if we go
back to our keyword research what we're
doing is we're clustering a bunch of
keywords under the theme bread recipes
and so by looking at the volume looking
at the competition looking at the Kei we
can choose different keywords for our
page and that's what we mean by
clustering we want to cluster keywords
into a Content frame so why Target only
one keyword per content when we can
Target many because we don't want to put
all our eggs in one basket we don't want
to Target just one keyword we want to
Target many and so that means clustering
your keywords into a theme and choosing
multiple keywords for that particular
page and when we do that we have a
better opportunity to rank high on
Google Search and the whole idea behind
ranking high on Google Search is we can
get the volume so if we know we're
ranked number one on Google search for
bread recipes or banana bread recipe we
know we stand a chance of getting a
majority of the volume associated with
that keyword and if we can get the
volume and get the traffic then we can
get the conversions so let's move on to
high quality content and talk about the
impact content has on your ability to
get your website ranked number one on
Google so let's just say you have
content on your website and the content
is ranking on you know page four of
Google and it's that blog with ice cream
recipes and if it's just content for the
sake of content it's not really
informative then it's not necessarily
going to get good engagement in the eyes
of Google you know they want to rank
content that's very informative it's
very fresh it's exciting to read it's
interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just non-informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
if people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce then the content
is just going to continue to fall down
the rankings and we want to prevent that
we want to move up up the rankings we
want to be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver and being able to rank number one
on Google so if the content is on page
nine what can we do well we want to be
able to you know take that content and
do something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like Facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that Community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summertime and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search
engines hey this content is good quality
likewise for any other platform most
social media platforms have engagement
metrics and those engagement metrics
pass signals is it good is it not good
do we like this content are we giving it
a thumbs up are we going to want to
follow it are we going to want to share
it and so if you share content that you
feel is engaging on social platforms
then it's going to be engaging and it's
likely going to cause an increase in
engagement for example a decrease in
bounces and once you share that quality
content then the likelihood of it moving
up the rankings even as far as number
one on Google is going to be greater so
you always want to start out writing
good quality content so let's talk about
good quality content because Google does
take content seriously they do take into
account what other people think of that
content so high quality content is an
important factor so how to create good
content that's always the question so
let's talk about some best practices
here remember in the last segment we
talked about keyword research so we want
to perform good keyword research why
because we want to choose keywords
remember we're choosing multiple
keywords per page one keyword could be
related to our brand one keyword could
be related to the content but another
keyword could be related to a user's
intent like recipes if you recall the
example we use with bread recipes maybe
somebody's looking to type in a keyword
that says how do I make you know a bread
or how do I make a specific type of
bread or how do I make banana bread or
what's the best recipe for banana bread
they're question related and we want to
be able to answer those questions so
that's where choosing those right
keywords that's going to respond to a
user's intent so starts with choosing
the right keywords so remember we talked
about a number for different tools when
we talked about keyword research so
there's a research tool that you can use
called phrase.io and that will help you
do quick research on you know keywords
and Trends and whatnot so if you know a
better research tool that you use for
keyword research then drop us a comment
below I'd be interested in getting your
comments about keyword research and what
research tools are out there so if you
know something better than phrase.io
drop a comment below and we'd be
interested in getting your perspective
so keyword research is key but creating
content that fulfills users requirements
so answering those questions it's a
recipe we want to answer that question
if it's directions we want to answer
that question if they don't know how to
do something we want to answer that
question then that's the whole idea
behind content content is not just a
fill a page it's to really fulfill users
requirements that's when you get good
engagement so if somebody's typing in
something on Google and they're looking
for an answer your content should answer
that question but we also want to make
the content readable so in other words
you know write for your audience don't
impress anybody with very high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use jargon don't use a street
language for example use everyday common
language that's just easily digestible
when your audience is reading and then
we want to keep that content organized
and so when we mean organized we want to
use headers and subheaders you know
break your content into paragraphs keep
the flow organized if we can keep the
flow organized then it's going to be
easier for somebody to read and then
it's okay to add resources especially
resources from credible sites so if you
can incorporate those resources in there
then it's just going to add The
credibility to your content let the
audience know that hey I've done my
research on this topic and this is is
what this person has to say about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content so these are all tips to
Remember When creating content and then
the one important tip here is we want to
use white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
wide hacked techniques that's what we
mean write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so there are
different types of content so there's
content where you just write words to
install text based you could also use an
infographic infographic is simply just a
graphic that visualizes exactly what
you're trying to explain for example if
we want to write an article about how to
write good engaging content we don't
necessarily have to write all that out
as a text we can create an infographic
so for example here's an infographic on
20 effective ways to basically not bore
your readers but write engaging content
so you could see this is an infographic
it's all graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be easier to
understand because they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the points of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic has 20 different steps
or rules and they lay those out all here
in this infographic and the great thing
I like about infographics is you could
you could share them on social media you
can re-engage them as a post you can
save them from really any social
platform so infographics tend to tell a
better story and versus say just writing
text you can use video and images so you
don't necessarily have to lay it all out
in an infographic you can certainly
insert a video or an image into your
content especially if it's a blog post
if it's a blog post then sometimes video
and image is on its own tell the story
you don't necessarily need text to go
ahead and tell your story a video or an
image as they say tells a thousand words
and so images and videos are great to
use in a blog post so using different
forms of content you know you always
want to review your content when a user
dwells on your web page for a longer
time Google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorable so if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
HubSpot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again there's best practices we just
went over but the key is you know if you
have longer more engaging content then
it's going to bode better for you on
search engines so a couple of steps to
create high quality content so you want
to begin with a comprehensive
introduction so always introduce your
content remember the content should be
relevant to the keywords so if you're
choosing keywords and your keyword
research think about answering that
question if somebody's typing in bread
recipes maybe they're looking for banana
bread recipes how to make the best
banana bread or how to make banana bread
using dried figs we want to be able to
align our content with that keyword
naturally you want to create a title
that's worthy that's click worthy so
remember if you're in Google search and
you're doing search for something simple
like bread recipes we want to make
something that's going to be you know
engaging for somebody to click on like
easy perfect yeast bread or easy crusty
French bread or something that's going
to be engaging you know the best bread
recipes or how to make the best homemade
bread you know something that's going to
draw somebody's attention to the title
of that blog post so we want to include
LSI keywords so what I mean by LSI
keywords in your content we mean you
know long tail keywords make it natural
headings and subheadings should consist
of keywords and variants so if you're
writing headers and subheaders include
the keyword in there and that way the
content always stays relevant to the
audience okay shorten your sentences in
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easier for
the end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
web website we want to make sure that
it's relevant content that way
somebody's reading something and you
have an internal link let's just say
from a bread recipes page to a banana
bread recipes page then they may find it
interesting click on that link and go to
the banana bread recipes page so it's
keeping somebody engaged on your website
so putting in internal linking will help
keep the end user engaged because you're
offering up links that's relevant to the
content you always want to break up that
content with images okay we want to use
alt tags meaning we want to pan the
image with text so that way if the image
doesn't load then at least the alt text
will load so we can incorporate call out
boxes and more importantly we want to
update our content regularly so we
always want to get the best recipe out
there if it's banana bread or different
ways to Crepe banana or always just
coming up with ways to update the
content so we want to keep our content
our blog post fresh and then we want to
include a CTA call to action if we
include a call to action then that's
going to keep somebody engaged and have
them act on your content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three-month-old post on
BuzzFeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012. again a lot of
Engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we could see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
contents updated regularly it's engaging
and it includes sources from high
Authority websites some do's and don'ts
on the content so take into account the
best practices I mentioned about
creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content I.E in the form of infograph
Graphics or videos or text or images you
can add images from public domain sites
you can be relatable and use examples to
clarify points just like the BuzzFeed
article simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some Do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com
creditxyz.com for the image and even put
a link back but ideally you don't want
to take images from other websites just
as much as you don't want to take copy
you don't want to take images use your
own imagery and content but if you don't
have imagery then you can always go to
stock photography there are plenty of
websites out there where you can sign up
for a subscription like Adobe stock
images as an example you can sign up for
an account and in some cases you can
sign up for a free account and use stock
imagery okay don't give less information
to your audience give them to your
audience what they deserve which is the
information they're looking for they're
looking for the best banana bread
recipes give them the best banana bread
recipes incorporate your own images
break it up with titles give them a good
quality piece of content that they're
going to be able to engage with and so
if you put long paragraphs in your
content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long pair
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about high quality content in order to
get your pages ranked high on Google
search let's turn our attention to
optimizing on-page elements and discuss
some website level factors that are both
going to help you rank high on Google
search so let's just do an overview of
what we're talking about when we talk
about on-page elements and website level
factors so optimizing on page elements
include a number of different things but
primarily we're going to focus in on
meta tags also known as meta description
tags header tags also known as title
tags and URLs so those are just some of
the on-page elements we want to be be
able to optimize using relevant keywords
in order to rank on Google search we
also want to take a look at some website
factors that will affect our ranking on
Google search they include website
architecture having a secure website
having a site map and taking a look at
page speed so all of those are some of
the website factors we need to take into
account in order to rank high on Google
search so title tag and meta description
together are considered meta tags so
both play an important role in ranking
high on Google so we want to be able to
write unique title and descriptions for
each page on our website when I say
unique that means a title In The Meta
description need to be different for
every page on the website and so if
you're not quite sure what a title tag
in a meta description tag is if you go
to search and just type in any
particular search query the title tag is
what's going to show up here and bold
and then the description is going to
show up below it below the URL and
that's going to describe the page so
both of these meta tags are important
because it describes what your page is
all about and that's what Google uses in
the search results pages so we want to
be able to pay attention to the length
of our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results Pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's going to happen is
the meta description tag or the title
tag will get trunk at it and so if we
look here for example we could see all
of the title tags here fit the 65
character limit but if you run over the
character count on meta description and
then Google is going to truncate the
copy so you want to stay within your
parameters in order to avoid getting
your content truncated and so the other
thing when we're writing title meta
description tags we want to minimize
keyword repetition so if we're
optimizing for keyword we don't want to
necessarily just plug that keyword into
the title tag and meta description
multiple times we want to make sure our
title tags and meta descriptions are
naturally written so if somebody's
typing for banana bread recipe with
dried figs you know we want to have a
nice title tag and a description that is
going to get somebody to respond based
on their need and so we definitely want
to avoid keyword repetition but we want
to be able to use that keyword in the
title tag because if you remember from
the earlier segment when we did the all
in title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
they want to use that keyword in the
title tag because again the title tag is
an important factor when it comes to
search engine results so we want to use
the keyword but we want to avoid
stuffing or using it repetitively in our
title tag and our meta description we
want the title tag and The Meta
description to describe the page sound
natural but also be engaging because the
point is we want people to click on our
link and go to our website from search
engines so title tags with numbers tend
to result in higher click the rates this
is according to mods so for example if
you just put in a title tag that says
learn digital marketing well that may
work but if you put a number in there
like five easy ways to learn digital
marketing that might get somebody to
click on your link and go to your
website so having questions in your meta
tags can also increase your
click-through rate for example if you
just put learn the import importance of
first page rankings not too bad but
again generic but if you put it into the
formal question how to rank number one
on Google it's more action oriented it's
gonna get somebody to resonate with the
question that they have and that may be
their query how to rank number one on
Google and so these techniques will help
you get higher click-through rates and
so according to backlinko title tag with
a keyword can improve site ranking so
remember we want to include that keyword
in the title tag even though we only
have 65 characters we want to include
that keyword but we want to avoid
stuffing the keyword in there we want to
again make the title tag action oriented
maybe with the number maybe as a
question with the keyword in there once
naturally not easy to do but that's the
beauty of SEO if you can follow these
best practices and write a good title
tag then the chances of of you improving
in your search results are going to be
greater so having only one H1 tag in
your post is going to be good so
remember when somebody clicks on a link
so let's say they do find a title tag
engaging and they click on this this
link here and they go to that website
you know you want to start out with
having that particular H1 Tech because
the H1 tag especially with the keyword
in it is going to signal to Google hey
we're organizing our page and because
it's an H1 tag it's important we're
structuring the page according to best
practices so having only one H1 tag in
your post is definitely helpful having
multiple tags H tags in your post help
organize the page a lot better so we
want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your header tag should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dry figs
with banana breads well the title says
California fig banana bread and remember
the last segment when we're talking
about high quality content well look no
further than including a video into our
content so not only will this video help
keep the engagement high but it breaks
up the monotony of the page and it's
from a third-party source so it adds
credibility to the page so adding a
video based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on Google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those H tags in there H2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of H1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same H1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those H1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember
all white hat techniques we want to
avoid hidden tags we want to avoid
stuffing keywords we want things to be
natural we don't want things to be
forced and your H1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long H1 tags if
we go back to our page example a short
sweet tag here California fig banana
bread it's relevant to the content it's
short sweet it breaks up the monotony of
the content and more importantly and
again any content you have on the page
should always answer the user's intent
remember people are using search to
answer questions find information our
content should be able to answer that
for them so according to John Moeller
senior webmaster Trends Analyst at
Google header tags would definitely help
Google for rankings in the search
results so we want to use header tags so
when it comes to URLs we want to use
hyphens and avoid underscores so if we
look at this URL here this uses hyphens
fig and banana bread so it's all broken
up with hyphens that's a best practice
remember canonical URLs a canonical URL
signals to Google this is the original
content so we want to use original
content and if you have multiple sources
of content out there on say different
websites we want to use a canonical tag
to signal to Google this is the original
content please Index this content and
not doesn't hurt to use a favicon URL
meaning a small icon and helps to break
up the monotony and help your URL stand
out we can add targeted keywords in the
URL so again looking at the URL here I
can see we're using targeted keyword as
part of the URL structure Fagan banana
bread and notice the H1 tag is fake
banana bread so it's all consistent and
it flows naturally you URLs that are no
longer existing then we want to be able
to set up a redirect for those URLs
meaning a 301 redirect is a server
response for Google that says Hey Google
this page is no longer available but it
we permanently redirected it to this
page which is now available so that's
what a 301 redirect does it helps signal
to Google and all the other search
engines that if the page is no longer
there that's fine you're just going to
go to this page this is the page that's
permanently there now and another thing
we want to do here is if you have mobile
URLs you want to include those in the
sitemap and we're going to hit on that
in just a minute but all urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account this
best practices keep your URLs short use
high fins put the keyword in that URL
and make it easy to understand want to
avoid capital letters in the URLs the
URLs are case sensitive so go lowercase
you should always go lowercase from the
URL readable URLs again the rule of
thumb here is if you understand what the
URL is then Google's going to understand
what the URL is so the shorter the URL
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on Google search so according
to backlink to URLs that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those URLs
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on-page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
rank high on Google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine Bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that Google's
going to be able to find all the pages
so so what do we mean by that create a
logical hierarchy structure so if you're
selling shoes you know you're going to
have a home page break the structure up
into men's shoes women's shoes
Children's Shoes then under men's shoes
you could have it by brand it could be
Nike Puma Adidas on the women's side it
could be Nike Puma Adidas on the child
side it could be Nike Puma Adidas and so
you want to keep the structure flow in a
hierarchy so we want to balance the
amount of subcategories within each
category so the men's if it has Nike
Puma Adidas the women should have Nike
Puma Adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and CSS or HTML meaning
we want to be able to use something that
Google is going to be able to index so
most sites are built in HTML and that's
what Google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their servers and then more
importantly build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking so
internal links mean that if you're on a
site you should have natural lengths
pointing to other pages on your website
so to keep the flow going we don't want
to have unnatural inbound things you
always want to have natural internal
links to keep the flow of the user going
from one page to the other so here I can
see as an example all the ingredients in
this recipe well this has an internal
link to another page on our site and
this happens to link to a page where
somebody can buy the ingredients so it's
a natural internal link so John Doherty
of Credo has claimed that one of the
biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the Credo website is architecture
so for example in Credo John Doherty has
increased the organic sessions by 74 in
Pages by per session by 41 just by
changing the site architecture so you'd
be surprised by changing the side
architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus nonsense
secure so what we mean by that is
securing your site we want to make it
sure that compliant with certain
protocols and so if we go back here we
can see that this particular site is
compliant it is secure https means it
has a secure license meaning the site is
secure so Google likes secure versus
non-secure so non-secure would be HTTP
so we want https as our protocol and
what that means is just enabling SSL
certificates and that means when you
enable an SSL certificate that means
your domain or your protocol is going to
be turned to https so Google prefers
sites that are secure versus non-secure
so if you use hsts as a protocol that
adds an extra layer of security over the
https and
hsts prevents cookie hijacking so adding
in multiple layers of security always
helps in my opinion if you have an HTTP
website a non-secure website you should
look into buying an SSL certificate
getting your sites flipped over to https
because what's going to happen is your
url structure is going to change when
your url structure changes Google is
going to recognize that because they're
going to index your site and when they
index your site they're going to see
those secure URLs and that's going to
work favorably in your favor and help
you rank higher on Google search so
websites using secure or https have a
higher chance of ranking higher so https
is a ranking signal because Google
indexes those pages so let's also talk
about site Maps so sitemap is one of the
most important ways to improve your
website ranking why well because
sitemaps are a way to organize all your
URLs into one file so we're basically
going to prioritize all our web pages in
a site map so if you go to any
particular website and you type in
sitemap.xml you're likely going to see
all the pages on your website so usually
the site map is located in the root
directory so if I type in sitemap.xml
I'm going to be able to see all the
pages in my root directory and I can
also prioritize them I can also alert
Google as to how often they change and
every page is going to have a date stamp
associated with it so Google can
actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently so content's not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then Google's gonna see that size that
date stamp that last modification down
so we want to be able to make sure
content is updated frequently we want to
let Google know that we change it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our Pages let Google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a site map we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
URLs in the site map so we want to be
able to add all our original URLs in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
Dynamic URLs site maps for larger
websites and what I mean by Dynamic URLs
that means that if I look at this side
map and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a Blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the sitemap
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see the
site map grow with more URLs when the
sitemap grows with more URLs then that
means then Google's going to index more
pages they're going to index more fresh
pages so they're going to be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
Dynamic sitemaps is we want to be able
to capture all the URLs just as they're
published and we want to be able to
maintain our site maps and so I would
always recommend a dynamic site map but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called XML
sitemap so if I just type in XML
sitemaps into Google search here I can
see XML sitemaps generator and I can be
able if I have a small website just
create a free and simple site map on my
own when XML sitemaps creates it or your
platform creates a dynamic sitemap
either way the site map is going to sit
in the root directory and then what we
want to do in turn is let Google know
where that sitemap is so in search
console we want to be able to submit the
sitemap so you're going to add the site
map you're going to let Google know
where it is it should be in the root
directory and it should be called
sitemap.xml and when you do that
Google's going to be able to take those
URLs and index them so we could see we
submitted 528 URLs Google index 521 so
one thing about URLs here is when we
create a site map we're putting all your
URLs in there we do not add no index
URLs in your site map when what that
means is that any URL we don't want
Google to index we're just going to
exclude from the sitemap okay so we want
Google to take all the URLs we want
indexed and put them in the sitemap so
according to edgy using sitemaps for SEO
can increase your website's visibility
and help you get indexed why because
what you're in fact doing is taking all
your URLs that you want indexed you're
telling Google how often they're
modified you're telling Google which
ones are important and you're submitting
that to Google and so Google's going to
be able to take all these URLs quicker
index them quicker and when they're
indexed quicker you can get ranked
quicker and when you get ranked quicker
you can get traffic quicker so that's
the whole idea behind sitemaps so let's
turn our attention to page speed now so
when the last factors for our website
besides architecture making it secure
and adding sitemaps is we want to take a
look at how quick our Pages load here
are some tips in order to optimize page
speed because ideally the quicker a page
loads the more engaged the user is going
to be if it takes a longer time for the
page to load all the elements of that
page then what's going to happen is the
user is going to get impatient maybe
leave the website all together or go to
another page and so we want to be able
to optimize images so any image that's
of large size in terms of megabytes we
want to be able to optimize that
compress the image so that's one way to
speed up page speed we want to use a
simple website design you know HTML with
CSS or cascading style sheets just a
simple design with simple a hierarchy
and website navigation structure so
nothing fancy nothing complex just a
simple website design with optimized
images we want to leverage browser
caching and we want to upgrade the
server response time meaning all your
files are sitting on the server so when
somebody it goes to web page the server
is serving up all of those files the
images the text Etc and so we want the
server to respond as quick as possible
so when it comes to page speed we can
look at the factors affecting page speed
and Google analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I go under behavior
and I go under site speed and I go to
overview I'm going to be able to see
what my average load time is for my site
and ideally we want our pages to load as
quick as possible so that means anything
under four seconds anything four seconds
or higher and it's likely the end user
is going to leave the page there's a
correlation BP between page load time
and bounce rate and so what Google
actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions in Google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then Google's
going to be able to tell us hey okay
this particular page load fast this
potato page loads slow and if it loaded
slow why is it loading slow so here we
could see the home page of the example
is loaded on average of seven seconds
well if we look here they're going to
give us some suggestions so if I click
on this page speed suggestions it's
going to load a report and a tool called
page speed insights and basically what
it's then going to do after it's done
running is it's going to tell me all the
ways in which I can optimize my pages
not only for desktop but also for mobile
so here I can see for desktop or for
mobile I can look at some ways in which
I can optimize it to increase page speed
for example sizing my images properly
server response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirects so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page load time and all that's found in
page speed insights and all that's found
within Google analytics so remember
optimizing code minimizing redirects
optimizing your images upgrading your
server response and all of those are
factors and so again you can go into
analytics page speed insights and you
can see exactly what Google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
Google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank Pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today Walmart as an example
experience to decline in conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increased conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're going to stay on the site and if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase
and Page low is low time will make a
world of difference in terms of
Engagement and conversions let's turn
our attention to off-site engagement so
previously we talked about on-page
elements and website factors that are
fact our rankings for search results but
we also need to turn our attention away
from our website meaning what we do on
our website and turn our attention what
we can do for our website off our
website and onto other websites so
that's offside engagement and so let's
look get an example so that ice cream
recipes blog so we did everything we
possibly could we updated The Meta tags
the title tag The Meta description we
added H1 tags we've made sure the site
architecture was sound we submitted a
site map we we made sure the page load
was good and fast so we did all the
things we're supposed to do on our web
page but we're still not ranking well
what do we need to do well we need to
turn our attention away from our website
into other websites we call this off
site or off-page SEO and we need to
basically generate links from high
quality sites back to our site so if
we've done everything we can on our own
website and we're still not ranking
where we want to be well then we need to
turn our attention to other websites and
so if we turn our attention other
websites and other websites that are
relevant other websites that are of
quality uh other websites that have high
domain Authority then we're going to see
an increase in rankings so it's just a
matter of getting quality links from
quality websites that are relevant
that's what's going to move the needle
on search after we've taken care of all
the on-page elements so more backlinks
from high domain Authority results in
higher rankings SEO is a combination
between what we do on our website
meaning optimizing the page and making
sure our website has good site
architecture and follows the best
practices in terms of site maps and Page
load then we need to turn our attention
to the backlinking to improve our domain
Authority so according to backlinko
analysis off-site engagement is one of
the most important elements for ranking
number one in Google so you can't just
focus your attention on updating the
title tag and making sure the pages load
fast you have have to turn your
attention as well to getting back
lengths from high quality sites that's
off-site engagement and so gaining links
back links from multiple domains is
vital it's vital because they bring
referring traffic to your site they
bring credibility to your site but more
importantly Google is going to recognize
the relationship between these sites and
your website and if these sites that
have backlinks or links pointing to your
site and if they're of high quality then
we call that passing link shoes so it's
going to bring quality to you in terms
of organic search so if we look at an
example if I do a search for banana
bread recipe they're 241 billion results
for banana bread recipe Why did this
particular page from Simply Recipes
ranked number one well we can turn our
attention to Moz and Maz has a report
called link Explorer and so Moz link
Explorer report helps us identify our
own page Authority our own domain
Authority and how many links we have
from other quality websites so if I put
that particular URL into link Explorer
and notice the URL here is short even
though it uses an underscore when it
should use a hyphen it's still ranked
number one and why because off-page
elements help this page rank number one
why their page Authority out of 100 is
58 their domain Authority out of 100 is
82 and what does that mean well that
means that they have a lot of good links
from other domains of high quality they
have 824 linking domains to this one
domain they have 3600 inbound links and
they're ranking for a lot of different
keywords so if we scroll down we're
going to be able to see kind of a
breakout the quality of websites that
are linking to them so they have 19
domains with a domain authority of 91 to
100 linking to them they have 15 domains
between the range of 81 and 90. so what
does that tell me between 15 and 19
that's 34 particular domains that are
very high quality linking to it and so
we could see the breakout of the linking
domains we could see the top file links
to the site and we can see the page
Authority so the link Explorer report
gives us an overview of what pages are
linking to ours and it also gives us an
idea of what our own page Authority and
domain Authority are because domain
Authority and Page Authority both need
to be high in order for us to rank on
Google Search and in order for it to get
high we need links from high quality
sites so that's the whole idea behind
off-site engagement so some of the
offsite engagement prints are influencer
marketing meaning is there somebody out
there on social who has a huge following
but not only do they have a huge volume
but are they relevant to our product for
example Usain Bolt who's a famous
Sprinter if we're selling shoes and
we're selling Nike shoes maybe Usain
Bolt can reference us on Twitter or
Facebook that's influencer marketing
getting people to influencing people to
buy our product we can engage with
audiences on multiple social media
platforms like Facebook and Twitter
meaning if we're running a promotion on
those running shoes then we can promote
that on Facebook okay we can promote
that on Twitter we can also bookmark our
webpage on popular bookmarking sites
like StumbleUpon we can also put our
content on discussion forums like Reddit
we can join High PR quality q a sites
excuse me and post answers to questions
related to business like quora.com so we
can engage in sharing our content and
answering questions so there's lots of
ways to get links to your website if you
have a blog post as an example you can
make sure that maybe that content is
shared on a similar blog post so if you
have an ice cream recipe blog post well
maybe you can look at a dessert blog
post and share your content on that
particular blog post and have a back
link pointing from that blog post to
yours as an example and you can
reciprocate so the whole idea of content
is sharing the content but at the same
time of sharing it you're producing
backlinks and backlinks help domain
Authority so not only did I help domain
Authority but they improve the search
rankings so in Google's eyes the higher
your domain Authority higher the page
Authority in Google's eyes that means
your page is important it's credible
herbal and we're going to improve it in
the search engine rankings it increases
brand visibility if we have our content
on a highly engageable website a highly
popular website or blog it's not it's
going to lift our brand visibility if we
have Usain Bolt who's very famous
Sprinter do some influence in marketing
for us then that's going to increase our
brand visibility so anytime we can
associate with something that has some
influence or some clout or high domain
Authority then it's only going to
increase our brand awareness and
visibility so again it's going to
increase our domain Authority because of
the association of passing link juice
from one domain to another it's going to
then as a result increase referral
traffic because if we're on a high
quality website that gets a lot of
traffic then the chances of some of that
traffic going our site is going to be
great and again it improves The
credibility and Trust of our website and
that's what we want we want Google to
trust us and a way to build trust is is
by associating our website with other
websites of high equal or higher quality
so when we talk about off-site
engagement we want to do some guest post
on relevant websites so if you have that
ice cream blog go to another blog like
the dessert blog and do a guest post so
not only that will that improve your
brand awareness but it'll generate a
backlink and maybe drive some referral
traffic you can participate in forms and
blog discussions like core.com or Reddit
get your content out there start a
discussion about a specific topic to
engage users build brand awareness and
generate that backlink you can always
you know put your your site on a
directory like Yelp for example or Yahoo
directory you could prefer testimonial
link building meaning you serve products
or offer up a service well somebody
could provide a testimony on their
website or you can just earn back links
from relevant authoritative the web
pages like we mentioned quora or
Wikipedia or there's plenty out there so
the idea is to associate yourself with
high quality websites but do it
naturally you don't want to force
anything so if you're selling a specific
service or you're selling a specific
product look for like mining services or
products that complement what you do and
that'll create the natural environment
natural ecosystem that will eventually
give you the benefits that you need to
rank higher in the search results pages
so we don't want to purchase any links
we don't want to cloak content we don't
want to just inject links on sites that
aren't relevant we don't want to just
have site-wide links all over the place
pointed to the same page and we
certainly don't want to be on low
quality websites or directories it's all
about quality not quantity with off-site
engagement so having an offside
engagement complements what you do on
your website for on-site together both
of those efforts will get you higher
search engine results
so before we go into Google Keyword
Planner let's talk about keywords yeah
keywords we use them everywhere and they
shave as the foundation of nearly every
marketing campaign that we launch online
whether you're deploying Google ads
cleaning up content for SEO helping your
products to be found on Amazon
keywords are at the heart of how you
connect with your customers or your
ideal prospects so they are used for
pay-per-click and for SEO purposes
in the context of an SEO campaign a
keyword is a phrase a query that a
Searcher types into the browser to prove
to get a list of results examples of SEO
keywords could include words like
accounting software QuickBooks for
self-employed and workers or online
bookkeeping Solutions
now PPC keywords are used for your
advertising like Google ads your ad you
add a keywords to your Google ads setup
to help determine when and where your ad
should appear
yep so somebody types in a query Google
matches that query with ads that contain
that query yep and then with various
calculations it will show the ads that
best answers the query so a great
keyword list can help improve the
performance of your ads and help you to
avoid a high price to pay for your ads
poor keywords can ultimately cause you
to have higher price to pay for your ads
and lower at positions
so at the beginning of any SEO or PPC
campaign you should plan to invest time
to do your keyword research much of this
process can be automated and Google
Keyword Planner is a fantastic tool that
can help you with that but remember in
the end it's still humans who need to
look over the list to properly determine
the keyword relevance
so let's have a look at some of the
features of Google Keyword Planner and
what Google Keyword Planner actually is
so Google Keyword Planner is a tool that
helps advertisers find the right
keywords to Target for their Google ad
campaigns
yeah it helps you research the keywords
for your search campaigns and you can
also discover new keywords related to
your business you could identify your
competitors keywords and get ideas
around the keywords that your
competitors are using additionally
Google Keyword Planner will give you
volumes estimates of the searches that
those keywords receive and the cost you
would potentially pay when you use those
keywords in your advertising campaign
yeah so Google Keyword Planner allows
you to see how often certain keywords
are searched for on Google and it
provides data of the cost of running the
ads for those keywords so you get also
suggestions for related keywords is
great if you don't really know where to
start as far as finding keywords for
your ad so very important to know that
Google also provides the average cost
for your ads to show on searches for a
keyword so it's easier to pick and chose
choose which keywords best suit your
strategy and your budget
so Google keywords planner is a useful
tool for identifying the most effective
keywords to use in your ad campaign and
as I said before as well for estimating
the potential cost and reach of a
campaign
so knowing how frequently keywords in
your industry are searched for is
extremely important for your campaign
because you wouldn't want to Target
keywords that no one is using but you
also want to Target keywords that have a
ridiculously high search volume because
they tend to be more competitive and
when they are more competitive you will
have to pay a higher price to Target
those keywords so to summarize Google
Keyword Planner helps you discover new
Search keywords
it shows you average monthly search
numbers for those keywords it helps you
to determine the cost and it helps you
to create new search ad campaigns so all
in all a very powerful tool that you can
use for your Google ad campaigns which
is also completely integrated with
Google ads so the keyword list that you
create in Google Keyword Planner you can
then bring directly into your Google ads
campaign setup
so here are some important terms related
to Google Keyword Planner
so there is keywords of course keywords
now what is a keyword a keyword is a
word or a phrase that users type into a
search engine to find information on a
particular topic from an end user
perspective you could say it's a query
yeah and advertisers use those keywords
to Target their ads to users who are
searching for specific products or
services or have questions around
problems that they have now search
volume is the number of times a
particular keyword is search for on
Google over a certain period of time so
Keyword Planner provides you data on
search volume to help you understand how
popular certain keywords are match type
refers to the way in which a keyword
will trigger an ad Google offers several
different match types like broad match
phrase match and exact match it goes
from a exact match where Google will
actually only look at the exact word or
phrase that you specified as a keyword
compared to Broad match where it will
look at a much broader sort of range of
keywords in relation to the search term
that you defined in your Google ads
setup
an ad group is the container for your
keywords yeah it's a set of keywords
that are related to a specific theme or
topic so ad groups are used to organize
and structure your ad campaign and each
ad group can have its own sets of ads
and targeting options in relation to the
keywords that you specified keywords can
be negative as we say yeah so negative
keywords is a word or phrase that Google
will not show an ad for in when it comes
to certain search queries yes so it have
helped you to avoid wasting Impressions
on irrelevant surges and thereby it
improves the relevance of your ads so if
your keyword is accounting because
you're selling accounting software you
don't want people who search for
accounting jobs yet to see your ad
because they will not be interested in
buying your accounting software so you
can specify jobs as a negative keyword
as I said earlier Google Keyword Planner
will also give you traffic estimate
traffic estimates are estimates of the
potential reach and cost of an ad
campaign based on the selected keywords
and Keyword Planner provides those
traffic estimates to help you with your
budget setting and targeting options for
your campaigns there are important
metrics as well that are related to
Google Keyword Planner and therefore of
course also related to Google ads a cost
per click is the amount that you will
pay each time a user clicks on your ads
yeah that's why we call Google ads
pay-per-click advertising you're not
paying paying Yeah by default you're not
paying on when people see your ads you
will pay when people click on your ads
and of course what you want to know for
your campaign what is the average cost
per click
you also want to know what the
click-through rate for your campaign is
that is a ratio of the number of times
an ad was clicked in comparison to the
number of times it was shown and that
expressed as a percentage so two
important indicators cost per click and
click-through rate
finally there is a very important term
is what we call long tail keywords
yeah they are more specific keyword
phrases that visitors are more likely to
use when they're closer to a point of
purchase
yeah so a normal keyword can be dog food
and you see it has a very high search
volume which means the higher the search
volume the more likely you will pay a
higher cost per click because the
competition is very high for those
keywords
yes so what brands do what what do
companies do is actually they step away
from the intense competition on the
long-term keyword or the the short-term
keywords like dog food and they move to
longer term keywords like how to make
dog food at home
it gives you a lower search volume but
the chance that people will engage with
you on your ads is bigger because they
are closer to that point of purchase
okay so those are long tail keywords
right so let's have a look at some of
the Keyword Planner features
so to summarize yeah Google Keyword
Planner gives you search volume data for
keywords once you put a keyword in you
get that volume data but it will also
give you ideas for keyword yep and it
will actually automatically group those
ideas for you in potential ad groups
that you can use it will then give you
traffic estimates and you can say use
filters as well to make your keyword
list more specific right
so let's have a look at how Google
Keyword Planner works yeah and it's
important to understand that before you
can use Google Keyword Planner you will
need to have a Google ad account web and
unique can create that by going to
Google ad you will have to put in your
credit card or debit cards yeah but as
long as you're not publishing any
campaigns you won't get charged by
Google so there's no risk for you to
when you enter your credit card details
okay and then when you're in a house and
I'll show you in a minute where you can
find it then you just start entering
your keywords and then Google Keyword
Planner will do the rest for you
so let's have a look at how Google
Keyword Planner works first of all we
need to go to Google ads so let's type
in Google ads and I assume yeah or the
fact is you will need a um a Google ads
account to be able to access Google
Keyword Planner so when I sign into my
Google ads account I click here on the
account that I want to use for this demo
and this takes me to the Google ads
interface
so this is of course a different topic
to talk about Google ads which we will
do in other videos for now it is
important to find out where do I find
Google a Keyword Planner and how do I
access it so when you click here in the
top on tools and settings
you will hear see all the tools that you
have available for planning for your
shared library for bulk actions for
measurements setting up your Google ads
billing for your Google ads but here
under the planning you see Keyword
Planner and that takes you straight to
the Google Keyword Planner so here's the
interface so here you see
plans that you've created for keywords
yes so you can save your keywords into
ad groups you can save those ad groups
into plans and what you can then do is
import those plans as it were in your
Google ads campaign but what we're
particularly interested in for now is
how do I discover new keywords and how
do I get search volumes and forecasts
those are the two areas where you can
get data about your keywords so let's
start with looking at Discover the
keywords so here you go and there's two
ways to find keywords you can start with
keywords you can also start with a
website so what you do here you put in
the keywords that you want to look for
so I can here put for instance SEO
I can put in link building
and I can put in a keyword research
and click on that
yep so I can unfiltered unrelated
keywords I can put it in and entering a
site so I can make it as specific as
possible but let's go for these three
keywords
get the results
yeah and here you see my three keywords
and here you see a whole range of
keyword ideas
yeah and that is very of course Very
powerful very useful information these
are all words in relation to my three
words that I specified SEO link building
and keyword research
now what is the data it will give you
the average monthly searches you see
that here in bands from 10K to 100k from
1K to 10K it will give you the
competition level for the keywords now
bear in mind this is competition level
for Google pay-per-click advertising it
is not a competition level for the
actual keyword so
um yep and then here you see the top of
page bit the low range and here you see
the top of bit high range
yes so that is kind of the interface
here you have your keyword view you can
specify your columns you can exclude
ideas in this case add all suggestions
and here you can add filters and here
you can refine your keywords and we're
going to have a look at that in a minute
up here you can specify the country
yep so we've got United Kingdom you can
say where do you want to search for and
here you put in the period and that is
in this case January to December 2022.
so that is sort of the high level
interface when it comes to getting ideas
for keywords so let's go back and do a
bit more
details on this yes so let me take a
word like t-shirt t-shirt and what are
the ideas that I'm getting and I click
here get results so here now I'm getting
a whole range of ideas
yeah on keywords
so now there may be keywords that I
don't want in here yeah so this is where
I can specify and refine my keywords so
here I can say do Branch or non-branded
so I don't want any keywords in relation
to specific Brands so I can take those
out yes so your Nike keywords are gone
yes so your Adidas keywords are gone so
it is a lot more specific now
yeah so you can also say for instance I
don't want t-shirts with no I don't want
Playboy t-shirts yeah so what I can do I
can go to filters I can add a filter and
here I can say exclude
in this case keyword text does not
contain white for instance yep so that
will means it will take all the t-shirts
out where the word white comes in
yep so that is how you can get your
speed more specific with your keywords
and filter them to be more specific and
more relevant for you all right so what
you can then do you can actually select
a few of the keywords that you say hey
these are relevant for me and you can
say okay I am going to put them in a
plan I can put them in an existing plan
or I can put them in a new plan I can
put them into an ad group yep or I can
also look at the match type for those
keywords yeah so I can put them as broad
match phrase match and exact match and
then I can add keywords to create my
plan okay I can copy the keywords
there's more that I can do I can add
them as negative keywords yeah so those
are kind of the functionalities that you
have when you search for your keywords
so let's have a look now at do a bit
more on your keywords when it comes to
competition and when it comes to long
tail so let's close this let's do a
search on keywords for the term e-bike
yep so I'm going to get my results
and what I want to do I want to look for
the keyword with a low competition
yeah so here you see the high
competition and the low competition I
can sort them going up and going down
yes I'm going to so it's a low and now
remember this competition is for ads
yeah so this is not competition for your
search engine optimization
yeah so here when you look at low
competition keywords look at this one
you have stealth bomber e-bike here you
see that is a very popular keyword with
low competition which has a year on year
change of 900 percent
yeah so that is how you can find your
trending keywords yeah so this could be
a very relevant keyword for you yep so
there is also your three months change
so you can look at seasonal keywords
so I can also search for the term for
instance holiday sweater
get results
yeah and if I now look at my three
months change I can look at seasonal
keywords here so look at this Pull and
Bear Christmas sweater holiday sweater
ugly Christmas sweater yeah funny so
here you see the treaders specifically
when it comes to to seasonal patterns so
important that you identify those as
well
yeah now how do you find lucrative
keywords you're going to look at the top
of page bit Yeah and see if they have a
commercial value so what you do is
you're going to look at the top of page
bit high range yeah and from low so here
you see we go back to high range
yep so here you see that these terms
like the Bowden Christmas sweater has a
fairly high top of page price yeah so a
bit price which means there is a good
commercial value for this sweater which
also means that you could then use that
for your SEO because a lot of people
will be searching for that keyword so
there's a high commercial value and then
it's good for your
organic ranking so lots of features that
you can get here out of your Google
Keyword Planner
okay so now that you've understand the
basics of Google Keyword Planner let's
have a look at some tips that will give
you more functionality in the Google
Keyword Planner so one of the big issues
that I have with Google Keyword Planner
is the fact that my average monthly
searches are in a range between here for
example
ebook I didn't want ebook I wanted
e-bike
yeah so that this is range so between 10
and 100
000 average monthly searches now that
range is so wide that doesn't do
anything for me so how can I bring exact
average monthly searches into my Google
Keyword Planner now there's two ways of
doing that the first way of doing that
is go to the forecast section for the
with the word e-bike for instance yep
and I'm going to add a keyword and I'm
going to type e-bike
yep I'm going to add the keyword to the
ad Group which is test I'm clicking
create and I'm going to save my keyword
now here you see what the details is
that you get here so I can get based on
this data uh here you see the average
cost per acquisition number of clicks
but what I want to do here I want to
look at not the maximize conversions but
I want to look at the maximize clicks
and I'm going to apply that
yeah I'm going to put it into a slightly
bigger
um let's have a look here yeah so here I
have the data so here you see I can get
two conversions
440 pounds with a five per pound average
daily budget now what I'm gonna do here
I'm going to click on the highest price
the highest budget that I would spend of
this of let's say 520 and let's see how
that changes my data so then here you
see that with this highest price
for the term e-bike yeah I can get about
000 impressions
and because I took the highest price
that would be giving me the highest
number impressions of Impressions so I
could say that on average the e-bike for
this period the monthly number of
Impressions that you would get would be
thirty thousand yeah so that is a way to
get more exact search volumes for your
keywords
another way of getting average monthly
search details is by using an external
tool called keyword everywhere keyword
everywhere is basically for Google
search so if I type in e-bike here in
Google search it will give me
search volumes here in under the Search
terms and I can see additional keywords
as well but once I've activated it
yeah so I'm gonna switch it on yeah so
to get these details I can now go back
to my keyword ideas if I do a refresh
and because I've activated the Google
Chrome plugin I go back to discover new
keywords I type in e-bike I'm getting
the results and see what I'm getting now
I'm getting exact volumes I'm getting
cost per click I'm getting competition
and I get trends for that keyword or
those keywords as well so this all of a
sudden adds a lot of value to your
Google Keyword Planner when it comes to
the monthly search volumes so a very
powerful tool now it basically works on
the basis of credits that you buy each
keywords that it shows you the search
volumes is costing you one credit
yeah and you buy hundred thousand
credits for ten dollars that basically
gives you one hundred thousand keywords
as part of your research so it is a good
deal I think to get the credits for your
keyword everywhere too
okay so that is how to unlock search
volumes in Google Keyword Planner let's
look at the let me switch it off to go
back to the core functionality switching
off keywords everywhere let's do a
refresh yeah so we're going to discover
new ideas we're going back to the e-bike
and we're going to see that I can make
my search results local yeah with the
local Dimension so here I can type
United Kingdom but I can make my
locations more specific so I can also
say for instance let's do London yes so
I now have United Kingdom and London so
I'm going to take United Kingdom out and
I now have
london-based search volumes yep so
that's what you can get by changing the
location I'm going to look at the
popularity of search locations so I'm
going to look at forecasts I'm going to
let's say ADD test is the keyword the ad
group here I'm going to type in Super
Bowl okay I'm going to click save and
I'm going to change the location to the
United States okay and don't need the
United Kingdom so I'm going to click
save
yeah so here I'm getting my conversion
data but if I scroll down then here you
can see what are the top states when it
comes to using that keywords
yep so that is a really powerful way to
look at
locations you could also be even more
specific I can hear say okay give me zip
codes for instance here so you can
search by ZIP codes as well and you can
see how the popularity is around zip
code
so finally what you can do here as well
is to look at the various devices that
people are using for those Search terms
okay so that is it what I want to share
with you on Google keywords planner
you've seen the basic operation and I
also gave you some ways to get
additional functionality and
particularly ways to get more detailed
search volumes
so now that you've seen all the ins and
outs of Google Keyword Planner its
functionality and how to overcome some
of its shortcomings let's close with
giving you some tips and tricks on using
Google Keyword Planner first of all make
sure you use Broad and specific match
types when you enter your keywords to
get as wider range of keywords possible
in your in your keyword lists also make
sure that you research your competition
just go to enter the website of your
competition and see what keywords come
up with that your competitors may be
using that you have forgotten so you can
then take those keywords and get
additional keyword ideas around those
keywords that your competition is using
make use of negative keywords I
explained negative keywords earlier yeah
keywords like jobs like free like
promotion yeah filter those out in your
in your keyword lists so you have the
best sort of Clicks in your Google ads
Google Keyword Planner is not the only
tool combine your keyword data with
other tools like semrush or HH ah refs
and uh like the keywords everywhere tool
that I explained to you and how that can
enrich the data you have in your Google
Keyword Planner and then finally
experiment with different keywords and
AD groups while you're running your
campaign Google will give you campaign
results it will give you suggestions it
will give you the most popular keywords
that people are using so every time
check your campaign settings and your ad
groups and your keywords and you may
want to fine tune those hello everyone
and welcome to this Google analytics
full course video by simply learn today
we will understand Google analytics
which is the best analytical tool
provided by Google to check up on our
website we will understand how Google
analytics works
how we can use it to measure the
performance of our website we'll also
understand how to set up goals and
create events that will help us keep our
website on track
next we will look at Google tag manager
and towards the end we will unlock the
mystery of how to rank at number one
position on Google it's it's not that
hard as you think it is
we have Rob with us who has more than 15
years of experience in digital marketing
and analytics and he will take us
through these topics over to you rob
welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders
with simply learn and today we're going
to talk about Google analytics I'm very
excited to be with you today because
Google analytics is one of my favorite
Google platforms and my favorite topics
so let's talk about what we're going to
cover today and we're going to start out
with how to set up a Google analytics
account and so we're going to talk about
everything that entails including
creating your Google analytics account
we're going to talk about setting up a
property in your account and what a
property is we're going to talk about
setting up a reporting view in your
property and we're going to talk about
installing the tracking code so those
are the series of steps we're going to
go through today in terms of setting up
a Google analytics account so let's get
right to it and so really the Bruin
prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a Google analytics account is
to have a Google login and ID so when
you actually go to Google analytics you
need to be able to sign up or sign in
and so once you actually sign in then
you're gonna go walk through a series of
steps but really that's really all you
need to get the account going is a
Google ID and login so if you have a
Gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other Google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for Google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new Google Analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be to name your company your your
name whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here I'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the URL for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
in analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm gonna talk about why that's
important here in a minute and then
you're going to choose your time zone
and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics and the day ends based on that
time zone so so the data that Google
analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located in okay and then you have some
additional options here okay so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow Google products and services
so if you opt into this then basically
what Google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
I would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by Google
it doesn't hurt to hear from Google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what Google
is going to do is share your data that
it collects on your website in this case
demo.com simplylearn.com it's going to
share that data anonymously with others
in the industry in this case jobs and
education and because you've opted in
it's going to do the same exact thing
for you it's going to share Anonymous
data on other websites in the same
industry and the benefit of that is we
get to see what other websites or how
other websites are performing compared
to ours what's the Benchmark in our
industry and so the benchmarking to me
is important and I'm going to go over
that in a few minutes when we go over
the different reports but to me I would
always opt into benchmarking because
this is the only report Google provides
in analytics about how others in your
industry is performing versus your
website okay so it's a way to compare
your website performance against others
in the same industry the other options
here technical support and account
specialist I would also recommend man
you opt into those because then it
allows you to basically Google allow
Google access to your account and
they'll be able to help you if you occur
or run into any issues so these are the
options in setting up a Google analytics
account it's very simple very easy to do
you're just entering in a few Fields
note that we talking about a website
right now so I'm talking about
demo.simplylearn.com but just know that
if you want to track a mobile app Google
analytics will allow you to do that as
well you just choose the option mobile
app so we're tracking a website we want
to know how users behave when they get
to my website and that's what Google
analytics is going to allow us to
measure and look at we just need to do a
couple more steps in the process so once
we fill out these fields here we're
going to click get tracking ID now I'm
going to accept the terms of service I'm
going to accept another terms and
service and relate relation to data
protection I'm going to click accept
once I accept I'm going to be able to
get some tracking code the tracking ID
is the ID associated with your account
and so this number is going to be
associated with your account so your
account ID starts with UA and it's going
to be this number here now the dash one
is the property you set up so in this
case I set up
demo.simplylearn.com if I wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then I can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property I set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
Etc depending on how many properties I
set up so by default I set up one
property so my first property ID is dash
one if I set up a second property the
same account number is just gonna have a
dash too and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID and the snippet of code
now this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in in
the ID now there's an alternative to
adding the Google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is the way
I would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend watching the YouTube video we
have on Google tag manager you can just
go to YouTube Type in simply learn
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associated with tag
manager if you can associate it with tag
manager then that's the easier route to
go versus putting code on your website
okay so again take a look at the video
we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager that's the route I would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a Plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to basically understand how
Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
analytics demo account and so if you
just type in and search Google analytics
demo account basically what you're going
to do you're going to choose the first
listing there and you're going to go to
demo account so if you have a Google
analytics or Google login then all you
need to do is click on access demo
account and so what Google's going to do
is put this demo account into your
account and so it's going to look
something like this so if I click on
demo account here it's going to add to
my Google analytics account so I'm going
to have then access to the demo account
from Google and Google analytics so I
would recommend going this route here if
you're not familiar or you're not sure
what you're getting yourself into so
think of the demo account as kind of a
test drive you're test driving Google
analytics before you even add any code
to your website so again all you need is
a Google account and if you have a
Google account and you add the demo
account to your Google analytics account
you're going to be able to see how
analytics works okay and so that's what
I would also recommend so if you're not
ready to start adding code to your
website then what you can do is just
simply add the demo account and then
once you add the demo account you're
free to peruse around Google analytics
to see the different types of reports it
has to offer now when you do actually
set up a Google analytics account you're
going to have some settings that you're
going to want to pay attention to so
when you set up the account you have the
account name and then you have a
property so under each property you have
by default you're going to have one View
and so here you can see this view here
so if we look at the account we set up
we set up a demo simply learn account
property is demos simply learned so
that's associated with the website we're
going to track and then again by default
under each property you're going to have
a view and so by default the name of the
view is going to be called all website
data and so in that view is where all
your analytics data is going to be
stored so you can see my screen here
there's a lot of different settings you
have you have settings under the account
you have settings under the property and
you have settings under the view so
we're going to talk more about these
settings and future webinars for
advanced Google analytics users but for
now know that there's a bunch of
settings that you have that you can play
around with when it comes to Google
analytics anything from adding users to
your Google analytics account your
Google analytics property or view you
can actually set up goals you can set up
filters you can set up segments you can
link up Google ads you can you know set
up remarketing list there's a lot you
can do in terms of the settings as it
relates to Google analytics but so know
those settings are there they're located
right down here in this little sprocket
icon that's the admin icon so if you
need to get to these settings at any
time you could simply just click on the
sprocket or the admin icon and then
you'll be prompted to choose any one of
these settings here that you want to
edit or alter so now let's take a look
at some Google analytics reports so once
you've actually set up your account you
have a number of different reports that
you have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm in admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users I actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here I can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring Source if they came from
say search or social I can see the
source there and I can see what pages
they're active on and then here I can
see what locations where they're located
and so if I want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview I can
certainly do that if I go to locations
under real time I could see a majority
of my users are coming from the United
States okay where are they coming from
I'll just click on traffic sources and
here I could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's Google
it's either paid search or organic
search so I can see here it's organic
then I can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so I
could see currently I have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the Google's women's white t page so
forth and so on now most importantly if
you have a vent tracking set up so if
you taking a look at our Google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in Google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current events that I have
currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I could
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look look at
what conversions are happening in real
time just by clicking on conversions and
so now I could see I had one active user
who entered the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you could see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience this is just right
underneath real time I'm gonna see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information
Etc however we can still paint a nice
picture on who is coming to our website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from what language what device
do they get to our website from how old
were they okay were they male or female
or other what interests do they have
what browser do they use so we can paint
a nice picture based on all this
information that Google analytics is
providing us under audience so if I go
to audience overview here I can see I
have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that
represents 61 of the users and so Google
analytics does a great job of giving me
an overall percentage so if I have a
hundred percent of the users I could see
61 percent of those users represented
English speaking users from the United
States seven percent represented English
speaking users from Great Britain and so
when it comes to analytics we have users
and users are broken down into two
categories they're either returning or
they're new so when you add the Google
and Alex tracking script to your website
what's going to happen is if a user or
when a user goes to your website they're
going to get cookied if it's the first
time they've been to your website what
Google analytics is going to do is store
a cookie in the browser so when that
same user comes back another day in the
same browser analytics is going to
recognize that that cookie is in the
browser and so then analytics is going
to categorize that user as a returning
user okay so that's how analytics is
able to differentiate new versus
returning so if that user doesn't have a
cookie in the browser then analytics is
going to recognize that store the cookie
and then count that user as a new user
and so when you're looking in analytics
you're going to be able to see a
breakdown of new versus returning so
here I can see over three quarters of my
traffic over the past week here I can
see April 6 through April 12th three
over three quarters are new users to the
website here I could see about 23 24 are
returning users okay so I can get a good
breakdown of what type of users are
coming am I driving new traffic am I
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay I can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience and so
if I skip down now to demographics I can
click on overview and when that report
loads I can see now under demographics
overview I can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here I can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if I
want to change this date range I could
simply do that I can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and I can even compare it to the
previous pair period or the previous
year I'm going to choose the last 30
days I'm going to click apply now I'm
looking at data over the last 30 days
and again you can change the date range
to any range you want you can only go
back as far as when you actually created
the Google analytics account you can't
go prior to that so here I'm looking at
the last 30 days and I can see almost 47
of my users were in their age range of
25 to 34. now when it comes to gender I
can say 66 percent represent males so I
can get a breakout of gender and age as
well as interest and click on interest
and look at the overview there and see
what the interest is of the users who
are coming to my site based on in-market
segments or Affinity I can also choose
language and location so if I want to
know exactly where my users are located
located when they're coming to my
website I can click on location and here
I can get a breakout 43 percent of the
users of the last 30 days were from the
United States more importantly I can
align my audience with goals and we'll
talk about goals here in a minute but
here I can see if I have an e-commerce
website I can see of those 43 percent
0.29 percent of those converted or
purchased something and that equates to
94 transactions so I can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if I click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports I tend to spend a bit of time on
because I want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
Google demo website I can see mobile
represents approximately 27 percent of
the traffic so desktop still represents
a majority of the traffic so for you you
want to keep an eye on mobile because
mobile is definitely a majority of what
people use nowadays that's how people
start their day that's how they transact
Via Mobile whether that's purchasing
something communicating or searching it
all starts with mobile so you want to
keep an eye on mobile and more
importantly you want to keep an eye on
Behavior so Google analytics is telling
me that yes I have approximately 27 of
my traffic of the last 30 days came from
mobile how are they interacting with my
website so if I look across this report
I'm going to be able to see different
metrics so if I'm measuring specific
metrics against my dimension in this
case the dimension is what we're
measuring and in this example we're
measuring mobile I can see that the
bounce Ray is approximately 48 percent
and bounce rate means that if a user in
this case for mobile landed on a page
they left the site without going any
further so they consider it a bounce if
they don't go to another page if they
leave the site from the page they landed
on and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 4 28
Mobile in desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41 now if I look a little bit
further at engagement I can see how many
pages on average do mobile users look at
so versus desktop it's a little bit
lower you can see 3.86 on desktop it's
4.5 now if I look a little bit further
in engagement I want to be able to
measure how long somebody from mobile
stays on the website if they're bouncing
at 48 but they're also looking at 3.8
Pages 3.9 almost four pages per session
then that means in this report analytics
is telling me they're spending about two
minutes on the site and interestingly
enough I can see that mobile of the last
30 days had more transactions so 51
transactions versus 34 transactions from
desktop and interestingly enough the
e-commerce conversion rate is at point
two nine percent that's higher than
desktop at .07 it's lower than tablet
but it's higher than desktop and mobile
has the most transactions and since they
have the most transactions they have the
most Revenue at 2 380. so yes the
engagement isn't exactly as great as it
is this desktop but we can see that
people are still purchasing with their
mobile devices so it's something to keep
an eye on and mobile is something I
definitely look at in fact since it's
such an important report one thing you
can do in analytics is if you actually
like a report and you think you're going
to look at that report multiple times
then you can simply just go ahead and
click save at the top here so if I click
save I'm going to enter a name for this
report I'm just going to call it mobile
report and click OK and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is low located under
customization customization is located
above real time okay so if I close that
up you can see audience real time
customization if I click on
customization if I click on Save reports
I should be able to see my save report
here and I do so here I can see mobile
report if I click on it I can simply go
to the report I was looking at before I
saved it so save reports to me is a good
feature and analytics because it allows
you to quickly access a report that
you've saved in the past so let's take a
look at one more report under audience
and let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we're setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and I recommended you do so
and so if you did I actually opt into
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see how your site compares to
others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs and education and I choose
education all education as my industry
vertical I should be able to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how I compare with those
websites so I'm choosing all countries I
can narrow that down if I wanted to I
can just search for the United States I
can choose a specific State and then I
can choose a particular site size so
here I'm choosing sites by daily session
so these are sites that have an average
of 5 000 to almost 10 000 sessions a day
and so in this vertical education in the
United States sites that have five
thousand to
9999 sessions per day that means that
they're approximately 310 web property
is contributing to this report okay
based on this criteria I chose now if my
site is similar meaning if I'm in the
United States if I'm in education and
I'm receiving 5 000 to 9 999 sessions
per day then I'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now Google
sharing this data anonymously from the
other websites and they're doing the
same with your website to those
particular websites benchmarking reports
okay so it's a shared data anonymously
in particular Industries and verticals
and so now I'm looking at a channel
report so if I want to see how I compare
to others in my industry then I can go
ahead and see by channel for example in
my driving as much traffic as others in
my industry and you can see I'm not in
fact I'm 76 77 worse in terms of the
amount of traffic being driven from
organic search so anything in red is
going to show as a negative result a
negative comparison whereas something in
green is a positive comparison so if I
look at engagement I can see that I
might not be driving as much traffic but
I can see that the pages per session are
better than the site average or the
industry average I can see if I go over
again looking just at organic search I
can see the bounce rate is better than
the industry average so the channel
report under benchmarking allows you to
measure how you compare to others in
your industry and you could do so by
looking at location and devices so if
you opted into benchmarking when you set
up your account then you'll be able to
compare your website against others in
your industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning are new came to our website
and so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our website
did they come via organic search meaning
do they type something into Google and
find you in the organic listing
analytics also groups users based on
whether they came to your site directly
meaning did they type in the URL
directly into the browser or did they
bookmark your website site and come back
via the bookmark so they're grouping
users under direct they also group users
under referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like Twitter or Facebook if
you're running paid search meaning if
you're running paid search on say Google
then do they come from Paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics for group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I could
see how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report it's
so so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number is about 56 percent so 56
percent of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and and so just like we looked
at with the audience reports when it
came to mobile we can also look at
engagement by channel so just like
mobile we looked at bounce rate pages
per session average session duration we
can do the same thing here with our
Channel report more importantly in
addition to behavior we can see
conversions and since we're running an
e-commerce platform we could see what
the conversion rate is by channel so
organic search did drive the most
traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 000 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in Revenue so I'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
I can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by Channel you'll
also get a summary so here I can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so I could see over the last 30
days I've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that out of those four fifty four
thousand users I had 70 000 sessions I
could see my average bounce rate was 43
percent the pages per session were just
over four and the average session
duration how long did somebody stay on
my website on average about 2 minutes
and 50 55 seconds the average conversion
rate was 0.14 and I had a total of 97
transactions totaling 5500 okay and
that's all over the last 30 days so any
report you look at in analytics is going
to have a summary and note that any
to allow you to save it so if it's a
report you think you're going to go back
and look at at a future date then you
simply just have to click on the save
button conversely if you don't want to
save it you can simply just export it so
you can export it as a PDF if I click on
PDF it's going to allow me to export
that as a PDF now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
Google sheet you can export it as an
Excel or you can export it as a comment
delimited file so here you can see I can
save it as a PDF if I want to and if I
click OK it's going to save to my
desktop or location of my channel using
and then I can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running Google ads note that you
can connect Google ads to analytics and
this is key because now I can see how
many people are coming from Google ads
to my website and are they converting
now this is important because with
Google ads I'm actually paying for the
click so you can see here I'm running a
report based on campaign data so I could
see what campaigns are driving traffic
how much a pain per click and you can
see on average I'm paying 34 cents per
click and then more importantly I want
to be able to see if they're converting
so you can see I've spent eight hundred
and ten dollars over the last 30 days
and received 850 58 dollars in Revenue
so you want to make sure that you link
up your Google ads account to your
Google analytics account for this very
reason you want to be able to see how
your Google ads campaigns perform once
the users get to your website and so I
want to see if they're engaging and I
want to see if they're converting so
they're all sorts of reports under
Google ads so you can look at it by
keywords by search queries by hour of
the day if you're running display
campaigns you can look at display
targeting says all sorts of reports
under Google ads you just have to link
it up and you link it up under the admin
now there are other reports that you can
look at so if I go to campaigns I can
look at all campaigns so if you're
running all sorts of different types of
campaigns whether that be on Facebook
whether it be email whether that be you
know other types of advertising let's
just say Twitter or Instagram you're
going to be able to see those campaigns
here and that's under all campaigns and
again you'll be able to see the campaign
name and you'll be able to see metrics
associated with those campaigns and more
importantly you'll be able to see your
e-commerce if you're running e-commerce
platform or if you have goals set up so
you'll be able to look at how your
campaigns are not one not only driving
traffic but two are they converting
let's go from acquisition reporting to
behavior so Behavior reports are going
to actually show you how users behaved
once they got to your website once they
landed on a page on your website how did
they behave so when we looked at
audience we got a sense of who is coming
with acquisition we get a sense of how
the traffic got to our website did they
come from organic direct social Etc the
behavior reports allow us to actually
measure how that traffic behave once
they landed on a page on our website and
so if I go to overview under Behavior
now I'm looking at this graph here it's
showing me how many pages I've had and a
page view is simply once a page is
viewed it's counted as a page view so if
a user comes to my site they're
initiating a session and if they look at
a page then that page is going to have a
page view okay so a user can look at a
page multiple times in a session and
every time they look at that page it's
going to count as a page view so here I
can see in this graph how many pages
I've had again over the last 30 days and
if I look further at my overview report
I can see the specific pages and how
many pages they've had and I can also
look at some other metrics okay the
average bounce rate the average time on
page I can look at the exit rate which
means how many people actually exited or
the percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look at a report by Page
this is my Dimension this is what I'm
measuring my page and now I can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other Pages then every page that user
looks at it's going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to another to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where pages is an accumulation of how
many times the page was viewed in the
same session so in other words you're
always going to have more page views
than unique pages okay so this gives me
a sense of how my pages performed so
again I can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low if the exit percentage of
exit rate is high then you probably want
to do something with that page now these
are all pages but if I jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people people
actually landed on that page and so here
I can see under my landing page report I
can see the home page had 36 000 17
sessions in the last 30 days that's how
many people landed on the home page so
here I can see 71 percent were news
sessions meaning that I had a lot of new
users who landed on the home page in
fact 25
000 or 52 percent of the people who
landed on the home page were new I could
see the bounce rates about 42 percent
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing I like about
the landing page report is they can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case I can see of those 36 000
sessions I had 20 22 transactions
totaling 1200 in revenue and that's an
e-commerce conversion rate of 0.06
percent so the home page over the last
30 days contributed to point zero six
percent of the revenue so this gives you
an idea of when somebody lands on your
website and they land on a page is that
page helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under Behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because with Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from might
know how to have the best infrastructure
you may not even be on the best internet
Network meaning you're on a cell network
or the Wi-Fi is not that gray or you can
be on a page that just has a lot of
images or a lot of code that may slow it
down so there are other factors involved
and so what Google analytics does is
show you what those factors are so here
I can see by browser what the average
load time is if I want to look at
Country I could see what country is
contributing to the load time now the
great thing about about the site speed
report is if I go to speed suggestions
okay what speed suggestions is going to
do is it's going to show me the page
load Time by Page and then it's actually
going to provide a link where I can
actually click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
Google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if I click on seven total
what it's actually going to do it's
going to open up a new window and it's
going to open up another Google report
called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is going to give me some
information about what I can do to
create foreign
correct the page load of that particular
page so look at the site speed report
it's important because there is a
correlation between site speed or page
load time and user behavior of that page
and there's also correlation between
page load time and a page ranking
organically on search so page load time
is very important it's so important that
I'm even going to save it so I'm going
to click save and click on speed site
speed suggestions as my name and click
OK and now that report is going to be
saved under customization under save
reports let's jump from Behavior to
conversions now conversion reporting is
arguably the most important section in
in Google analytics because what the
conversions reporting allows us to do is
see how people are converting or if
they're not converting on our website
and so in Google analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals now you have
the opportunity to set up 20 goals in
your Google analytics View and so to set
up a goal okay so you're going to click
on admin and Under The View you're going
to see goals and so if you don't even
have goals the first step is to create
goals and so you have four different
goal types in analytics so you have
pages per session so how many pages per
session is so if your goal is set to say
three or two if somebody actually looked
at two or three pages per session it's
going to count as a goal okay so if I
look here I can see I have pages per
session set at 10. so that means that if
a user came to the site looked at more
than 10 pages per session then it's
going to count as a goal another goal
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it it's going to
count as a goal and in this case I can
see here that the goal is set to this
particular page here and so when
somebody actually lands on that page
it's going to count as a goal now there
are two other goal ties we can look at
one is duration so just like pages per
session in our previous example is
somebody looked at 10 pages per session
it's going to count as a goal with
duration it's based on time so in this
particular case if you set up a duration
goal and the duration is set to say one
minute and 30 seconds then that means if
a user comes to my website and they
spend at least one minute and 30 seconds
then it's going to count as a goal okay
and then the fourth type of goal in
Google analytics is an event based goal
so when you set up event tracking you
could turn that event into a goal so if
somebody clicks on say the submit button
of a form you can turn that event into
to a goal so here you can see the
category equals contact form so you can
always verify if a goal works just by
clicking on verify this goal and in this
case this event is turned into a goal so
anytime somebody fires this event it's
going to count as a goal so you have
four different goal types in Google
analytics you have pages per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure goals under conversions so now
if I look at goals overview I can be
able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal two engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate of 10 meaning
that I had 7 000 of all the users that
came to the website 7000 in goal
completions meaning
7106 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want to
be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and the great thing about
Google analytics here is that I can
actually see by segments so the default
segment in a segment is just looking at
a specific user set so the default
segment is always all users however I
can choose a different segment so if I
want to choose instead of all users if I
want to choose Mobile Traffic I can
select Mobile Traffic hit AI so I'm
actually now looking at a subset of data
I'm looking at mobile traffic so if all
the mobile users have come to my site I
can see 1400 engaged or looked at 10
pages or more okay and that's a seven
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rates of each
goal but you can also change the
segments of that particular goal to see
who exactly converted okay another
report I like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if I
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here I can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
converter version so if I look at three
channels direct organic and referral I
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral twelve and a half
percent if I look at direct and organic
12.24 so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion paths as an example I
can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times two
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination over the last 30 days my
second best conversion gen grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition Price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert art but that traffic came
back a second time via direct and did
convert so that's our second best
Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only have channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance for this particular webinar
we're going to jump into Google
analytics Direct play and spend all of
our time there because it's about
learning practical applications so goals
are important goals uh let me just say
this goals are in analytics something
that should be aligned with your
business and we call goals that are
align with your business kpis are key
performance indicators so it's very
important as a precursor that you know
how to set up goals in Google analytics
because if you're using Google analytics
you want to measure everything against
the goal so without further Ado let's
jump right into Google analytics so if I
go to Google analytics and I log in okay
what I want to do is go down to admin
click on admin here and admin will take
you to basically a screen that looks
like this where you have an account
column you have your property column and
then you have review column now The View
column is where you're going to go to
set up goals okay so every view in every
property has up to 20 goals okay so by
default in analytics you're going to
have at least one view for your property
so if I have a property I'm gonna have
at least one view but if I happen to set
up multiple views like you see here then
I know for every view I set up I have 20
goals to work with so where are those
goals so Under The View I'm going to
click on goals and now I could see I
have 20 at my disposal now you can see
here by clicking on the recording column
I can see I have in this particular
property this particular view I have
five goals that are active so you can
use up to 20 but you don't have to have
20 active Okay you can have one active
two active my recommendation is at least
have one one goal again when you set up
a goal you're going to measure
everything in analytics against that
goal okay so in this case we have five
particular goals we're measuring so we
have five active out of 20 total so if I
don't know no longer want to use a goal
I could simply just turn it off if I
want to continue using it just turn it
on okay it's that simple you could turn
on and off goals so here I already have
five set up so if you want to set up a
new goal the one thing you need to know
in Google analytics is in order to set
up a new goal okay you need to have edit
access at least the view level I would
say at the property level so you want to
make sure whoever's in charge of Google
analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log login
to Google analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're going to need edit
permissions to add new goals so I have
edit permissions I'm going to go to
goals and I want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal or do you have any Commerce
site is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red CTA button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
that up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99 of the
time I'm just going to choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free pre-filled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so we already have in mind what
type of goal we want to set up so for
example if somebody goes to fill out a
form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that thank you page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission
then goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if I go to continue I'm going to name my
goal first so I'm going to say thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an ID so notice this is goal
ID 15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so one through five six through
ten eleven through fifteen sixteen
through twenty into goal sets so for
example goal 16 through 20 is part of
goal set for and why does Google
analytics combine these goals into
different goal sets well because it's
easier to measure and look at data by
goal sets so for example if I jump into
any report here if I go to all traffic
channels and I want to measure how many
goals by Channel I can look at it by
goal set so if I have goal set one
selected then I know any goal I have
active in there between goal ID one
through goal id5 I'm gonna be able to
see those goals and goal set one and now
I'm going to be able to measure every
goal I have active and goal set one
against the channel so if I choose goal
set two whatever goals are active there
goal set three Etc notice I don't have
any goals 16 through 20 active that earn
goal set four therefore I don't have
that option available to me so back to
admin the bottom left navigation again
goals okay we want to measure somebody
going to the thank you page we have edit
access we're going to choose custom as
our goal setup we're going to type in a
goal name I'm just going to say thank
you okay this is goal 15. now this is
the important part Google analytics has
four different goal types destination in
duration pages per session or screens
per session to screens per session is
related to mobile because Google
analytics measures mobile app activity
and then you have an event so we're
going to cover all four of these but for
the sake of this simple example I'm
going to choose destination why because
if somebody goes to that thank you page
we're going to go ahead and put in the
thank you page as the goal the goal URL
so for example destination is my choice
I'm going to click continue now this is
where I'm gonna put the URL so if my URL
is just simply thank you.html I can just
go ahead and put thank you.html or if
it's just thank you then I can just do
thank you depends on the website depends
on the URI structure so whatever that
URL is that's what you're going to put
in and when you're done you can verify
it so what Google analytics does is
actually will verify over the last seven
days if anybody's actually gone to that
particular page so if we click verify we
can see zero percent conversion rate so
that tells us that if this is the
correct URL then we've had zero percent
people go to that page this is just an
example however if you didn't see a
conversion then you might want to make
sure you check the URL here that you put
in and if you do see a conversion rate
then you know it's working so Google
analytics actually has options so we're
saying thank you is equal to so the
destination URL is equal to thank you or
thank you.html or thank you dot ESP or
whatever that thank you page is okay you
do have options so if you have a long
URL you could say it begins with and you
could say it begins with say thank you
so this is the logic we're going to say
hey if anybody goes to a URL that begins
with thank you thank Canada's a goal or
you could say equals two so if anybody
goes to a URL that equals two thank you
then count it as a goal you have one
more option Here regular expression so
Google analytics understands the
language of regular Expressions so
regular expressions are just special
characters used to communicate with
Google analytics in order to hone in on
exactly what you're trying to track so
we can always say you know starts with
or ends with so we can you know use
characters like the dollar sign ends
with or begins with so we can always do
that so you can use regular Expressions
as well if you're familiar with regular
Expressions if you're not then you don't
have to use them but there are special
characters where that you can insert in
that are used as regular expression so
if you're not familiar with regular
expression don't choose that option you
can choose the other option of equals to
or begins with now note that on all
three of these options I didn't put the
domain so if my domain is Amma Dash
foundation.org slash and then thank you
I don't need to put the domain because
analytics is already knows what domain
we're tracking so you don't have to put
in the domain here when you're entering
in in this case the Google URL so you
can omit the domain so when you put in
that URL you know that you have three
options to work with and then you always
always want to verify that goal URL you
always want to verify it because if you
see zero percent conversion and in this
case of the last seven days then that
should tell you something either your
goal is not set up correctly or you just
don't have any conversions either way
you want to double check that now when
it comes to the destination URL goal you
do have an option here for funnel so if
I turn on funnel then that means I have
the ability to track how people went
through my funnel so if I have a cart
and I want to be able to check how many
people go in and out of the cart then I
have the option of adding specific Pages
as part of the cart so we could say you
know step one which is basically cart we
could say step two is billing
information that could be slash billing
we could see step three is shipping
information slash shipping and then step
four could be you know confirm and that
could be slash confirmation so whatever
your url structure is for your cart and
it doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all I'm doing is putting a
series of steps with URLs as each step
and why do I want to do that because I
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that I've created okay
so here I could see this is my funnel
that I've created for this particular
goal okay and the funnel is only
available for the destination URL so the
funnels available if you want to see
traffic through the goal okay and how
people go through the funnel and where
they drop off now you have an option
here to make the first step required so
if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel through the first step only now
if I turn that off then I'm measuring
the funnel through each step meaning
that I can measure people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required the first step then I'm only
measuring traffic as it enters in the
top of the funnel so you have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals you do have a value
so if somebody did actually convert Okay
Google analytics is going to count it as
a conversion and you can assign a value
so if you're not an e-commerce website
then you may want to think about
assigning value if you are an e-commerce
website then analytics has the ability
to track e-commerce revenue for your
website so you don't need to add a value
but in this case let's just say your
non-profit organization and you're
collecting donations
and on average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to five dollars well you can just
go ahead and put five dollars in there
as the value for that goal so that means
that if somebody did go to in this
example slash thank you and convert
analytics is going to count it as a goal
and then assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're
non-ecommerce if you're say a non-profit
like this organization or your B2B and
you want to track some value then you
have that option there so with the
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel with all goal types
you have the option of adding a value
all goal types and we're going to go
through the rest of them you have the
option of verifying that goal so that's
the structure of setting up a goal
destination URL is just one goal type
we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in Google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes to the funnel so
where do you look for that funnel in
information well you want to get out of
admin you want to go to the left side
navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visualization So based on the funnel you
set up you're going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice on this particular funnel we
don't have the first step required why
because I could see traffic as it goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so here I could see the
first step is the store front page so
over this particular period of time I
had 84 sessions enter the storefront
page so out of those 84 I can see 21
left the storefront page 63 went on to
the next step in the funnel which is the
cart page I can then see 24 people went
on to the cart page directly and 5
exited the site altogether okay so that
gave me 87 total and from 87 I saw that
82 went on to the next page for the next
step what analytics does is they give
you a percentage so in the first step we
had 63 move on to the cart page out of
84 that's 75 percent so from the cart
page to the create your account page we
had 94 move on so we didn't have anybody
enter in the create your account page we
didn't have anybody leave to create your
account page so if 82 82 create your
account and then we have 82 move on to
the payment page so that's a hundred
percent okay we have one exit so we have
81 that proceeded to be on the payment
page which was purchase so 81 of 82 is
and we started with 84. so that gave us
Plus plus the 24 that we accumulated
along the way so that gave us a 75
percent funnel conversion rate so 75
percent of the people who entered in the
funnel went on to purchase okay so don't
be confused with the overall e-commerce
conversion rate so 75 is the funnel
conversion rate the overall conversion
rate for this particular goal is
18.45 over this particular period of
time why because that takes into account
all sessions that have won to the
website so 18 of all traffic went on to
convert but those that did go into the
final 75 percent converted so that's a
look at the funnel so if you set up a
funnel that's what it's going to look
like you have the option to measure
everything from step one and Beyond or
measure as traffic goes in and out of
the funnel so the purpose of this is
we're going to be able to see see where
traffic drops off how effective our
funnel is what pages we need to address
in that funnel okay so that's the whole
point of the funnel and the funnel is
available with the destination URL goal
so if I go back to admin if I go back to
goals Under The View I can actually see
what that funnel looks like so here we
chose regular expression so this is what
the URL is okay you can see our funnel
in each of the steps we have set up
notice we're using regular Expressions
here and then if we verify this goal we
could see over the past seven days 19
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working in this particular
with this particular goal because we do
have a conversion rate okay so that's
the destination URL goals let's now talk
about the other three types of goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about is pages per session so if you're
you're not sure what type of goal to set
up for your website at the very least
you should try and set up either
duration related goal or pages per
session related goal so let's talk about
the pages per session so basically what
this goal is going to allow us to
measure is for example if we set the
goal to three pages per session then
we're going to be able to measure if how
many people went to the site and looked
at three pages per session so let's take
a look at that goal so if I open up the
goal here I can see three pages per
session is what we're naming it so
basically what we're asking analytics to
do is anything greater than two pages
which would be three and Beyond count as
a goal so if anybody comes to the site
looks at more than two pages three pages
or more then it's going to count as a
goal and so here we can verify it so if
we verified over the last seven days we
could see a 4.12 conversion rate and
that tells me that four percent of my
traffic over the last seven days looked
at at least three pages or more so
you're probably asking yourself well
what number should I put in for the
actual variable so in this case we see
two well what you want to do is you want
to look at on average let's just say
year to date you want to make sure you
have statistical significance so you
want to look at a period of time so if
you go to analytics go to audience okay
and then if you go to overview and if I
change my date range to year to date I
could see on average right now I have
1.21 pages per session so that's on
average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically measure at
a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do is get
people to stay on the site longer look
at Pages more during their session so
look at more pages and so we want to be
able to see what segment of the audience
is looking at more pages what channels
driving traffic that's looking at more
pages what pages are contributing to
more pages per session so the whole idea
is you want to hone in on what your goal
is and see what's working and then see
what's not working so you can make
adjustments the whole idea be on Google
analytics is to improves website
performance and so if our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just 2 it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're going to choose three now you
can choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 I
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and I probably wouldn't choose
two so I'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in Google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session we can measure how
long somebody stays on the website and
we could set up a goal for that so in
this case I have a goal set for one
minute 30 seconds so my goal type is
duration so if I click continue then
basically I'm asking analytics in this
case anybody who stays more than one
minute and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here I can see a
minute and seven so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with two minutes so again the
whole point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here I could see over the last
seven days if I verify this particular
goal I can see eight percent of my
traffic over the last seven days stayed
on the site at least one minute and 31
seconds okay they stay greater than one
minute and thirty and so the whole point
is you can hone in because this is a
goal I can go in this is goal okay this
is a goal here and so I could see that
this is gold 13. so now I can go to
acquisition as an example I can go to
channels as an example since this is I
go this is goal 13 so that would be in
goal set three so I can actually see
what channel is basically driving that
goal okay in other words what channel is
driving traffic that is staying on the
side at least one minute 30 seconds and
so that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here I can see we have
a over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here I could see for
example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here I could see social
media has a ten percent so I could see
that or people coming from organic
search are staying on the site longer or
they're looking at more pages than any
other channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
Dimension just because his engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of Engagement
related goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available in Google analytics is an
event so if you click on new goal
include custom click continue you have
the option to choose an event so an
event is something that you can measure
on your website that analytics can't
measure by default so if you want to
measure PDF downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link I mean you can
measure pretty much anything with an
event then you want to be able to turn
that event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so we need to identify that
event so if I go to for example this
particular website here and I want to
measure how many times somebody clicks
on the Donate Now button well if I met I
can measure that as an event so when you
set up an event in analytics you have to
actually assign a category and an action
for that event so that's the first thing
you need to do when you identify an
event or let it go first you need to set
up the event in order to set up the
event you need to assign a category in
action okay so once you identify what
you want to track as an event on your
website you're actually going to go on a
tag manager or have your web Master go
on a tag manager and set up a tag and in
that tag they're going to assign that
particular category in action and so
here you can see we have this set up our
category is named donate now and our
action is click and that's what we want
to do we want to measure how many people
click on that donate Now button so
anytime somebody does that then the
category donate now is going to appear
in analytics with the action click so
when you actually do set up an event you
can go into analytics and you could test
that event so if I go to the website and
I click donate now Okay the reason why I
have this as an event is because I'm
taking to a third-party website to
handle the donations so here I can go
into analytics and now I can see a
category is being fired for header
donate with the action click so that's
my category and that's my action so that
category in action is what is firing
after somebody clicks on the Donate Now
button so if I want to turn this event
into a goal I can easily do that now
that I've set up the event now that I've
identified the category in action I want
to go back to admin and set up the event
with these parameters in place so just
turns out we already have the goal set
up so let's go through how this goal is
set up so first we chose custom we chose
event we gave it a name it has the best
practice when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
I would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals in your reporting you
know it's an event so I'm going to click
continue and now that I've actually have
set up the event already in Google tag
manager I giving it a category give it
an action okay see here you can see we
have a regular expression set up so
anything with the header donate or
donate is going to fire this goal so
over the last seven days I have a 0.81
conversion rate okay I could have easily
put in equals two and put in whatever
the action what or the category which is
donate now or I could have put action
equals click I could have done that as
well so let me show you another example
here so if I do this custom continue
events donate now here's my goal ID it's
going to be an event so all I need to do
is put in the category in action so
donate now and then click so that's all
I have to do and that's my goal so I can
verify it okay to see if anybody's fired
it and basically that's what I need to
do to turn that event into to a goal
okay so you need to set up for an event
first you need to identify the event set
it up and Google tag manager which is
another platform and once you've done
that then you have your category in
action once you have your category in
action you're again going to go into
analytics and then simply put in that
category in action into the appropriate
fields to set up your event related goal
now all events don't have to be turned
into a goal if you actually do set up an
event and you're not worthy of a goal
meaning it's not a kpi or a dozen align
with your business goals well don't fret
you can always just go to behavior okay
you can always go to events you can
always go to overview and measure your
events that way so here you can see all
of our events that are fired now we do
have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we we convert that
particular event into a goal okay if
it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under Behavior so the
point I'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
Google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is a
category all you need is that action and
so so one final note on that event
related goal just like any other goal
you can add a value okay so if I have an
event set up I can choose to add a value
here or in Google tag manager if I've
assigned a value to that event so if I
go back to the actual event and Google
tag manager you can see I have a value
set up for one dollar then I could just
go into analytics and say you know what
I already have the value added so go
ahead and use the value added in Google
tag manager okay so I'm going to choose
yes now if I choose no I have the option
to add the value here just like I would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related go you can
add the value right into the tag in
Google tag manager just as I've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and measure any
Dimension against that particular goal
so here I can see e newsletter sign ups
by Channel I can go into another goal
set here I can see contact form
submissions okay I can see what
particular channels driving contact form
submissions okay so just know that you
can align a goal against any Dimension
so if you have e-commerce you don't have
to set up for goal for that that's
separate but if you want to take a look
at your goals and analytics and on its
own you can just go to conversions goals
overview here I can actually get a good
sense of how my goals are performing
over a period of time so again if I
choose for example year to date now I
could see based on the goals I've set up
how many total goal completions value
which takes into account the value we've
added into these goals okay the total
conversion rate and here I can see it
broken down by the goal I actually have
set up and I can see it by Page or I
could see it by Source a medium so I
could see Google organic is driving the
most gold completions then Google CPC
direct and then I could see some others
in here as well out contributing to
goals now I do want to point your
attention to another report in Google
analytics that does take into account
goals and that's multi-channel funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels if I go to
assistant conversions I can actually see
what channel in this example is
assisting with the conversions I've set
up and so what do we mean by assistive
conversions well that means that if a
channel let's just say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert when it arrived
at the website and left but it came back
a week later via another Channel let's
just say email and when they came back
via email they did convert during that
session well what analytics does is they
give an assist to organic search because
they help Drive the traffic to the
website so it's similar to the game of
basketball if I have the ball and I pass
it to my colleague and my colleagues the
one who scores because they had the ball
last well they get the credit for the
point I.E the conversion but I get an
assist and so analytics works the same
way they're always going to give credit
to the last click or direct conversion
but they will give credits to the
channel in this case that assisted with
the conversion so that's under assistive
inversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if I want to hone
in on say the Donate clicks only then
I'm going to be able to see what
contributed to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that I think is
important so after you set up your goals
you can actually see what channels in
this particular example help to Drive
conversions again this is year to date
so I can see all the different
combinations of channels that work
together to contribute to a conversion
so again I can choose a specific goal or
I can choose all my goals so those two
reports are under multi-channel
funneling there's also another report
that I think is good that's time lag
meaning how long did it actually take
somebody to convert so here you can see
most of our conversions 265 year-to-date
happen on the day somebody arrived on
the website but I could see I did get
some conversions a day later two days
later Etc so you have time lag top
conversion pass assistant conversions
they're all under multi-channel
funneling and they're all available
after you set up at least one goal and
so if you're not sure what goal to set
up okay don't fret you can always at
least set up an engagement related goal
so that's available to you duration
pages per session you also have
destination and event tracking and
they're all available to you you have 20
available per view now if you're not
quite sure exactly what type of goal to
set up there is an option available in
analytics and that's the gallery so you
can always import a goal from the
gallery so in other words we could take
a look at what other people have set up
in terms of goals so you just have to
click on the button import from gallery
and it'll take you to the gallery and
you'll be able to see what are the goals
others have set up today we're going to
talk about how to set up event tracking
in Google analytics so let's get started
so many of you out there have a website
similar to the one I'm looking at now
this is a non-profit that I work with
I'm a foundation and like this website
and probably like your web website you
probably have some interactivity on
there that needs to be tracked for
example buttons uh if you have buttons
like this one that says donate or
newsletter sign up or there's a PDF
download or a video that needs to be you
know tracked based on the amount of
people who click on the play button so I
mean all sorts of inter activity on a
website have you ever wondered how to
track that well there is a way to track
that because by default Google analytics
can't track interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you want to attract
well you're going to need event tracking
and if you're in analytics and you're
always wandering around the data and you
happen to find yourself under events
well if you want events on your website
and you want data to populate under
Behavior top event events you're going
to need to set up event tracking so
event tracking is a two-part process and
we're going to talk about that two-part
process the first part of that is to
identify what you want to track okay so
if we go back to our example website
here I'm a foundation again we noted
there's a lot to track here we gotta
donate now Bob we got a newsletter sign
up we have some social icons okay we got
a donate Now button here we got a play
button here got all sorts of
interactivity you know we got a button
here that says you know purchase tickets
for an upcoming event I can go
throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
Google analytics by default is only
going to track page view data meaning
how somebody got to your website what
page they looked at how long they stayed
on that page what page they left from
more or less they're timing how long
somebody stays on the website and what
pages they look at so there's more to a
website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the Donate now but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one identify what
you want to track okay so there's a lot
we want to track we're just going to use
one example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate Now button okay
so this donate Now button we want to
track now we have a newsletter sign up
we have Facebook and and that's fine you
could track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the Donate Now
button what's focused on the donating
Now button then we'll come back and
start tracking these other things but
this is what we want to track to start
out with okay so step one identify what
you want to track now when it comes to
tracking events on a website you want to
identify those events so we did that by
choosing this donate Now button now once
we identify what we want to track we
need to assign two parameters for that
event so with event tracking you have
three parameters but one is actually
optional so you have two mandatory
parameters that you have to assign to
everything you want to track on your
website and that's the category and then
the action so event label or label is
the third parameter but again that's
optional okay so basically when we
identify an event on our website we want
to assign it a category and an action
okay so why do we want to assign it a
category in an action because when we're
in analytics under Behavior under events
top events we could see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if I click on any one of these
Dimensions I'm going to be able to see
some of the parameters I've entered in
for previous events I'm tracking okay so
the whole idea is you want to be able to
group different events together into a
category and assign an action and assign
a label to it that's really what you're
doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I wanted to or I can create
a separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you how you organize
your categories because basically all
you're doing is giving a name to what
you're trying to track and the name is
equivalent to a category so in this case
the Donate Now button is very important
I'm just going to call it category head
or donate now I need to give an action
to each category and so in this case I'm
just going to say click because that's
what the action is doing it's it's
somebody's taking the action of clicking
now if it's a video and it's a play
button I can assign an action of play
it's up to you whatever you name these
parameters you just need to be organized
and methodical about what you name it
that's all and so in this case header
donate and then click okay and so that's
our category in action and so that's
clearly step two so step one identify
what you want to track step two assign a
category action and or label but
remember label is optional so if we go
back in analytics here I could see some
categories and if I click on action I
can see some actions that I've named now
step three so we've identified in step
one what we want to track we've assigned
a category in action so step three is
going into Google tag manager to set up
the event okay so if you're not familiar
with Google tag manager then you can
easily just you know do a Google search
for Google tag manager and basically
you'll have all sorts of information on
it there's a good video overview of tag
manager here that you can watch so tag
manager basically is what we want to use
to set up event tracking now tag
managers use for a lot of different
things but the main thing we're doing
here is setting up an event for our
website and so I'm logged in to the same
email address I'm using for analytics
okay so now I'm in tag manager and I
want to set up my event for this donate
Now button so what do I need to do well
for every event I want to set up I need
to set up a tag okay so if I go to tags
I can see I already have some tags set
up and some of these are events and so
when you actually set up a tag I
recommend having a naming convention so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it GA Dash event
Dash whatever it is we're trying to set
up and so in this case we want to set up
a new tag for the Donate Now button on
our website so we're in Google tag
manager because tag manager is what's
going to fire that event so if I click
on new okay and I click on tag
configuration I'm going to choose Google
analytics and then I'm going to choose
event as my track type so we want the
data to show up in Google analytics and
we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a page we're tracking an event
and so now remember in step two you
identified what you want to call that
category you identify what you want to
call that action action and you have
some optional parameters like label so
first things first header donates the
name of our category and our action is
click and if you want to add in a label
and a value so if you want to sign a
value you can if you want to add in a
label you can okay those are optional so
you just need to focus on category in
action and then the last setting here
that's probably worth mentioning is a
non-interaction hit okay so this is
automatically set to false and why is it
set to false because it's a
non-interaction no that's false we want
this event if somebody clicks on the
header donate to be an interaction so
for example if I land on this page here
and I click on that donate Now button
that I'm tracking as an event and I
actually leave the site because I have
my settings set to false I want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is now not going to count a
bounce if I change it to true so from
false to true then that means it is
going to be a non-interaction if
somebody lands on the page and if
somebody clicks on the button so I don't
want it to be a balance I want it to be
an interaction so my advice is leave it
set to false we're going to choose
Google analytics as our setting here
this is our variable for Google
analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're signing a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set default so anytime
the event fires it's going to account as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do to set up the tag in Google tag
manager now if somebody else is setting
up the tag for you then again you want
to revert to step two you want to be
able to give that person the appropriate
category action and or label and or
value why because you're the one that's
going to be going into Google analytics
and you're the one that's going to have
to go to behavior events top events and
look for the particular at category in
action and or label so you need to be
able to communicate that information to
whomever is setting up the tag now if
it's you great you already know what it
is because you're entering that
information into tag manager so in this
case I'm going to go ahead and choose a
variable for my label parameter and why
do I want to do that because in tag
manager I have something at my disposal
called variables and variables allow you
to see specifically things that are
being tracked so in this case I chose
pagepath okay so pagepath is a URL and
why did I choose pagepath as my variable
for the parameter label because if
somebody does click on the header donate
button and the header donate button on
our website is on every page so if I go
to the children's page I'm still going
to see that header donate button and so
for me I want to be able to see what
page somebody clicked on that hit or
donate button and so this allows me to
actually see in Google analytics what
page somebody clicked on the header
donate Now button and so now if I go
back to GTM Google tag manager I have a
category I have an action and I have a
label which is a variable okay so note
that in Google tag manager you have a
lot of different variables at your
disposal and variables are there to help
you identify specifically what is being
tracked so take a look at all the
variables at your disposal and tag
manager in this example I'm using page
path so now once you set up your tag
pretty straightforward again tag types
Google analytics track type is event you
are assigning the category action end or
label and or value you're changing or
leaving the default in place for
non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for Google
analytics which is your property ID so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here I'm going to
look at a trigger I've already set up
for this this particular event and so if
I click on it I'll be able to see that
what it is it's a click on some links
not all links but some links I'm
actually saying Hey Google tag manager
fire this event when the click ID equals
header donate button now it just so
happens that if somebody did click on
this donate Now button they're gonna go
to another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager I
could have set the trigger to equal URL
equal instead of Click ID I could have
said URL equal
networkforgood.com so that could have
been my Logic for my trigger in this
case I decided to go with the click ID
and so in this case that button has an
ID associated with it called header
donate button so if you wanted to use
click ID for your event for your button
you could simply just go to the website
you can right click on that button and
click inspect element and so when I
actually inspect the element I can see
now the button here you can see it's
highlighted in the upper Pane and in the
lower pane I can see where it's linking
to it's linking to networkforgood.com
but here you can see if I hone in a
little it I could see ID equals header
Dash donate dash button so that's the
click ID notice there's also a class I
could have set the trigger to equal this
class or again I could have set the
trigger to equal the URL or the page
that this button is pointing to I could
have chosen any one of those but I
decided to go with the ID so this is the
ID I chose and that's the ID I have in
my trigger okay so that is what's going
to fire that event so if somebody clicks
on a button that equals header Dash
donate dash button it's going to fire
that event which is going to equal
category header donate action click and
then the label is going to be page path
so now that we've set up our events we
want to test to see if it actually works
so there's two ways to go about testing
an event and the first way is through
Google analytics so if we go to Google
analytics and then we go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so let's go
ahead and go to and test this and go to
the website so if I go here for example
and I click on omagar alumni okay so if
I click on that you can see I'm under
our family and if I click on that button
then go back to analytics and look at
real time I should be able to see this
event fire so if I click on it I'm going
to go to network for good now if I go
back to analytics here in real time
under real time under events per second
I can see that event firing category
equals header donate the action equals
click now if I click on the category
here I can see the label the label
remember was page path and here you can
see this event fired on the our family
page which was the page I was just on so
that's one way to test to see if your
event works and in this case analytics
recognize the event so it works it fired
and so therefore it's going to show up
under Behavior under events you can go
under overview or top events okay and
what am I going to look for in this case
I'm going to look for header donate okay
if I click on hit or donate as my
category I'm going to be able to see my
action and if I click on action I'll be
able to see my label in this case home
page and then later on when the data
propagates in analytics I'll be able to
see under label the page that I clicked
on that header donate button which is
slash our family okay the second way in
which you can test to see if an event
fires is if you preview so if I click on
preview in tag manager okay I'm going to
go into preview mode okay in preview
mode allows you to see in analytics and
tag manager and on the website what tags
are firing so here I could see I'm in
preview mode now so I'm going to go to
the website and I'm going to refresh and
in my browser same browser I'm using for
tag manager I can see the tags that are
being fired on this page already okay
because I'm in preview mode so here I
could see remarketing I could see page
views I could see Google optimize I
could see some tags that are already
firing on this page now if I click on
this button here by holding down my
shift command and then click on that
button I'll be able to see that the tag
fired in preview mode there's my event
header donate and I can see it fired so
now I can see it fired in the preview
mode so in addition to Google analytics
in preview mode I could see that that
tag is fired and I know that it's
working so there you have it you have
two ways to test to see if the event
fires again you have real time in
analytics okay so in real time if you
just go up to real time all you need to
do is go down to events go to your
website click on the button if you see
it firing in real time then you know it
works the second version or second way
to test your event is through the
preview mode okay if you see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working okay so let's rehash our steps
first step is we want to be able to
identify what we want to track okay so
it could be this newsletter sign up it
could be click on a Facebook it could be
anything we want to be able to track an
image a click on a CTA button whatever
we want to track identify it second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in Google analytics remember label is
optional variable or excuse me value is
optional third step go into tag manager
actually set up your tag and your
trigger so if you set up a tag and it's
an event name it GA Dash events that way
you can see in your list of tags and tag
manager what event tracking you have
already set up so when you set up your
tag you set up your trigger your trigger
is based on logic that can be a URL it
can be a click ID it can be a class ID
whatever you want to use to fire that
event and then once you do that you want
to test it you could test it in GTM or
you could test it in Google analytics if
it doesn't fire you want to tweak your
trigger if it does fire then great and
then one thing I would recommend is if
you're setting up various events for
your website that's the best practice
what I would recommend is set up a
spreadsheet and in that spreadsheet you
know you want to put a note what's
firing what are you doing to fire it
could be in this case someone somebody
clicks on the Donate Now button in the
header you want to put the tag name in
here the type okay then you want to
record your category action and label
and then the great thing about events is
you could turn those events into goals
and that's as simple as going back into
analytics okay so if I go in analytics
and I go to admin and I go to go goals
if you set up a new goal okay all you
need to do is choose custom click
continue you're going to choose event as
your goal name and then from a naming
perspective in Google analytics for your
goal I would definitely put event first
and then click on header donate okay so
if I click now continue what is my
category it's equal to head or donate my
action is click and so I can verify to
see if this is working and here I can
see in analytics that the goal would
have a 0.22 conversion rate so that
tells me that the goal is working and I
can turn this event into a goal and when
you turn something into a goal in
analytics then you can measure it across
all dimensions that's what I would
recommend if the event is equal to a kpi
or business goal or it's of importance
it's something you really want to
measure okay it's just a click say on a
Facebook button I wouldn't recommend
setting that up as a goal okay so once
you've set up your event you recorded it
in your spreadsheet it's firing you want
to be able to then go back into Behavior
back into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if I choose my date range
here I can just go to here to date so
here I can see my enter donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notice in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same same
session so if I go to the Yama
Foundation website okay I can click on
that donate Now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because in some cases
users May click on the button more than
once in the same session and so here I
can see total events unique events and
if I added a value to that event I
should be able to see it here so if I
added a dollar as an example to this
particular event because it had 164
unique events I should be able to see
164 as my value but since I see Zero
that means that I did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average I have have
per event so it's taking into account
the number of or the value the total
value divided by the total number of
unique page views or sessions and so
because I don't have value I'm not going
to have average value but here you can
see because value is optional here I can
at least see how many events or how many
clicks I receive for a particular button
again it could be a video if I clicked
on this video as an example I can see
how many people actually started it I
could see the unique and the total
events and if I click on label if I have
a label assigned then I'll be able to
see what page triggered that event so if
we go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary Dimension here we
can see the home page had the most
unique events been followed by the
children's page the contact form Etc so
what you you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here I can see the home page
has accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would look at the data in Google
analytics under Behavior under events
and then under top events or overview is
where you can start analyzing your event
tracking so first you need to do
identify it assign a category action
enter label set up that tag and Trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're gonna go to
analyze have you ever wondered what will
happen if the pages of your website are
not visible in the search engines
definitely this can be the most scary
thought you ever had
but due to lack of technical knowledge
this is happening in the real world with
the newbies in the SEO industry
well for these beginners this video is
the opportunity and the solution to your
problems
to get your Pages search and appear in
Google search results
it is important that these pages
are indexed in Google
and to get the web pages indexed Google
search console or search console is the
One-Stop solution
before we dive deep into this topic
consider subscribing to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn
in this video we are going to cover all
the basics of search console like what
is search console and its importance
the working of search console
the Google search console complete guide
for 2022
that covers all the basics of Google
search console
we will discuss about the companies
hiring the candidates with required
skill sets
in search console in SEO industry
section
and we will end this session by knowing
how search console will continue to be
in action for many more years
so dear Learners if you want to get
upskilled for free then do give it a try
for simply learns advanced search engine
optimization program
which comes with a completion
certificate and in-depth knowledge about
SEO and SEO techniques
check this course details from the link
in the description box below
so let's start by knowing what is search
console
Google search console formerly known as
Google webmaster tool is a web service
provided by Google Developers
Google search console is mainly
responsible for optimizing a website for
its visibility
indexing website detecting crawl errors
Etc
after understanding what is Google
search console
now we need to focus on why search
console is an important part of search
engine optimization
a website's technicalities are directly
or indirectly related to search console
consider you have created a website for
your business
but from past few weeks your website is
not visible in search result Pages here
search console comes into action
there is a possibility that searched
engine crawlers are not able to crawl
your website thus it is not visible in
the search result pages
to make crawlers crawl your website you
will need to optimize your website using
search console
some other technical aspects of search
console includes
fixing indexing problems
sending the updated content or Pages for
indexing
generating search traffic reports
generating alerts if there are any
issues related to indexing or any other
issue gets the list of sites linking to
your website keep the track of mobile
usability
amp pages
and more
so now it is the right time to
understand how search console works
but before we begin this topic have a
look at the range of courses of digital
marketings and search engine
optimization from skill up by simply
learn you can get the link in the
description box below so now I have a
question for you what will you do at
first if your web page fails to appear
in search result pages
well let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below
stay tuned with this video Even though
if you don't have the answer right now
by the end of this video you will surely
able to answer this question so let's
get started by knowing how search
console works
to understand the working of search
console it is necessary to have a
detailed knowledge about how search
engine works search engines mainly Works
in three steps crawling indexing and
ranking let's have a look at each step
one by one
so first let's start with crawling
search engines are hungry for content
and so they send Web spiders or web
crawlers also known as robots or search
engine Bots to discover new content or
any updated content
content can be an image a web page a
video or anything else present on the
web this process is known as crawling
now let's know about indexing
as soon as the crawler discover the
updated content or new content
these web crawlers start storing the
URLs of the content into the search
index or web index this process is known
as indexing once the content is indexed
it starts appearing in the search result
pages
when a user enters a search query the
most relevant results are taken from the
index
and displayed in the form of most
relevant to least relevant in the search
result Pages this process is known as
ranking now that we have gained
knowledge about how search engine works
here I have a question for you
choose the correct option with respect
to working of search engines
you need to choose the option for all
the steps of how search engines work
option A indexing crawling ranking
option b ranking indexing crawling
option C crawling indexing ranking and
option D crawling ranking and indexing
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
now let's get started by learning how
search console actually works
search console is a primary source of
information that helps search engine
Bots to crawl index and rank the pages
of your website
thereby allowing the website owners to
monitor the health of your website
all you need to do is integrate search
console with your website and get the
ownership
allow the search engine Bots to crawl
your website and index the pages also
don't forget to submit your website
sitemap to search engines submitting
sitemaps helps the crawler to discover
more pages of your website
thereby understanding your site's
architecture
we will know how it is done in the
upcoming part of the video
also you need to keep an eye on the
errors suggested by search console and
solve them else it may harm the ranking
of your website
now let me remind you that all the
reports that are generated in search
console are based on the activity of the
web Crawlers on your website now let's
understand various parameters and
terminologies from search console
to get a complete understanding of this
webmaster tool
so without any further delay let's start
understanding the basic terminologies of
Google search console and how they work
and improve your website's health
the first one we have is performance
reports
Google search console provides two types
of performance report search reports and
discover reports
let's first understand about search
reports
search reports help to analyze the
search performance of your website
search performance reports include
metrics and dimensions
so let's first focus on metrics
here there are four types of metrics as
you can see in this image
the metrics include the total clicks or
I must say clicks Impressions average
CTR and average position
Impressions provides the data on how
many times your websites appears in the
search results
as you can see here
the graph shows the number of times this
website has appeared in the search
results the next metric we have is
clicks
clicks provide the data on the total
number of times users clicked from the
search results and reached your website
the graph below shows the number of
times the users have clicked from search
results and they have arrived on any
page of my website so suppose if here is
a number 200 so we can definitely get an
idea
for very number of dates number of dates
provided on the x-axis which shows that
how many times the user has clicked and
arrived on the website and the number
where is varies from between like 200
250 300 and in between 250 to 300.
and the next metric we have is average
CTR average CTR or click-through rate is
the percentage of Impressions that
results in clicks
in the same manner the graph below shows
or the average CTR for various different
dates
the next metric we have is average
position the average position represents
the data about the average position of
the sites in the search results
it is possible that your website is
ranking today at number one position so
it may rank tomorrow at 3 some other day
at 4 some other day at 9 or 10 and again
it may rank to the one so this data
actually provides the detail about the
average position uh which your website
frequently ranks at so that is if it is
ranking at one two and three in between
one two and three positions so the
average position may be two
now understanding about the dimensions
dimensions are the data attribute that
defines who did something on your site
or from where
here is the list of dimensions on which
the dimension performance reports are
generated that is
countries Pages queries devices search
appearance and dates
the dimension country suggests the
country from which the search came as
you can see here from the left column
you can get the list of number of
countries from the right side you can
get the idea about the clicks impression
ctrn position that is all the metrics
related to that query
from which the search came from or from
that location
or whatever the activity has happened
from that location next we have is the
dimensions pages
Pages show the pages clicked by user or
a page that is viewed on a search so
this this actually you get the reports
from the search console in the form of
the links where you get the link which
is the exact page that is viewed on the
search
if there exists duplicate pages on the
site then only one canonical page or
canonical link will be displayed by the
search engines out of the number of
duplicate pages so basically canonical
links are those links uh like if there
are suppose there is a one original page
and there are two three duplicate page
of the same page so what happens uh the
original page gains the canonical link
and uh this page has more value than the
duplicate pages
so whenever the search engine will crawl
your website all the duplicate pages may
be ignored and all its link juice or
link Equity or anything will be
completely taken for the original page
moving ahead to queries
queries provide the query string that
users search on the Google search
console
so Suppose there is a website it says
suppose uh let's talk about the simply
learn website so suppose a user may add
as Java course and simply learn websites
appears at second or third position so
this query
say suppose user clicks on the website
and reaches the website this query Java
course on simply learn or Java course
will add in the search console showing
that the user has reached to your
website using this query Java course and
again all the list of the queries
appears towards the left and all the
matrixes for that query like clicks
impression CTR and its average position
is appeared towards the right in the
search console now talking about the
search appearance search appearance
helps in grouping the data as per the
search result type or by the feature so
you can get here the number of search
appearance and again the same metrics as
with respect to the search appearance
criteria next let's move towards the
dates
dates groups of data as per the dates
according to the public time zones now
let's have a look over the Discover
performance report
now here you must be thinking about how
the search is different from discover
yes search and discover follow different
approaches users enter a query to find a
required information with search
whereas discover shows the content based
on what result will be best match for
your query as per the Google's automated
system
now coming to the Discover performance
report as per Google's guidelines
discover performance reports are visible
only if your website has a minimum
threshold of impressions in discover
now moving to another important
parameter of search console which is URL
inspection
URL inspection is an interesting tool in
the search console this tool allows you
to inspect whether the URL is indexable
or not
some main functions of this tool
includes
checking the current status of the URL
inspecting live URLs requesting indexing
for a URL
viewing Pages rendered version viewing
crawl Pages viewing tested Pages
Etc
in order to check the index status of
URL open the URL inspection tool
and add the complete URL
for which we need to know its indexing
status
now to understand the results check the
present status if it shows that URL is
on Google as you can see in the screen
this means that URL qualifies Google's
criteria and is eligible to appear in
search results
if it shows URL is not on Google then
the URL does not qualify the Google's
criteria and is not eligible to appear
in search results
you can check more details like URL
Discovery crawl and indexing information
from the page availability tab
click on the crawl page to see the
information about the HTTP request and
response if you find that the link is
disabled just hover over the page to
check the reason
now coming to the live URL test
it is helpful to test the live URLs and
check if it is capable of being indexed
it proves helpful when you update your
page and want to compare it with its
latest indexed version just to bring it
to your notice
a life test will only confirm whether
the Google crawler can access your page
for indexing but it doesn't assure that
your page will be included in the Google
index altogether with the help of index
coverage report one can find the list of
URLs which includes the URLs Google has
found on your website the URLs that have
been indexed and identify if any
indexing problem have occurred next we
move ahead to understand about the site
Maps
a site map is the file that contains all
the information of pages on your website
this helps search engine crawlers to
crawl your website and understand your
website structure
and helps them to index the pages more
efficiently more the crawler indexes
your pages higher the chances for the
pages of your website to appear in the
search results
with the help of site maps you can
provide information about various
contents like Pages videos images
Etc as you can understand a sitemap
plays an important role in indexing
process
you must be curious to know how we can
create and submit a sitemap to search
engines
before we understand this process make
sure that all pages of your website are
linked in an appropriate manner with
each other thereby maintaining a healthy
site structure
a site map can be created in XML format
RSS format or in text format
it can be Auto generated or created
manually as well
most commonly used site map is XML
following is an example of an XML
sitemap
this is the simplest version of the site
map that we are representing here you
can submit a site map to the sitemap
reports in the search console
however site Maps can also be submitted
through robots.txt file let's understand
about robots.txt file
so let's understand the robots.txt file
in short
robots.txt file notifies the web
Crawlers
about the URLs that they can access on
the website as there are lots of search
engines there exists different web
crawlers thus there is a possibility
that some web crawlers may not obey the
instructions from the robots.txt file it
is necessary to know how to use the
proper syntax as different crawlers
understand syntax differently
thus there are chances that some web
crawlers might fail to understand the
instructions from the robots.txt file
a page can be indexed even if it is
disallowed from the robots.txt file if
it is linked to other site
next let's know what enhancement reports
are
all the rich results status reports are
displayed under the enhancement tab
so let's know more about rich results
these type of results are known as Rich
results in serps so basically Rich
results can be any search results other
than the traditional Blue Links for
example image results carousels
Etc
you can check whether the pages from
your website support Rich results or not
using the rich result test tool provided
by Google Developers
now understanding the rich results
status report the enhancement tab
contains separate reports for Rich
result type some rich results report
types are listed below that are
breadcrumbs
education q a event FAQ fact check
guided recipe how to image license
job posting
learning video
review Snippets
Etc
Rich results status reports consist of
summary page and Details page
the summary page mainly consists of
Errors useful items found on your
website warnings
Etc The Details page consists of the
information about the issues when it was
detected item type when was the page
last crawled
Etc before we understand how to fix
error in search console it is is
important to understand the status of
each page as reported by search console
each page has any of the following
status error warning excluded and valid
if the status of the page is valid it
means the page has successfully indexed
the status of the page appears to be
excluded if one purposefully wants the
page not to be indexed
or a page is blocked by robots.txt file
for example setting the meta tag to no
index warnings majorly appears when the
page of your website is indexed
but there are some issues with the page
which need your attention and have to be
resolved as soon as possible
if the page status is error then there
is a need to pay a detailed attention
over the issues in the page as these
issues prevent the page from getting
indexed
let's discuss about the errors in detail
and how we can fix them
some popular errors from the search
console are listed below
that is the redirect error server error
submitted URLs blocked by robots.txt URL
marked as no index submitted URL is a
soft poor not poor four not four or page
not found error
so let's first know about the redirect
error some redirect error
that search console shows up are the
redirect chain that was too long
redirect true redirect URL that exits
maximum URL length and bad or empty URL
in the redirect chain
so all these error means that the
redirections are not working properly
and so there is a need to fix them so
suppose for example you have added too
many redirects from one page to another
so in this scenario
search engine Bots find it a waste of
time to crawl again and again to the
same redirections and at that time the
search engine crawlers or search engine
boards ignore those URLs or redirections
so in such cases you need to fix those
redirection to a single URL
the next we have is server error
the server returns 5xx error when it
fails to fulfill a valid request this
error mainly conveys that something is
wrong with your website server all you
need to do is reach out to your hosting
services and inform them about the issue
and make sure it gets resolved as soon
as possible
the next one we have is submitted URL
blocked by robots.txt to resolve this
issue you need to remove the line of
code from the robot.txt file that
restricts Google from crawling the
respective page the next we have is URL
marked as no index
when a URL is marked as no index it
sends the signal to crawlers that this
page is not meant to be crawled or this
page is not meant to be indexed if you
want this page to be indexed check the
metadata and remove the no index
attribute
to allow the Crawlers to crawl the URL
now let's understand about the error
submitted URL is a soft 404 and 4 not 4
or page not found error whenever a web
page load server returns a 200 signal
showing the success status code soft4
Note 4 is a condition in which server
returns 200 success status code and the
page not exist errors simultaneously
this is considered to be a bad user
experience
this error can be solved simply by
redirecting this page to any relevant
URL
or the home page of the website
talking about 404 or page not found
error this error mainly occurs
when you delete the page from your
website but the URL of the page still
exists in the site map
this error can be solved by simply
removing the URL or removing the four
not four URL from the site map or
redirecting the URL to a new page
this will help to avoid the further
errors in near future
we will have a detailed look at other
4xx errors in the upcoming videos
now that we are aware of the basics of
search console let's dive deeper to know
some stats regarding the search console
in the SEO industry
when you're thinking of adding a
business online your website should
fulfill all the technical SEO needs
which can be achieved by Google search
console thus there is a huge demand in
SEO industry for the candidates having
strong knowledge of Google search
console
the average salary of an SEO expert
with the Google search console skills in
US is 53 000 dollars
to 78 000 per annum and that in India
is 2 lakh 76 000 per annum some biggies
in the SEO industry looking for this
skill sets include Accenture Amazon
people group
Eton Etc
so let me know your dream company to
work as an SEO expert in the comment
section below
well if you are looking for the same
opportunity to be a skilled professional
in search engine optimization then you
are at the right place
simply learns search engine optimization
training course
will groom you to become industry ready
SEO specialist check the description box
below to know the complete details of
the course and click on the link to grab
the opportunity search console is for
everyone whether you are a business
owner a marketing specialist a web
developer or a website administrator
Google search console will continue to
be the part of search engine
optimization technique
and will keep on playing a major role in
the maintenance of the website and
Improvement in rankings
here we wrap up this digital marketing
full course if you like this video hit
the like button consider subscribing to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply note
till then keep watching and keep
learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign